GOOD AFTERNOON AND WELCOME.
THIS IS SECOND HEARING A BIT AT
AS JOINT HEARING BETWEEN THE
ASSEMBLY COMMUNICATIONS AND
CONVEYANCE COMMITTEE. AND THE
JOINT COMMITTEE ON EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT HOUSE WHICH WILL
EXAMINE OUR STATE EMERGENCY
RESPONSE I SYSTEMS.
I THIS IS THE SECOND OF A
MEETING THE FIRST YOU MIGHT
RECALL HAPPENED. UP BACK IN
DECEMBER AND IT CAN IN FACT.
DURING THAT TIME.
IMMEDIATELY WHEN WE LEFT THE
MEETING.
WE WE HAD NOTICED AND KNOWN
THAT THERE WAS LARGE WILDFIRE
SPREAD ACROSS SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA WAS A REALLY TIMELY
CONVERSATION.
AT THAT TIME IT IN SOME OF OUR
COLLEAGUES WHO ARE MORE IMPACTED
BY MIGHT SPEAK TO THAT BUT
HUNDREDS OF HOMES AND BUSINESSES
WERE DESTROYED. THOUSANDS WERE
FORCED TO EVACUATE.
INCLUDING MY CO CHAIR HERSELF
AYE I BELIEVE.
I'M FORTY CALIFORNIA'S NOT A.
A STRANGER TO DISASTERS IN WE'VE
NOW KNOW WHAT THE GOVERNOR'S
ECHOED IN OTHERS OF ECHOED IN
THIS BUILDING. THAT UP WHAT WE
ONCE KNEW AS A OCCURRENCE EVERY
NOW AND THEN HAS BECOME THE NEW
NORM AND WE EXPECT.
DISASTERS TO HAPPEN
UNFORTUNATELY AND IT'S NOT A
MATTER OF.
WELL IF IT HAPPENS AT A MATTER
OF WHEN IT HAPPENS AND WE WANT
TO BE A WELL PREPARED.
AND YET NO YET NO EVENT WAS
MORE DRAMATIC AND DEMONSTRATED
IN SOME CASES THE FAILURES OF
EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS AYE THE
NINE ELEVEN IN THE INABILITY OF
OUR FIRST RESPONDERS TO TALK TO
EACH OTHER DURING THAT CRISIS.
I THAT SOCK AND HORRIFIED OUR
NATION.
.
AND ALL THAT WAS ABOUT SEVENTEEN
YEARS AGO WE'VE NOW TAKING A
MAJOR STEPS TOWARD ESTABLISHING
A NATIONWIDE. UP PUBLIC SAFETY
NETWORK.
WITH FIRST NET WHICH WILL BE
DISCUSSING DAY.
BUT SOME ISSUES STILL REMAIN
THAT WE'VE WE'VE GOT TO BE ABLE
TO TACKLE.
WE'VE GOT TO WE'VE WE'VE WANT
TO TALK ABOUT WHAT WE LEARN FROM
OUR EXPERIENCES.
ALREADY WE ARE FOR THE NEXT WALL
FIRE THE NEXT EARTHQUAKE OR THE
NEXT NINE ELEVEN THAT HAPPENS.
OF PARTICULAR INTEREST TO ME.
FOR EXAMPLE IS IS MY DISTRICT
WHICH WILL HOST OF THE OLYMPICS
AND I WOULD LIKE TO TAKE A LOOK
AT WHAT HAPPENED.
IN FAILURE DURING NINE ELEVEN
I'M AND MAYBE WOULD POTENTIALLY
THAT THIS IF IT IF THAT SHOULD
HAPPEN.
IN THE NEAR FUTURE WHAT WE
WOULD DO AND HOW WOULD BE
DEFERRED AS IT RELATES TO.
COMMUNICATING AND FIRST
RESPONDERS.
I AND WHAT RESOURCES THIS PUBLIC
SAFETY OFFICIALS NEED.
TO ACCOMPLISH WHAT WE ASK OF
THEM EVERY DAY.
SO I WANNA THANK ALL OUR
COLLEAGUES OVER HERE TO THE AS A
VERY IMPORTANT I'M HEARING A
ONE.
HANDED OVER THE CO CHAIR FOR A
BRIEF COMMENTS AND WE'LL GO TO
OUR A COLLEAGUES.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SANTIAGO AND I ALSO WANT
TO EXTEND MY WELCOME TO. OUR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS IN OUR
DISTINGUISHED AGAINST WHOM WE OR
FROM WHOM WE WILL HEAR TODAY.
AND PARTICULARLY TO THOSE WHO
TRAVELED TRAVELED UP OF FROM MY
DISTRICT IN.
THE CENTRAL PART OF THE COASTAL
CALIFORNIA AREA. YOU'VE
DISCOVERED IT'S NOT EASY TO GET
HERE FROM THERE BOTA AND SO
BECAUSE OF THAT I AM MOST
APPRECIATIVE THAT YOU ARE
JOINING US.
I REPRESENT THE NINETEEN STATE
SENATE DISTRICT WHICH IS ALL OF
SANTA BARBARA COUNTY AND ALL OF
WESTERN VENTURA COUNTY I ALSO. A
CHEER ROSE WAS MENTIONED OF THE
JOINT LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE ON
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT.
I HAVE HAD THE HONOR OF
ASSURING THAT OF THIS IS NOW THE
FOURTH YEAR WE ALTERNATED
BETWEEN THE HOUSES AS WE DO
WHEN.
LAST YEAR MY COLLEAGUE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RODRIGUEZ WAS THE.
CHAIR FOR THAT TWO YEAR SESSION.
I'M EXCITED TO BE BACK DOING US
BUT HAVE NOTED THAT THINGS
CONTINUE TO. SEEM TO ACCUMULATE
WE'RE NOW.
WE CHOSE TO EXPERIENCE THE.
WORST I THINK FAR. WILDFIRE
SEASON IN CALIFORNIA'S HISTORY
THIS PAST YEAR.
THE FIRES UP IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA IN OCTOBER FIRES
BEFORE THEN THROUGHOUT THE STATE
AND THEN OF COURSE AS. WAS
MENTIONED THE.
THOMAS FIRE WHICH SHOW.
A OCCURRED LITERALLY AN HOUR
AND A HALF AFTER WE GAVEL DOWN
THAT FIRST HEARING ON DECEMBER
FOURTH.
WHICH FOR THE NEXT FORTY DAYS
BURNED ABOUT FOUR HUNDRED AND
FORTY SQUARE MILES.
OF MY DISTRICT.
EVERY INSTRUMENT WAS A FROM
SANTA PAULA TO OF THE HILLS
ABOVE MONNA SETO. AND US WAS
ALSO MENTIONED I WAS ALSO FORCED
TO EVACUATE FOR A PERIOD OF
ABOUT SIX DAYS PERSONALLY SO
THIS.
THIS EXPERIENCES WHEN I ALSO HAD
TO.
TO ENSURE.
PERSONALLY AS WELL AS
PROFESSIONALLY AND CAN TELL YOU
THAT.
WE HAVE GOT TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE ARE PROTECTING OUR
CONSTITUENTS IN OUR STATE TO THE
EXTENT WE CAN WITH THIS KIND OF
NOTICE AND. THE DISCUSSION WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE TODAY SO.
THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT
DISCUSSION AS I MENTIONED IT
CONTINUES THIS IS I THINK THE
FOURTH OR FIFTH HEARING WE'VE
HAD THIS IS THE SECOND WHEN
DEALING WITH OUR EMERGENCY
SYSTEM. AND THESE ARE.
A COLLECTION OUR COMMUNICATION
SYSTEM IS A COLLECTION OF THE
TECHNOLOGIES AND EQUIPMENT. THAT
ALLOW OUR FIRST RESPONDERS TO
COMMUNICATE WITH EACH OTHER
DURING AN EMERGENCY IN ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT WE'VE LEARNED.
IS THAT THE CRITICAL TIME IN
SAVING LIFE AND PROPERTY IS AT
THE BEGINNING OF THESE EVENTS
SO IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT THAT WE
HAVE OUR FIRST RESPONDERS ABLE
TO TALK A TO EACH OTHER.
TODAY WE'RE GOING TO EXAMINE HOW
WELL THAT RESPONDER TO FIRST
RESPONDER PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMUNICATIONS SYSTEM PERFORMS.
AS WAS NOTED.
AND I CAN'T BELIEVE IT'S BEEN
SEVENTEEN YEARS SINCE NINE
ELEVEN.
BECAUSE I WAS HERE IN THE
LEGISLATURE WHEN THAT EVENT
OCCURRED.
.
I'VE TIME REALLY DOES FLY BY.
AND OF COURSE WE LEARNED SADLY
THROUGH THE TRAGEDY THAT WE HAVE
NOT OR HAD NOT AT THAT TIME DONE
ENOUGH. TO MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE
COULD COMMUNICATE TODAY THE
TECHNOLOGY IS SO DIFFERENT WHO
COULD HAVE ENVISIONED SEVENTEEN
YEARS AGO WHAT ARE
COMMUNICATIONS NETWORKS. LOOK
LIKE TODAY SO.
WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO IS EXAMINE
HOW WELL OUR FIRST RESPONDER TO
RESPOND OR SAFETY COMMISSION OF
COMMUNICATION SYSTEM PERFORM?
I AM PARTICULARLY ON HOW WELL
THEY PERFORM DURING OUR RECENT
DISASTERS AND SPECIFICALLY I
THINK WE'RE GONNA TALK QUITE A
BIT ABOUT THAT.
THOMAS FIRE.
ARE HEARING ON DECEMBER FOURTH
FOCUSED ON THE FIRES PRIMARILY
IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA WHERE WE
HAD TO ENORMOUS LOSS OF LIFE AND
OVER EIGHT THOUSAND HOMES AND
STRUCTURES DESTROYED NO I THINK
FORTY FOUR PEOPLE KILLED THERE.
SO.
.
AGAIN.
WE TALK ABOUT THE FIRE OF THE
THOMAS FIRE BUT AFTER THAT AFTER
BREATHING A SIGH OF RELIEF.
JUST FEELING THAT WE HAVE BEEN
EXTRAORDINARILY LUCKY AND
SO BLESSED TO HAVE THE
FIREFIGHTERS WHO WOULD COME.
TO THE VETERAN SANTA BARBARA
AREA EIGHTY FOUR HUNDRED AT ONE
POINT TIME WE HAD PREPARED TO.
FIGHT OFF THE FIRE THAT WAS
JUST BURNING UNCONTROLLABLY AND
WE'RE ABLE TO.
LOSE A A LIMITED NUMBER OF HOMES
AFTER THE FIRED STARTED WE LOST
ABOUT FIVE HUNDRED AND SIXTY IN
ITS EARLIEST STAGES ANOTHERFOUR%
HUNDRED IN. A UNINCORPORATED
PARTS OF VENTURA COUNTY BUT
SAVED MOST OF THE HOMES THAT
WERE VULNERABLE IN SANTA BARBARA
COUNTY.
BECAUSE OF THE EXTRAORDINARY
WORK OF OUR FIRST RESPONDERS AND
THEN ON THE NIGHT OF JUNE BY
JANUARY NINTH WE WERE ALL BACK
IN OUR HOMES FEELING VERY BLAST.
รณ WE HAD THIS UNEXPECTED.
EVENT THAT.
DROPPED BILLION OF MILLIONS I
SHOULD SAY OF CUBIC OF FEET OF
MUD.
THROUGH THE MANSIO AREA THAT
KILLED TWENTY THREE PEOPLE AND.
DECIMATED ONE OF THE TRULY MOST
BEAUTIFUL PLACES IN CALIFORNIA.
ALTHOUGH THEY WOULD COST ME ITS
STILL BEAUTIFUL PLEASE COME AND
VISIT.
AND THEN GO HOME.
BUT JOB IT WE REALLY HAVE A LOT
THAT WE NEED TO CONSIDER BECAUSE
WE ARE IN A TWELVE MONTH FIRE
SEASON WE ARE IN. A NATURE IS
pIN VERY DRAMATIC AND SEVERE
WAYS
AND WE HAVE. WORK TO DO SO I
WANT TO THANK YOU AGAIN CHAIRMAN
SANTIAGO FOR ORGANIZING THIS
HEARING AND I LOOK FORWARD WITH
THE REST OF YOU.
TO THIS CRITICAL DISCUSSION.
I THINK MANAGER I WANNA.
EXTENDER.
CURSE YOU GO BOTH VICE CHAIRS
MISTER RODRIGUEZ AND A MISTER
LACKEY IN ANY PARTICULAR ORDER
IF YOU'D LIKE TO ALSO ON.
DO ANY COMMENTS.
SURE OFFERS MOMENT THINKER
SENATOR JACKSON AND SOME RUMORED
SANTIAGO FOR BRING US TOGETHER.
TO TALK ABOUT VERY IMPORTANT
ISSUE REGARDING COMMUNICATIONS
ESPECIALLY DURING THE DISASTERS
AS WE WHAT OCCURRED LAST YEAR
THE FIRES. BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY
OUR LAST YEAR IN DECEMBER A NO
FLOOD FOLKS AWARE OF. AUTISTIC
CALIFORNIA OPTED TO JOIN THIS
FIRST NET.
KIND OF FEDERAL OF
COMMUNICATING WITH THE MERGER
RESPOND HERS.
AND SEE HOW THAT'S GOING TO
REACT TO WHAT WE CURRENTLY HAVE
THE SYSTEM IN PLACE.
OBVIOUSLY THERE'S GOING TO
PROBABLY A LOT OF CHALLENGES AND
HOW BOTH SYSTEMS WORK TOGETHER.
BUT WHAT'S BORN THAT WE GOT
EVERYBODY TALKING TOGETHER AS
FIRST RESPONDER MYSELF
COMMUNICATIONS ALWAYS A KEY FROM
THE TIME WE GET THE CALL TO THE
TIME WE GET THERE AND. THEN TALK
ABOUT WHAT YOU'RE FACING WHICH
DEAL WITH THEM TOP RESOURCES YOU
NEED SOME LOOKING FORWARD TO A
VERY EVENTFUL DISCUSSION AND HOW
THE SYSTEM WOULD WORK. HERE
INSTEAD OF CALIFORNIA SO THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING US ALL TOGETHER
TALK ABOUT THIS PARTNERSHIP
THANK.
MISTER LUCKY IF IF YOU WISH TO
OF COURSE. BUT ALSO LIKE TO
THINK OF BOTH THE CHAIRS FOR
CONVENING THIS HEARING THIS IS.
COMMUNICATION IS SUCH A PIVOTAL
PART IN THE SUCCESS OF FIRST
RESPONDERS AND.
AS A MEMBER OF THE HYPERTROPHY
TWENTY EIGHT YEARS I COULD SAY
THERE WERE A NUMBER OF INSTANCES
WHERE.
A CONSOLIDATED NETWORK WOULD
HAVE BEEN VERY VERY HELPFUL.
IT IS A.
ONE OF THE CHALLENGES THAT WE
FACE STILL EVEN IN THIS MODERN
DAY TODAY OF OUR INTER
COMMUNICATIONS BETWEEN.
AGENCIES BOTH.
.
FIRE DEPARTMENTS AND EMERGENCY
RESPONDERS AND ALL ASPECTS OF
LAW ENFORCEMENT.
I STILL HAVE SOME LEVEL OF
DIFFICULTY COMMUNICATING WITH
EACH OTHER SO THIS IS A GREAT
REMEDY. AND. SOMETHING I'M
REALLY LOOKING FORWARD TO HEAR
MORE MORE ABOUT AND.
LIKE TO CONGRATULATE.
EIGHTEEN TEA FOR THE FIRST NET
CON CONTRACT THAT THEY WERE ABLE
TO SECURE AND LOOK FORWARD TO
THE GREAT SUCCESSES ARE GOING TO
ENJOY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU HAVE THEIR THAT ANY
OTHER MEMBERS WHO.
WOULD LIKE TO SAVE SOME COMMENTS
ABOUT MISTER COOPER.
THANK YOU MISTER BRIEF YOU GUYS
A STEPS IN THIS MEETING
IN THE EARLY DEL IN OF THIS AND
AND TALK ABOUT AS A FIRST
RESPONDER FOR THIRTY YEARS.
A CHANCE TO RESPOND SOME FIRES
AND FLOODS OF OFFERING MUTUALLY
DO MY TIME THE SECOND A COUNTY.
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT AND AN
INABILITY AS IMPORTANT AS WILL
REDUNDANCY IN BACKUP SYSTEMS.
WITHIN OURSELVES GOING UP TO
EIGHT OTHER JURISDICTIONS
AND OUR READERS WOULD WORK BACK
IN THE DAY BECAUSE WE HAVE HAD
THE SAME SYSTEM IT HAS CHANGED
QUITE A BIT.
BUT.
IN MY OPINION.
HERE WE ARE GOING TO THIRTY
YEARS LATER DOING WITH THE SAME
ISSUES.
AS IMPORTANT WE HAVE A SYSTEM
THAT'S GONNA WORK. GET OUR FIRST
RESPONDERS OTHER MATTER WHO YOU
WORK FOR WHETHER IT'S A SURE
FORMER POLICE DEPARTMENT ARE YOU
MASS OR FIRE YOU WILL MAKE SURE
THE SYSTEMS WORK TOGETHER. I
THINK THIS COMMITTEE HAS.
GONNA BURST IDEAS AND HOPEFULLY
CONSUMED SOLUTIONS AND ONCE
AGAIN WAS JUST THE START THERE'S
A LOT OF WORK TO DO ON THIS
SOUTHERN FLORIDA. HEARING
COLLITON COMES MY COLLEAGUES AS
WELL AS OUR GUEST SPEAKERS.
MR MAIENSCHEIN. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
MISTER CHAIRMAN I JUST WANNA
SAY IS SO WHEN I WAS ON THAT
SENIOR CITY COUNCIL THE TWO
WORST FIRES THAT HIT ARE IN HIS
RIVER CITY BOTH HIT.
MY COUNCIL DISTRICT
AND THE WORK THAT WE HAD TO DO.
DURING.
DURING THAT FIRES A AND AFTER
IN REBUILDING.
HOW SIGNIFICANT THAT WAS THE
IMPACT IT'S HAD EVEN TO THIS
DAY?
IN MY COMMUNITY HOW SIGNIFICANT
THAT IS IN THESE ISSUES ARE SOME
REALLY PLEASE THE WORK THIS IS
COMMITTEES DOING WE THERE IS A
LOT TO BE DONE.
AND I WOULD UNDERSTAND IT KIND
OF WAS A PERSONAL LEVEL IS A
FORMER.
GAUCHO I GET SICK HE'S ANNOYS A
GOTCHA BUT AT UC SANTA BARBARA
GRADUATE I WANT TO EXTEND THAT.
YOU MY PERSONAL THOUGHTS TO DO
YOU AS SENATOR JACKSON IN YOUR
COMMUNITY AND WHAT YOU'RE
CURRENTLY.
GOING THROUGH THAT YOU KNOW
THAT.
I'M THINKING ABOUT YOU AND AND
WISHING YOU THE BEST AS YOU HELP
YOUR COMMUNITY GET THROUGH THE
SOUTH.
MS SAGER CURRY. THANK YOU.
I WASN'T EXPECTING TALK BUT.
AYE AYE FOR LIKE SIX COUNTIES
ARE ON FIRE.
IN THE COMMUNICATIONS ISSUES OR
ARE OF PARAMOUNT ON HOW WE CAN
DEAL WITH A GOING FORWARD.
TRUST ME I'VE WORKED ON THIS
ISSUE FOR MANY ARE PRIOR TO YOU
FROM SHOWING UP IN THIS
BUILDING.
AND I'M REALLY INTERESTED IN
FINDING OUT WHERE WE ARE WITH
PERSON THAT. THIS IS A PROJECT
IS SUPPOSED TO BE DONE IN TWENTY
TWENTY I DON'T KNOW THAT THAT'S
GOING TO MAKE THAT DATE. BUT I
NEVERTHELESS THIS IS BEEN A LONG
TIME TO THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION
SO I'M REALLY INTERESTED IN SEE
WHERE WE'RE GOING WITH THE
PROGRESS HAS BEEN MADE. AND.
HOW WE'RE GOING TO MAKE SURE
THAT ARE A COMMUNITIES ARE SAFE
THANKS?
IF THERE'S ANY OTHER MEMBERS
WHO.
WISH TO MAKE ANY OPENING
COMMENTS.
I AM IN IF THERE ISN'T.
ANON CITING INSTANT TO KNOW IF
YOU WANT TO MAKE CONGRESS
METHODS. YES.
DISTIN.
.
SHARES THANK YOU FOR GETTING
THIS GALLON IN BEGINNING THE
CONVERSATION AND.
AND ALL THE MEMBERS THAT HAVE
MADE THAT THE MEETINGS AND TO
OUR.
.
BUSINESS OWNERS ESSENTIALLY ON
THE OUTSIDE AS A.
ARMY SERGEANT THAT'S TRAINED.
BOTH.
CONOCEN NO CONOCEN FOR A HOW
YOU CIVILIANS OUT THERE THAT'S.
STATESIDE IN COMBAT.
MEDICATIONS IS EVERYTHING AND.
IS ALREADY MENTIONED BY OUR GUYS
THAT I COME FROM BEING FIRST
RESPONDERS. IF YOU CAN'T
COMMUNICATE IN AN EMERGENCY
SITUATION AND.
YOU HAVE NOTHING IN YOU HAVE
CHAOS IS THE ONLY THING THAT IS
LEFT AND OUR CITIZENS.
DESERVE BETTER THAN THAT.
SO I'M VERY INTERESTED I KNOW WE
ALL ARE.
TO THE CONVERSATION WITH FIRST
NAT AND THE CAPABILITIES THE
REDUNDANCIES. THE PLANS TO MOVE
FORWARD I KNOW I REMEMBER HERE.
HAS STRIVED TO PUSH THIS
CONVERSATION FORWARD.
TO INSURE OUR CITIZENS A FUTURE
WHERE THEY CAN GO TO BED AT
NIGHT AND NO THERE'S A WAY. FOR
THEM TO GET SAFETY.
THANK IN A WE HAD A COUPLE OF
OUR COLLEAGUES JOIN US IF THEY'D
LIKE TO MAKE ANY COMMENTS IF NOT
I'M GONNA GO AHEAD AND.
PROCEED FORWARD.
AND THE.
LET'S BEGIN WE'VE ALL SEEN THIS
TITLE BUT IT'S IT'S MORE TRUE
NOW THAN EVER RIGHT READY OR NOT
IT'S GONNA HAPPEN.
EMERGENCY COMMUNICATIONS
NETWORKS IN THE FACE OF
WILDFIRES MUDSLIDES IN PUBLIC
SAFETY THREATS.
SO. I WANT TO GO AHEAD AND
START OF THE FIRST PANEL AND.
.
WE WE CALLED IT THE US SINCE WE
LAST MET OVERVIEW OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA WILDFIRES MUDSLIDES
AND WOOD* THE FIRST OF THREE
PANELISTS.
I PLEASE JOIN US.
.
IF THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS ARE
OKAY WE STRUCTURED IN ABOUT TEN
MINUTE PRESENTATION OR HAVE TO
TAKE THE TEN MINUTES BUT YOU
HAVE UP ABOUT TEN MINUTES.
I WILL BE THIRTY ONE.
STOP AT THE TIME THAT WILL GO
INTO Q. IN A.
AT THAT POINT SO THAT THE
PRESENTATIONS CAN BE COMPLETED
THAT'S OKAY WITH EVERYONE.
AND PLEASE INTRODUCE YOURSELF AS
WELL.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
.
CHAIR SANTIAGO CHAIRWOMAN
JACKSON
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS AND SENATORS
AND DISTINGUISHED GUESTS MY NAME
IS JOE TYLER I AM THE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF FIRE PROTECTION
CHIEF OF FIRE PROTECTION FOR CAL
FIRE.
SO.
I'M HERE TODAY.
TO TALK ABOUT.
THE DECEMBER FIRES SEE AS YOU
HAD MENTIONED BEFORE.
CALIFORNIA'S IN A FIRE A YEAR
ROUND FIRE SEASON.
IT SEEMS TO NEVER STOP ANYMORE
INDEED A CLIMACTIC CHANGES.
IT CONTINUES TO WORSEN.
THROUGHOUT THE YEAR SO MY. MY
POSITION HERE TODAY IS TO
DISCUSS WITH YOU A SPECIFICALLY
THE AT DECEMBER WILDFIRES AS
YOU'VE ALREADY HEARD ABOUT THE
OCTOBER WILDFIRES IN MAY ACROSS
BACK AND FORTH WITH SOME
STATISTICAL INFORMATION.
BETWEEN THE TWO BUT.
AS AS YOU'VE STATED ALREADY ON
DECEMBER FOURTH TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN.
AND FOR THE TWO WEEKS OF
FOLLOWING THAT ONE HUNDRED
TWENTY TWO WILDLAND FIRES BROKE
OUT ACROSS SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
UNDER THOSE RED FLAG CONDITIONS
AND THE FIREFIGHTERS FIRST
RESPONDERS. A LAW ENFORCEMENT
DEALT WITH THOSE RED FLAG
CONDITIONS IN THE SANTA ANA WIND
CONDITIONS OFTEN ON THROUGHOUT
THE ENTIRE FOURTEEN DAYS.
OF THE HUNDRED TWENTY TWO A
WILDLAND FIRES BROKE ON THAT
TIME FRAME ONE HUNDRED SIXTEEN
OF THOSE FIRES.
WERE CONTAINED IN THEIR INITIAL
ATTACK PHASES OF A SIX OF THOSE
FIRES GREW INTO. LARGE AND
DAMAGING A FAST MOVING FIRES IN
WHICH WE ALL HAD TO DEPLOY
RESOURCES TO.
OF THE SIX FIRES OF THEY WERE
PUSHED BY THE STRONG AND DRY
SANTA ANA WINDS.
DURING A TIME IN WHICH RELATIVE
HUMIDITY IN SUMMERS AREAS
REACHED AS LOW AS ONE PERCENT.
AND.
ON ONE PARTICULAR DAY LOOKING
AT THE WEATHER IN THE LOS
ANGELES AREA FOR THE RELATIVE
HUMIDITY ACTUALLY REGISTERED AS
ZERO PERCENT.
THE FIRES BURNED UNDER ONE OF
THE LONGEST DURATION SANTA ANA
WIND EVENTS IN HISTORY CAUSING
RED FLAG WARNINGS TO REMAIN IN
EFFECT FOR HISTORIC THIRTEEN
DAYS. WHICH WAS THE LONGEST
PERIOD OF TIME CALIFORNIA THAT A
A STAINED RED FLAG EVENT
OCCURRED.
THE SIX FIRES.
COMBINED BURNED OVER THREE
HUNDRED EIGHT THOUSAND THREE
HUNDRED EIGHTY ACRES AND
DESTROYED OVER ONE THOUSAND
THREE HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE
STRUCTURES AND ANOTHER FOUR
HUNDRED FORTY STRUCTURES THAT
WERE DAMAGED.
THE THOMAS FIRES WE'VE TALKED
ABOUT ALREADY BROKE OUT ON
DECEMBER FOURTH IT.
AT SIX TWENTY EIGHT IN THE
EVENING. AND IT WAS THE FIRST OF
SIX WHAT LARGE WILDFIRES THAT
BROKE OUT.
THE FIRE STARTED NORTH OF SANTA
PAULA.
IN VENTURA COUNTY MOVING INTO
SANTA BARBARA COUNTY AND WOULD
ULTIMATELY GOING TO DESTROY ONE
THOUSAND SIXTY THREE STRUCTURES.
TAKING THE LIVES OF TO
INDIVIDUALS AND BURNING OVER.
TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY ONE THOUSAND
EIGHT HUNDRED NINETY THREE
ACRES.
MAKING IT THE LARGEST WILDLAND
FIRE IN CALIFORNIA HISTORY.
THE CREEK FIRE OCCURRED SHORTLY
THERE AFTER ON DECEMBER FIFTH AT
THREE FORTY FOUR IN THE MORNING
IT STARTED EAST A SILMAR.
THAT IT WAS EVENTUALLY CONTAINED
AT FIFTEEN THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED
NINETEEN ACRES AFTER DESTROYING
SIXTY RESIDENTIAL STRUCTURES.
AND ANOTHER SIXTY THREE
STRUCTURES WERE DESTROYED OUT
BUILDINGS OR OTHERWISE WITH AN
ADDITIONAL SEVENTY ONE
STRUCTURES THAT WERE DAMAGED.
THE RIFLE IRA OCCURRED ON
DECEMBER FIFTH.
AT A ELEVEN THIRTY ONE IN THE
MORNING IS STARTED IN THE AREA
SANTA CLARITA.
IT WAS CONTAINED AT SIX THOUSAND
FORTY NINE ACRES AFTER
DESTROYING SIX RESIDENTIAL
STRUCTURES AND DAMAGING ANOTHER
THREE.
THE SKIRBALL FIRE OCCURRED ON
DECEMBER SIXTH AT FOUR FIFTY TWO
IN THE MORNING. AN AREA OF THE
FOR A FIVE FREEWAY IN MULHOLLAND
DRIVE.
I IN THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES IT
WAS CONTAINED OF FOUR HUNDRED
TWENTY TWO ACRES SIX STRUCTURES
WERE DESTROYED ANOTHER TWELVE
WERE DAMAGED.
THE LILAC FIRE OCCURRED ON
DECEMBER SEVENTH.
AT ELEVEN FIFTEEN IN THE
MORNING.
IN THE AREA OF OLD HIGHWAY THREE
NINETY FIVE IN THE BOND SOUL
AREA OF SAN DIEGO COUNTY.
IT WAS EVENTUALLY CONTAINED AT
FOUR THOUSAND ONE HUNDRED ACRES
AFTER DESTROYING ONE HUNDRED
FIFTY SEVEN HOMES.
IN ANOTHER SIXTY FOUR
STRUCTURES THAT WERE DAMAGED.
AND THEN FINALLY THE LIBERTY
FIRE THE LAST OF THE SIX STARTED
ON DECEMBER SEVENTH AT ONE
FOURTEEN IN THE AFTERNOON IN THE
COMMUNITY OR THE CITY OF
MARIETTA. AND RIVERSIDE COUNTY
IT WAS CONTAINED AT A THREE
HUNDRED ACRES AFTER DESTROYING
ONE HOME AND ONE OUT BUILDING.
ONE OF THE PRIMARY CHALLENGES A
FIREFIGHTER SPACE THERE WERE
THESE UNFORGIVING WEATHER
CONDITIONS
THE LACKEY HUMIDITY THE TENDER
DRIVE EDUCATION. AND SOME OF THE
STRONGEST SANTA ANA WINDS AS
WE'VE DESCRIBED CREATED A
CONSTANT BATTLE TO STOP THE
THREAT. OF THESE FIRES.
ON THE FIRST DAY THE THOMAS FIRE
LOAN THE FIRE SPREAD OVER THIRTY
ONE THOUSAND ACRES IN A SPAN OF
ONLY NINE HOURS.
ON DECEMBER FIFTH A STATE OF
EMERGENCY WAS DECLARED IN
MENTORING LOS ANGELES COUNTY'S
FOR THAT THOMAS CREEK IN RYE
FIRES. ON DECEMBER SEVENTH THE
STATE EMERGENCY WAS DECLARED IN
SAN DIEGO COUNTY AND SANTA
BARBARA COUNTY DUE TO THE LILAC
IN THE THOMAS FIRES.
BY DECEMBER EIGHT THE FEDERAL
DECLARATION WAS APPROVED FOR
CALIFORNIA.
ALL IN ALL. OVER EIGHT THOUSAND
SEVEN HUNDRED PERSONNEL
INCLUDING VARIOUS INCIDENT
MANAGEMENT TEAMS FROM LOCAL
STATE AND FEDERAL AGENCIES.
.
OVER TWO THOUSAND THIRTY TWO
FIRE ENGINES ONE HUNDRED SIXTY
BULLDOZERS THREE HUNDRED FIFTY
THREE HAND CREWS. WERE ALL
DEPLOYED ACROSS THE SPIRES IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
WE COULD HAVE DONE THIS WITHOUT
THE MUTUAL AID SYSTEM IN PLACE
AND THE COOPERATION BETWEEN OUR
LOCAL STATE AND FEDERAL PARTNERS
BOTH ON.
LAW ENFORCEMENT AND FIRE
DEPARTMENT AND ASSISTING
AGENCIES TO MAKE OF THE EVENTS
SUCCESSFUL ALLOW US TO MITIGATE
THE THREAT IN AND DAMAGE OF
THESE FIRES.
WE OBTAIN THE ASSISTANCE TO DO
SO FROM TWENTY ONE VARIOUS
STATES OF THE FARTHEST BEING
ALASKA IN NORTH CAROLINA.
IN ADDITION TO THE FOR A OCTOBER
FIRES THAT WE'VE HIT ON BRIEFLY
IN YOUR OPENING.
.
THE.
THOMAS FIRE BECAME THE SEVENTH
MOST DESTRUCTIVE WILDLAND FIRE
IN CALIFORNIA HISTORY AS WELL.
WITH THE ONE THOUSAND SIXTY
THREE STRUCTURES THAT WERE
BURNED.
NOW BESIDES THE.
FIRE ENGINES IN THE BULLDOZERS
AND THE HAND CREWS THAT WERE
DEPLOYED.
WE DEPLOYED ONE HUNDRED TWO
AIRCRAFT OVER THOSE FIRES.
FOR THAT.
ONE TO TWO WEEK PERIOD AND
ONGOING ACTUALLY INTO THE END OF
DECEMBER.
FOR THE FIXED WING AIRCRAFT THE
AIR TANKERS OVER SEVEN HUNDRED
FORTY SIX.
.
HOURS WERE PUT ON AIR TANKERS
AND OVER ONE. POINT THREE
MILLION GALLONS OF FIRE
RETARDANT WERE DROPPED ON THE
VARIOUS FIRES. MOST THAT BEING
ON THE THOMAS FIRE.
A HELICOPTER HOURS.
WE PUT OVER ONE HUNDRED THIRTY
SEVEN HOURS.
ON HELICOPTERS DELIVERING WATER
IN RETARDANT TO VARIOUS FIRES
ACROSS SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
DROPPING. ONE HUNDRED SIXTY NINE
THOUSAND SEVEN HUNDRED SEVENTY
FOUR GALLONS OF WATER.
AS WE CONTINUED ON AND ENTERED
INTO THE.
END OF DECEMBER CROSS ALL THESE
FIRES WE HAD.
.
FIRE SUPPRESSION REPAIR CREWS
WORKING ON THE VARIETY OF FIRES
PUTTING IN WATER BARS RE HAVING.
FIRE LINES.
WHEN THE FIRES WERE MITIGATED
IN ANY A CONTAINMENT STATE. BUT
UNFORTUNATELY.
WE EXPERIENCED ANOTHER EVENT.
AS WE APPROACH THE FIRST OF
JANUARY I SPECIFICALLY BELIEVERS
JANUARY NINTH.
WHERE THOSE EFFORTS HAD TO
SHIFT DUE TO?
MUD FLOW AND DEBRIS FLOWS.
BUT THAT WHAT I WOULD LIKE TO DO
SPECIFIC TO THOSE MUD FLOWS IS A
REFER TO ONE OF MY COLLEAGUES ON
EITHER SIDE OF ME TO DISCUSS
THIS FURTHER.
UP BUT THERE'S MUD FLOWS THAT
WERE PARTIALLY CREATED BY THE A
SCORCHED SOIL. AND I DO TO THE
INTENSE HEAT OF THE FIRES THAT
OCCURRED.
THEY WERE UNABLE TO ABSORB THE
MORE THAN FIVE POINT FIVE INCHES
OF RAIN THAT HAD FALLEN IN THE
COURSE OF ONLY TWO DAYS.
THE LACK OF VEGETATION ALLOWED
THESE INCREASED RATES OF
EROSION.
ULTIMATELY LEADING TO A
CATASTROPHIC FLOODING IN THE
DEVASTATING MUD SLIDES THAT THAT
WE EXPERIENCED IN JANUARY.
I'LL TURN IT BACK TO YOU IF YOU
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS.
LET ME PLEASE MOVE ON TO THE
REST OF THE OTHER TWO SPEAKERS
IN AND THEN WE CAN GO TO THE Q.
AND A.
THAT'S OKAY WITH EVERYONE.
MYSTERY DINNER MISTER TAYLOR.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS KEVIN
TAYLOR I'M THE DIVISION CHIEF
OPERATIONS FOR THEM ON A SEATO
FIRE DEPARTMENT IN SANTA
BARBARA.
AND I WAS ONE OF THE UNIFIED
INCIDENT COMMANDERS FOR THE ONE
NINE DEBRIS FLOW EVENT.
WHEN I TALK TO YOU VERY BRIEFLY
ABOUT TWO TOPICS THE FIRST BEING
THE IMPORTANCE OF PRE
POSITIONING RESOURCES.
AND THE SECOND BEING
COMMUNICATION NETWORKS USE BY
EMERGENCY RESPONDERS.
IN ADVANCE OF THE ONE NINE
DEBRIS FLOW ON JANUARY EIGHTH.
SANTA BARBARA COUNTY PRE
POSITIONED SEVERAL RESOURCES
INCLUDING OUR LOCAL TYPE THREE
INCIDENT MANAGEMENT TEAM.
COMPLETELY AND FULLY ACTIVATED
THE SANTA BARBARA COUNTY
EMERGENCY OPERATIONS CENTER.
EVERY FRONT COUNTRY FIRE
DEPARTMENT WAS A HUNDRED PERCENT
STAFFED WITH ALL OF THEIR
RESOURCES.
SEVERAL AMBULANCES WERE ADDED TO
THE EMERGENCY MEDICAL SERVICES
SYSTEM.
SHERIFFS AND LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT WERE FULLY STAFFED.
OR FLOOD CONTROL DISTRICT.
HAD FOLKS WORKING ON THE DEBRIS
BASINS
AND WE HAD ASSISTANCE FROM THE
CALIFORNIA NATIONAL GUARD. IN
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES WITH.
RTS AND SWIFT WATER FLOOD RESCUE
TEAMS.
NOW AS YOU KNOW ON THE NINTH
THIS TRAGIC DEBRIS FLOW RESULTED
IN TWENTY THREE FOR TALENT IS IN
OUR COMMUNITY.
ONE HUNDRED AND THIRTY FOUR
RESIDENCES DESTROYED.
AND ALMOST FOUR HUNDRED DAMAGED.
BECAUSE OF THIS PRE POSITIONING
OF RESOURCES HOWEVER EIGHT
HUNDRED OF OUR COMMUNITY MEMBERS
WERE RESCUED DURING THE FIRST
TWENTY FOUR HOURS AT THE EVENT.
IT'S UNLIKELY THAT THIS WOULD
HAVE BEEN POSSIBLE WITHOUT THAT
PRE POSITIONING.
EVERYONE THEY CAME TO ASSIST
BEFORE THE DEBRIS FLOW CAME
UNDER THE MASTER MUTUAL AID
AGREEMENT.
THAT'S ESSENTIALLY NEIGHBOR
HELPING NEIGHBOR.
WITH NO EXPECTATION OF
REIMBURSEMENT.
DEBRIS FLOWS IN MONTICELLO AND
SANTA BARBARA COUNTY ARE THREE
TO FIVE YEAR THREAT.
WELL THE WATERSHED.
REGROWSAND REPAIRS ITSELF.
AND SO WE ANTICIPATE HAVING TO
DO THIS OVER AND OVER AGAIN IN
OUR COMMUNITY.
MASTER MUTUAL AID IS MOST LIKELY
NOT ASSISTING NOBLE WAY TO DO
THIS.
SO THE ONE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLAR ALLOCATION REQUESTED.
BY THE DISASTER READINESS AND
SAFE AND SAFER COMMUNITIES
WOULD PROVIDE MORE EFFECTIVE AND
EFFICIENT RESOURCE DEPLOYMENT.
BY THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES FIRE AND
RESCUE BRANCH IN ADVANCE OF THE
STORMS.
OR IN ADVANCE OF WEATHER EVENTS
FOR WILDLAND URBAN INTERFACE
FIRES.
NOW MOVING ON TO THE
COMMUNICATION NETWORKS.
THERE WERE UTILIZED IN EMERGENCY
RESPONSE THE FIRST NOT PROGRAM.
WILL PROVIDE ABOUT A THOUSAND
CELLULAR SITES IN THE FIRST FIVE
YEARS OF OPERATION.
WHICH WILL PROVIDE US WITH
FASTER CONNECTIONS AND MORE
BANDWIDTH IN THE PUBLIC SAFETY.
SPECTRUM.
THE IMPORTANCE OF BAND WITH US
IS IT IMPROVES OUR SITUATIONAL
AWARENESS.
ALLOWING US TO DEVELOP A COMMON
OPERATING PICTURE AND ULTIMATELY
BECOME INTER OPERABLE.
THIS STARTS IN A DEBRIS FLOW
EVENT WITH THE WEATHER FORECAST.
A LOT OF DECISIONS ARE MADE IN
ADVANCE OF THE EMERGENCY BASED
UPON WHAT THE NATIONAL WEATHER
SERVICE IS FORECASTING.
SPECIFICALLY THE RAIN INTENSITY.
THIS SYSTEM WILL ALSO HELP OUR
LOCAL SHERIFF'S OFFICE ON LAW
ENFORCEMENT WITH EVACUATION
TRACKING.
EVACUATION COMPLIANCE.
AND MAY POTENTIALLY ALERT
RESCUERS WHERE THEY NEED TO
FOCUS THEIR EFFORTS IF A DEGREE
FOR WORKERS.
IT COULD ALSO POTENTIALLY CREATE
A SITUATION WHERE EVACUEES COULD
SELF REPORT THEIR LOCATION TO
EMERGENCY RESPONDERS.
IT WOULD ALLOW US TO LEARN THE
DEBRIS BASIN STATUS
AT THE TIME OF THE ACTUAL EVENT
WITH LITTLE OR NO RISK TO
RESPONDERS.
TODAY THAT REQUIRES A HUMAN TO
WALK UP THERE AND TAKE A LOOK
AND SEE WHAT THE STATUS IS.
AND IT WOULD ALSO HELP US WITH
OUR POLICEMEN AIRY DEBRIS FLOW
DAMAGE ASSESSMENT.
THIS WOULD ALLOW US TO MORE
ACCURATELY FOCUS OUR SEARCH AND
RESCUE EFFORTS ON THOSE AREAS
WHERE WE BELIEVE THAT PEOPLE ARE
TRAPPED.
AS OPPOSED TO THOSE AREAS WHERE
THEY WOULD NOT BE.
IT WOULD PROVIDE IMMEDIATE
INFORMATION SHARING WITH THE
EMERGENCY OPERATIONS CENTER
WHICH SHOULD WE JEWS ARE REFLEX
TIME. AND IMPROVE THEIR ABILITY
TO SUPPORT AND COORDINATE THE
RESPONSE ON THE GROUND.
AND THEN FINALLY THESE
TECHNOLOGIES WOULD ALLOW US TO
USE BOTH VIDEO AND FORWARD
LOOKING INFRARED DRONE
TECHNOLOGY.
TO MORE CLEARLY DEFINE THE
CURRENT SITUATION.
THE SYSTEM CREATES RESILIENCY
AND REDUNDANCY.
AND MAY ALSO HELP SOLVE THE
PROBLEM OF NINE ONE ONE CELLULAR
CALL ROUTING. THE RECALL CHIEF
MCELROY FROM SANTA BARBARA FIRE
DEPARTMENT ALERTED THIS GROUP TO
SEVERAL MONTHS AGO.
THIS IS WHERE THE EMERGENCY CALL
FROM THE CELLPHONE DOESN'T
NECESSARILY END UP AT THE
APPROPRIATE PUBLIC SAFETY
ANSWERING POINT. WHICH DELAYS
ARE RESPONSE.
SO IN CLOSING I'D LIKE TO STATE
THAT PRE POSITIONING RESOURCES
WAS CRITICAL TO OUR SUCCESS IN
THE ONE NINE DEBRIS FLOW EVENT.
AND REMAINS A VERY IMPORTANT
PART OF OUR LOCAL PLANS MOVING
FORWARD.
MASTER MUTUAL AID IS THE
SOLUTION TODAY BUT MOST LIKELY
NOSSOS DENOBLE.
AND THEN SAY THAT FIRST THAT
WILL PROVIDE PUBLIC SAFETY
DESIGNATED BAND WITH WHICH WILL
SIGNIFICANTLY IMPROVE OUR
SITUATIONAL AWARENESS.
AND INTER OPERABILITY WHICH IN
THE END WILL PROVIDE OUR
COMMUNITIES WITH A MORE
EFFECTIVE. AND EFFICIENT
RESPONSE AND RECOVERY OF THESE
LARGE DISASTERS.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SIR MISTER
NAME PLEASE.
MANY MEMBERS MY NAME SHIFTING
THEM SHARP COUNTY I APPRECIATE
THE INVITATION TO ACTUALLY
CENTER JACKSON THANKS FOR HAVING
ME HERE. NOW YOU'VE BEEN DEEPLY
IMBEDDED.
WITH THE THOMAS FIRE SINCE ITS
BEGINNING.
TO TYLER TALK ABOUT WHEN THAT
FIRE STARTED SANTA POLLACK INTO
A I WAS THERE SEVEN PM STANDING
SIDE BY SIDE WITH MY FIRE
DEPARTMENT BROTHER AND. AS WE
LOOK THIS FIRE AND.
BEING A COP LIKE GENERALLY
DON'T LIKE TO PAY ATTENTION WHAT
FIREMAN SAY.
BUT WHEN THE THAT THE TIME SHE
LOOKED AT ME AND SAID WE NEED TO
EVACUATE UP FOR ALL HIGH.
AND THE CITY OF VENTURA.
THANK HEAVENS WE LISTEN TO ON
THAT NIGHT.
I'M THERE'D BE A LOT THERE'S
GONNA BE A LOT OF DISCUSSION OUT
PERSON THAT IN EIGHTEEN THE
PEOPLE HERE SOME EXPERTS IS
HIGHER. BUDGET TALK ABOUT IT BUT
I THINK YOU TO REAP BE REMISS IF
WE DIDN'T DISCUSS COMMUNICATIONS
TO OUR CITIZENS
THE PEOPLE OF OUR COMMUNITY OUR
NEIGHBORS OUR FAMILIES. AND HOW
WE SAVE LIVES A MENTOR COUNTY
WE'RE VERY PRIVILEGED THROUGH
HARD WORK I'D HAVE A MULTI
TIERED REALLY REALLY EFFECTIVE.
A NOTIFICATION SYSTEM WE USE FOR
DIFFERENT ELEMENTS THE FIRST ONE
IS THE SYSTEM WE CALL VC ALERT
WHICH IS A THIRD PARTY VENDOR
CALLED EVER BRIDGE. DURING THE
THOMAS FAR WE MADE NOTIFICATIONS
TO ABOUT A HUNDRED AND SIXTY
FIVE THOUSAND PEOPLE WITHOUT A
NINETY SEVEN PERCENT. SUCCESS
RATE.
NOW THAT SOUNDS REALLY GOOD THIS
IS A SYSTEM THAT PEOPLE GO IN
AND SIGN UP FOR THEMSELVES.
SOME SOME COUNTIES CALLED
REVERSE NINE ONE ONE SOME DON'T
HAVE ANY SYSTEM BUT IT'S THERE
THE PROBLEM AS YOU NEED PEOPLE
TO GO SIGN UP FOR IT. SO IN MY
COUNTY I'VE SIXTY THOUSAND
PEOPLE HAVE SIGNED UP OUT OF MY
EIGHT HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE
THOUSAND PEOPLE. CONDITION THAT
I BY THE NINE ONE ONE DATA.
WHICH GIVES ME ANOTHER COUPLE
HUNDRED THOUSAND PEOPLE OF DATA.
HOW MANY OF YOU ANSWER YOUR
PHONE HOME?
THAT'S WHAT NINE ONE ONE DATA
IS.
SO. WHAT WOULD BE INCREDIBLY
HELPFUL AND WE'VE BEEN TRYING TO
WORK WITH CELL PHONE PROVIDERS
IF WE GET ACCESS TO CELL PHONE
DATA GEOGRAPHIC LOCATION?
BECAUSE IT DOESN'T DO ME ANY
GOOD TO HAVE YOUR CELL PHONE
NUMBER IF IT'S NOT BASED YOUR
ADDRESS.
BECAUSE OUR SURGICAL SURGED
SURGICAL NOTIFICATION PROCESS
RIGHT CONTROL LINE AROUND ONE
HOUSE TO AN ENTIRE NEIGHBORHOOD
TO ENTIRE CITY IS BASED ON THE
GEOGRAPHIC NOTIFICATION.
AND THAT IS REALLY REALLY
CRITICAL WHETHER IT BE AN ACTIVE
SHOOTER. WHETHER IT BE AN
EXPLOSION A CHEMICAL EXPLOSION
WHETHER BE A FIRE WE DON'T HAVE
TO USE THE WIDE AREA NETWORK
SYSTEM.
SO AS A FOLLOW UP TO OUR LOCAL
AREA NOTIFICATION DURING THE
THOMAS FAR WE DID TO WIDE AREA
NOTIFICATIONS
WHICH TOUCHED ANOTHER HUNDRED
AND FIFTY THOUSAND PEOPLE.
NOW IS YOU AND I DON'T MEAN TO
BE PREACHING THE CHORUS YOU KNOW
THAT GOES TO A PRIVATE THE
PRIVATE CELLPHONE CARRIERS AND
IT GOES TO THE CLOSEST CELLPHONE
TOWER.
SO THEY COVER THE AREA THAT WE
WANT BUT THEY ALSO COVER A
BROADER SPECTRUM.
SO A LOT OF PEOPLE GET THE
NOTIFICATION THAT THEY REALLY
DON'T NEED TO HAVE AND YOU GET
ALERT FATIGUE IT'S NO DIFFERENT
THAN THE CELL PHONE CALLS YOU
GET. THAT FROM VENDORS AFTER
WHILE YOU YOU YOU JUST DON'T PAY
ATTENTION BECAUSE IS NOT
SPECIFIC TO YOUR AREA.
IF WE CAN ENHANCE BY HAVING CELL
PHONE DATA IN OUR NERD IN OUR IN
OUR SURGICAL NOTIFICATION
SYSTEM.
IT WOULD REALLY REALLY MAKE A
DIFFERENCE BECAUSE I THINK YOU
SAVE LIVES BY.
BEING SPECIFIC WHEN YOU NOTIFY
PEOPLE GIVING THEM THE EXACT
INFORMATION. AND NOT
OVERWHELMING THEM WITH WIDE AREA
NOTIFICATIONS
SO WE WE USE A LOCAL SURGICAL
SYSTEM WHERE YOU WE USE THE WIDE
AREA NETWORK WE USE OUR
EMERGENCY BROADCAST SYSTEM.
WHICH IS FOR THOSE OF US BEEN
AROUND AWHILE ECOSPHERE LOCAL
RADIO STATIONS AND TO NOTIFY
PEOPLE WITH THE LOCAL MEDIA ON.
OUR UNSEEN WITH US THE QEII Y.
RETOOK REPORTER OUT OF SENATE
WORRY WAS THERE. VIRTUALLY EVERY
MINUTE WITH US AND ON TOP OF
THAT WE SEND FIRST RESPONDERS
OUT TO KNOCK ON DOORS.
NOW AYE AYE SIR ICED IT MOMENTS
TALKING TO THAT SECTOR OF
HOMELAND DEFENSE ABOUT THIS I
SAID WE'RE LUCKY.
THAT WE ONLY HAD TWO DEATHS IN
OUR FIRE CHIEF CORRECTED MEMBER
CURRENCIES WHO WEREN'T LUCKY.
IT DIDN'T HAPPEN BY ACCIDENT
BECAUSE WE HAVE A WELL REHEARSED
SOPHISTICATED.
PROGRAM THAT REALLY REALLY WORKS
NOW HE ALWAYS WANT NO DESKS OR
TWO DEATHS WERE A WOMAN
EVACUATING ON A CAR ACCIDENT.
AND THEN SADLY COREY COREY
IVERSON OUR HERO FIREFIGHTER WHO
DIED FIGHTING THE FIRE.
I WAS PRETTY DANG HAPPY WITHOUT.
WE LOST A THOUSAND STRUCTURES
ALONE LOST TWO LIVES AND PART OF
IT WAS BECAUSE OF THIS
NOTIFICATION SYSTEM TO GET THE
MESSAGE OUT ACCURATELY.
AND SURGICALLY TO THE RIGHT
PEOPLE AT THE RIGHT TIME AND NOT
OVERWHELM THEM WITH ADDITIONAL
NOTIFICATIONS THAT THAT MAY NOT.
PAY ATTENTION TO.
SO IF THERE'S LEGISLATION.
TO GET PEOPLE TO OPT IN TO GET
CELLPHONE CARRIERS TO PROVIDE US
WITH THAT INFORMATION AND I
REALIZE HIS PRIVACY ISSUES WE
HAVE THE NINE ONE ONE DATA FOR
HOME PHONES WE HOPE THERE'S A
WAY TO WORK AROUND THAT.
THE OTHER ISSUE WHICH THE F.
FEDERAL SHE SHE IS WORKING ON A
READY. JUST ALLOW US TO EXPAND
THE NUMBER OF CHARACTERS WERE
ALLOWED TO PUT OUT INNOCENT
APPLICATIONS BECAUSE WITH A
SMALL NUMBER OF CHARACTERS.
YOU CAN'T GIVE DETAILED
INFORMATION AND YOU PUT OUT A
MESSAGE SAYS THERE'S A DISASTER.
AND NOBODY KNOWS WHAT WHAT IT'S
FOR SHOULD BE ABLE TO ADD SOME
ADDITIONAL CHARACTERS TO THAT
WOULD BE INCREDIBLY HELPFUL.
AND THEN BE ENOUGH PEOPLE
TALKING AS MY BROTHERS HERE OF
TALK ABOUT A PERSON AT SO I
WON'T EVEN. DISCUSS THAT THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU MISTER DEAN AND.
OPENED UP TO COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
THERE ANY
RUSSIANS.
I'M SURE.
THANK YOU SHERIFF DEAN ACTUALLY
HAVE A BILL ON CHOSE THIS
SUBJECT BASED UPON THE HEARING
WE HAD BEFORE THE FIRE AN HOUR
AND A HALF BEFORE THE FIRE
STARTED IT'S AN. I SP EIGHT
TWENTY ONE THAT'S ACTUALLY GOING
TO BE A AN OPT OF AN OPT IN
SYSTEM. COUNTIES CAN OFTEN FOR
INDIVIDUALS WHO CAN THEN IF THEY
DECIDE THEY DON'T WANT TO
PARTICIPATE THEY CAN OPT OUT BUT
IT'S GOING TO GIVE.
I COUNTY SEE OPPORTUNITY TO GET
PEOPLE ON THAT NOTIFICATION
SYSTEM RATHER THAN PEOPLE HAVE
TO FIRST KNOW THAT THE SYSTEM
EXISTS THEN TAKE THE AFFIRMATIVE
STEP TO OPT IN. THEMSELVES THIS
WAY WE KNOW AS YOU'VE INDICATED
IT WILL SAVE LIVES SO I
APPRECIATE THAT PLUG FOR S. B. A
TWENTY ONE. UNKNOWING ESTIMATE
BEEN.
BUT.
.
PERHAPS WE WERE CHANNELING THAT
THE IDF AS A RESULT THE LAST
HEARING I DID HAVE A COUPLE
QUESTIONS IF I COULD FOR.
DEPUTY TIE A TYLER.
YOU MENTIONED THAT YOU PUT TO.
A HUNDRED.
IT WAS SHIPPED ONE POINT THREE
MILLION GALLONS OF FIRE
RETARDANT.
I SAW SOME OF THAT.
OF ITS KIND OF PINK.
IT LOOKS REALLY WEIRD ON TREES
BUT I KNOW THAT IT DID HELP SAVE
A LOT OF I AM CURIOUS FROM
BURNING UP PARTICULARLY IN THE.
THE MONTECITO WARY AND THERE WAS
SOME INVENTORY IF I RECALL
CORRECTLY. THAT'S A LOT OF.
FIRE RETARDANT COULD YOU TELL ME
WHAT THE ENVIRONMENTAL
IMPLICATIONS ARE IS THE SOFT
TOXIC. AS IT SORT OF SWEPT DOWN
THE THE HILLSIDES WITH THE THE.
WOULD WE CALL THAT OF MUCH LIKE
WE CALLED THE WITH NINE THE ONE
NINE.
MY DEBRIS INCIDENT WERE TRYING
TO READ THAT REPURPOSE THE NAME
SO. OF THE IT'S.
ONE THAT DOESN'T COME EASILY TO
MY LIPS SO.
CHIEF TYLER WHAT WHAT TAYLOR
WHAT WE CALL THIS THE MONEY ONE
NINE DEBRIS FLOW ONE NINE TO
REFILL THAT'S THAT MUCH
MUDSLIDES AND MOAN SEAT WANTING
TO BRIEF.
WHAT WHAT IS THAT MEAN IN TERMS
OF IN THE ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS
OF OF THAT?
?
FIRE RETARDANT BEING IN THE.
COMMUNITY.
SO CSUS SPECIFICALLY AT THERE
WERE A LOT OF QUESTIONS CAME
ABOUT THE AMOUNT OF FIRE
RETARDANTS BOTH THE NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND SO THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA THAT WERE. WERE
DROPPED.
LET ME ASSURE YOU THAT A SECRET
DOCUMENTS A LOT OF ANALYSIS HAS
BEEN DONE ON FIRE RETARDANT AND
THERE IS CONCERN.
.
BROADLY OF BY DIFFERENT
ORGANIZATIONS ABOUT TO ITS
CHEMICAL COMPONENTS AND WHAT IT
MIGHT DO TO THE ENVIRONMENT. UP
THERE IS A SPECIFIC.
INTER AGENCY AIR TAKE IMPORTANT
FAR CHEMICALS.
ORGANIZATIONS WHO FOR SERVICE
THE CAL FIRE TAKES PART IN IN.
MISSOULA MONTANA THAT EVALUATES
FAR CHEMICALS AND THEY ALSO
EVALUATE THEM FOR THEIR TOXICITY
TO THE COMMUNITIES AND THE
ENVIRONMENT.
BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY A FIRE
RETARDANT FOR THE MOST PART IS
MADE UP. A PRIMARILY OF WATER
WITH EIGHT GUMMING AGENT AND
APPROXIMATELY ELEVEN PERCENT.
NITROGEN COMPONENT THAT YOU
WOULD FIND IN A NORMAL LAWN
FERTILIZER. HAS A GUMMING AGENT
THAT'S INCLUDED WITHIN THAT
FERTILIZER.
WITHIN THAT WITH THAT IN THAT
RETARDANT.
AND IT HAS THAT RED DYE IN IT.
NOT BECAUSE THAT IS THE MAKE UP
OF THE RETARDANT ITSELF BUT THE
PRIMARY REASON FOR THE RED DYE
IS SO.
THE AIR TACTICAL GROUP
SUPERVISOR THE AIR TANKER
PILOTS.
AND THE.
AND THE HELICOPTER PILOTS CAN
SEE WHERE THEY HAVE DROPPED THE
RETARDANT.
WHILE THEY'RE FLYING IN THE AIR.
AGAIN MADE UP OF APPROXIMATELY
ELEVEN PERCENT. OF NITROGEN
AGAIN THE SAME CALLED CHEMICAL
COMPOUNDS THAT YOU SEE AND
FERTILIZER.
AND WE HAVE FOUND.
HISTORICALLY THAT.
THROUGH DILUTION OR OTHERWISE
THEREIN NO CHEMICAL ILL EFFECTS
OF FIRE RETARDANT.
TO COMMUNITIES.
I'M SURE SOME OF MY
ENVIRONMENTAL FRIENDS WOULD HAVE
A RESPONSE BUT I'LL BE SURE THAT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH LAST
QUESTION AND FOR ALL FOR EACH OF
THE PANELISTS BASED UPON YOUR
EXPERIENCES.
.
DID ANY OF OUR FIRST RESPONDERS
EXPERIENCE ANY INTER OPERABILITY
PROBLEMS OR COMMUNICATIONS
DIFFICULTIES.
DURING ANY OF THESE.
EVENTS THAT OCCURRED IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA PARTICULARLY
THAT THE THOMAS FIVE.
THE SENATE BEEN DOING THIS FOR
FORTY YEARS AND THERE'S ALWAYS
SOME SORT OF COMMUNICATION
PROBLEMS ARTICULAR BOUNCING OFF
SATELLITES OR WHAT IT AS I AM
VENTURA COUNTY UBER WERE REAL
LUCKY WE CAN TALK TO EVERYBODY.
ALL THE LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
CAN TALK MY AGENCY WE CAN TALK
TO FIRE BUT THEY'RE STILL
PROBLEMS HE JUST AYE IN ACCOUNT
ANY BOUNCE OFF A MOUNTAIN. WERE
IS IT SO THERE'S NO PERFECT
SOLUTION IN OUR COUNTY BECAUSE.
WE WERE LUCKY TO BE ABLE TO WORK
TOGETHER COMMUNICATE.
COMMUNICATION LIES IT ACTUALLY
WENT FAIRLY WELL AND I KNOW OUR
FIRE DISTRICTS WERE CLOSE WITH
LOS ANGELES A LOS ANGELES COUNTY
TO REMEDY THEIR.
OUR INNER BORDER ISSUES THAT.
HAVE BEEN PRESENT THE PAST.
BUT WE CAN CERTAINLY YOU KNOW
FIRST THAT WILL CERTAINLY
ENHANCE THAT.
I GUESS THAT'S THE.
WHAT IS IT WE CAN DO TO CONTINUE
TO IMPROVE I MEAN THERE HAVE TO
BE SOME POSITIVE SIDE OF THESE
THINGS LIKE LESSONS LEARNED WHAT
WE DO BETTER IN THE FUTURE IF WE
HAVE TO?
CALL UPON THOSE KINDS OF
COMMUNICATIONS SERVICES.
SIR TYLER I WOULD CONCUR RICHARD
DEAN.
WE DID NOT SEE THE.
LEVEL OF COMMUNICATION ISSUES.
IN THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
FIRES AS WE SAW IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA WHEN THE A SAILOR
CONNECTIVITY IN THE SAILOR
TOWERS WERE DISABLED AND OF THAT
FUNCTIONALITY.
BECAME LESS AVAILABLE IT IS
IMPORTANT NOTES.
IN.
IN OUR ICS ORGANIZATION OR
INCIDENT COMMAND ORGANIZATION
THAT.
THROUGHOUT THE INCIDENT WELL I
THINK I WOULD WELL I WOULD THINK
I'D REACT I CONCUR WITH SHIFTING
THAT WE WILL ALWAYS HAVE SOME
LEVEL OF COMMUNICATION
DIFFICULTY IN ITS.
GENERALLY A GEOGRAPHIC
TOPOGRAPHIC IN NATURE.
IN OUR INCIDENT COMMAND SYSTEM
WE HAVE A LOGISTICS SECTION
CHIEFS AND SPECIFICALLY
COMMUNICATION UNIT LEADERS. THAT
WE BRING IN MOBILE
COMMUNICATIONS CENTERS.
MANY AGENCIES SHARE OF FIRE.
O. YES.
ALL HAVE THESE CAPABILITIES
WITH THAT.
WE CAN REACH OUT THROUGH THE
ORDERING SYSTEMS AND ORDER
ADDITIONAL FREQUENCIES SO WE'RE
NOT TALKING ON TOP OF EACH OTHER
DOWN WILDLAND FIRES. IN THESE
MOBILE COMMUNICATIONS CENTERS WE
HAVE THE AVAILABILITY OF
SATELLITE TELEPHONES AND
PORTABLE REPEATERS AS WE FIND.
GEOGRAPHIC AND TOOK A GRAPHIC
DIFFICULTIES WE CAN PLACE A
PORTABLE REPEATERS AREA THEN
PROVE THAT. THAT COVERAGE AND IF
WE DON'T HAVE THOSE PORTABLE
REPEATERS WE CAN ALWAYS PUT A
HUMAN REPEATER IN A SAFE
LOCATION. WHO CAN RELAY
INFORMATION SO?
ENCLOSING A EVERY INCIDENT WILL
HAVE SOME LEVEL OF COMMUNICATION
DIFFICULTY IN THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA FIRES THEY WERE. NOT
LIKE WHAT WE EXPERIENCE AND.
THANK YOU I WILL FOLLOW PUSHING
HIS SHIRT COLLAR STATEMENT JUST
NOW BUT ALLOWS RESOURCES COMING
AFTER THE FACT SO THE INITIAL
STRIKE WAS GOING ON IN. THIS
RESPONSE COME OUT BILLS BOAT
MEDICATIONS ARE GREAT BUT THOSE
COME IN AFTER THE FACT THEY ARE.
NOT INITIAL SIX OR SEVEN HOURS
NEEDS INITIALLY TAKES PLACE.
YES SIR I WOULD OCCUR FOR FOR
CAL FIRE SPECIFICALLY WE HAVE
SIX MOBILE COMMUNICATIONS
CENTERS LOCATED ACROSS
CALIFORNIA.
AND AT GENERALLY YOU WILL NOT
PROBABLY SEE THOSE WITHIN THE
FIRST ONE.
THANK YOU LET ME JUMP TO MISTER
RODRIQUEZ HER QUESTION AND BACK
TO.
.
MISTER COOPER.
WHICH WERE KEVIN YOU TALKED
ABOUT THE PRE POSITIONING OF OUR
RESOURCES HOW DO YOU COME UP
WITH THE.
THE NUMBER OF RESOURCES YOU
NEED WHEN YOU PRE POSITION FOR
WHETHER IT'S THE THE FIRES
REPAIR FOR THE SANTA ANAS OR.
THE FLOODS IN THIS CASE ABOUT
WHAT WOULD YOU BASED ON TOP
RESOURCE YOU NEED FOR THOSE
TYPES OF.
PREPAREDNESS OF THAT WOULD
OCCUR ON BASIN ON.
SO MISTER RODRIGUEZ WE UTILIZE.
DECISION MAKING MATRIX
ESSENTIALLY EVALUATES WHAT THE
WEATHER FORECAST IS.
THE VALUES THAT RISK
IN THE CASE OF A FIRE PREVIOUS
FIRE BEHAVIOR IN THE CASE THAT
OF OF A DEBRIS FLOW THE REPORT
ON THE DAMAGE TO THE WATERSHED.
AND OUT THE OTHER END OF THAT
COMES A PRE FIRE PLAN IF YOU
WILL ARE PRE INCIDENT PLAN.
THE PRE INCIDENT PLAN GENERALLY
WILL IDENTIFY THE NUMBER OF
RESOURCES THE TYPE OF RESOURCES
THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE REQUIRED TO
MANAGE THEM AND WHERE THEY ARE
MOST EFFECTIVE REPLETE DEPORT.
PRE DEPLOYED.
SCUBA NEEDS TO HAVE A QUESTION.
ANY OTHER MEMBERS HAVE
QUESTIONS.
WHEN.
METROPOLITAN AND I ASSUME THAT
THAT THERE WAS YOU HAD BASICALLY
RESPONSE THAT I'M JUST CURIOUS
TO WE KNOW.
THE BECAUSE OF THE SIX FIRES
THAT OCCURRED.
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA ON
DECEMBER FOURTH AND FIFTH.
AND IF NOT WHAT WHAT'S THE
TIMELINE BY WHICH. WE CAN EXPECT
TO KNOW WHAT THE CAUSES WERE OF
THOSE FIRES.
SO I CAN.
I CAN SPEAK TO.
AT LEAST.
FOUR OF THE SIX FIRES AND I CAN
ONLY SPEAK TO FOUR OF THE SIX
FIRES BECAUSE. OF FOUR OF THOSE
FIRES WERE WITHIN THE STATE
RESPONSIBILITY AREA.
OF A OF CALIFORNIA WHERE THE
OTHER ONES WERE.
LOCATED THE CITY MARIETTA IN
THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES AND I
BELIEVE.
THEIR INVESTIGATORS.
MAY HAVE COME UP THE BECAUSE I
DON'T KNOW WHAT THOSE CAUSES
WERE ON THOSE INCIDENTS FOR THE
FOUR REMAINING THAT I CAN SPEAK
TO.
WE ACTIVELY HAVE A FIRE
INVESTIGATORS THAT ARE
COLLECTING DATA FROM.
.
VARIOUS SOURCES AND.
THEIR ORIGIN AND CAUSE
INVESTIGATION.
.
THE A DIRECTOR PELLATT CONTINUES
TO GET TO A REGULAR UPDATES FROM
THOSE INVESTIGATORS WE HOPE
THAT.
WE WILL SEE. THOSE CAUSES.
BE RELEASED
THAT RELATIVELY SOON.
A MONTH TWO MONTHS WHAT'S
RELATIVELY SOON.
I WOULD SUGGEST THAT ARE ON THE
LONG SIDE MAYBE TWO MONTHS.
SO ANY. THAT'S ON THE LONG SIDE.
THANK YOU.
MR GRUBER IT I DON'T OUT SELF
YEARS HIS WORK WITH THE I. O.
U.'S TOOK TO CUT POWER OFF.
IN SOME AREAS WHEN THEY HAVE.
STRONG WINDS OF FIRES SPECIAL
DOWN SOUTH BUT WE DON'T DO
APPEAR THAT'S ONE THING THAT NOW
WE'RE GOOD AT IS INCONSISTENCY
NOT I'M TALKING EVERYONE THE
ENTIRE SYSTEM. WERE STATE WHAT
SHOULD BE FOR A CUP POWER OFF
WHICH YOU LIVE HAVE HIGHWAYS
THAT SHOULD BE A STELLAR
EVERYWHERE. THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT WE CAN LOOK AT BECAUSE
YOU'RE TOO OFTEN HEAR THINGS
AFTER THE FACT IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA WE DON'T DO THAT. P.
JESUS AND DO APPEAR IN IT WE
SHOULD TAKE A LOOK AT YOU KNOW
POSSIBLY IN PLANO TACTICS.
WALLET WOODS INTERVIEWS TO
CONSUMERS OBVIOUSLY IT DIFLUCAN
SAVE LIVES.
SO THERE IS YOUR THOUGHT ABOUT
DOING THAT AND MAYBE A STATEWIDE
POLICY.
WE DO HAVE HIGH WINTER IN FIRES
TAKE OFF.
WE WE TALK ABOUT.
LESSONS LEARNED THESE ARE ONE
OF THE LESSONS LEARNED THAT.
THAT WE ARE LOOKING AT IS
WORKING CLOSELY WITH THE CPU SEE
AS WELL AS THE.
UTILITIES.
ACROSS CALIFORNIA TO TRY TO.
EVALUATE THIS PROCESS IS AND
PERHAPS STANDARDIZE ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. I GUESS MY QUESTION
WOULD BE IS HOW LONG THEY'VE
BEEN CUT SO I'VE JUST HEARD
ABOUT IT AS A RESULT THESE
FIRES.
SO HOW LONG THEY'VE BEEN CUTTING
OUT THE POWER DOWN SOUTH.
IT'S BEEN GOING ON FOR YEARS.
I DON'T KNOW THAT ANSWER.
I WOULD HAVE TO GET BACK TO YOU
ON THAT.
ASSUMING RECORDS I JUST HAVING
LIVE THERE IT'S.
GENERALLY DRIVEN BY AN INCIDENT
AND POST INCIDENT AND POST
INCIDENT LITIGATION.
SO AFTER THE THOMAS FIRE I THINK
THEY. YOU KNOW EDISON COULD SAY
FOR SURE BUT I THINK THEY'VE CUT
OUR POWER THREE DIFFERENT TIMES
A BEFORE THAT I CAN REMEMBER
WHEN.
THAT'S GREAT I MEAN WE SHOULD DO
IT I THINK SHOULD BE SOMETIME A
STANDARD. THAT WE CAN A PLAYER
POSSIBLY TAKE A LOOK AT THAT
YOU.
ANY OTHER MEMBERS WHAT I I DO GO
QUICK A QUICK QUESTION AND
YOU'VE TOUCHED UPON A LITTLE BIT
BUT I WANTED TO MAYBE TAKE A
LITTLE BIT MORE. AND ANSWERED
YOU AN ANSWER TO HAVE ALWAYS
WHAT YOU SHOULD YOU DO I'M SORRY
WHAT DID YOU DO AND IN WHAT
COULD HAVE BEEN DONE
DIFFERENTLY.
AND I'LL START OFF AND BY
STATING NAPA.
BUT WHAT I'M GOING AFTER IS SO.
THESE FIRES HAVE IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA WE'VE LEARNED
SOMETHING FROM THEM.
EIGHT.
WHAT IS IT THAT YOU DID
DIFFERENTLY AND SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA A WHAT IS IT?
GENERALLY I COULD'VE BEEN DONE
DIFFERENTLY.
AS IT RELATES TO.
COMMUNICATION.
AND NOTIFICATION THE OF THE
PUBLIC.
BECAUSE THERE'S TWO THINGS OUT
THAT I'M LOOKING FOR THEIR RIGHT
WILL YOU KNOW WHAT YOU DID DO.
AND. WHAT COULD BE DONE BEYOND
AND IF YOU COULD TALK A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT REDUNDANCY AS WELL?
?
I APPRECIATE THAT.
YEAH I'M NOT ELISE INVENTOR
COUNTY I DON'T THINK WE DID MUCH
DIFFERENT AFTER.
THAT THE FIRES IN IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA I GET SO ONE THE
LESSONS WE LEARNED IS. PUTTING
OUT IN SPANISH LANGUAGE WE USE
GOOGLE TRANSLATE.
AND.
BECAUSE IT WAS THE BEST WE HAD
AND WE HAVE SO MANY DIALECTS A
MENTOR COUNTY THAT THE NUMBERS
WEREN'T.
THAT THAT LANGUAGE WASN'T
TRANSPOSE PROPERLY AND AFTER
THAT WE HAD INTERPRETED IN ONE
OF THE CHALLENGES FOR THAT I
KNOW THERE'S SOME LEGISLATION
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW MOAN IS.
OFTEN TIMES.
WERE AT THE BACK FOR A PATROL
CAR FIRE ENGINE AT TWO O'CLOCK
IN THE MORNING AND WE HAVE TO
GET A MESSAGE OUT WITHIN THREE
MINUTES. AND THERE ISN'T TIME TO
HIRE A TRANSLATOR SO COST IT
TAKES ME GIVE IT TO SEND THAT
OUT TO ACCOMPANY A CONTRACT
WITH.
COST ME A HUNDRED EIGHTY DOLLARS
AN HOUR PLUS TAKES ABOUT AN HOUR
FOR THE TURN AROUND.
IF WERE OUT ON THE SCENE THEN WE
HAVE TO BE ABLE TO SEND
SOMETHING OUT INSTANTLY
OTHERWISE LIGHTS ARE GONNA BE AT
REST SO WHAT WHAT IS THAT
BALANCE SO THAT'S CERTAINLY A
LESSON I LEARNED THAT WAY. I'M
WE OPEN UP A TWENTY FOUR HOUR
CALL CENTER IN OUR EOC.
AND OUR WEBSITE FOR PEOPLE TO
CALL IN AND ASK QUESTIONS
I CLARIFY ON OUR NOTIFICATIONS.
SO THAT WORKED WELL FOR US AND
IT WAS SOMETHING THAT WE HADN'T
DONE BEFORE THAT WE WILL
CERTAINLY CONTINUE TO DO.
THANK YOUNG OF HIS ANY OTHER
EXAMPLES.
I CAN TELL YOU IN SANTA BARBARA
COUNTY WE COMPLETELY REDID OUR
NOTIFICATION SYSTEM BASED UPON
OUR FIRST DEBRIS FLOW TOURISTS
TO. A CURRENT TODAY
SO WE WENT FROM A IMMEDIATE
EVACUATION ORDER TWO MORE OF A
SEVENTY TWO HOUR. A PRE
EVACUATION ADVISORY FOLLOWED BY
A RECOMMENDED EVACUATION WARNING
AND THEN ULTIMATELY BECOMING A
MANDATORY EVACUATION ORDER.
SO WE FELT IT WAS NECESSARY TO
ALERT THE COMMUNITY TO THE
FORECAST EVENTS.
AND THAT WAS THE REASON FOR THE
CHANGE OR THE LESSON LEARNED IF
YOU WILL.
DOING TALK ABOUT SOME OF THE
DIFFERENT AVENUES TO USE TO
COMMUNICATE WITH FOLKS.
I CERTAINLY WE USE THE SAME
AVENUES AS EVERYONE ELSE SO OUR
PRIMARY TOOL IS THE EVER BRIDGE.
WE CALL IT THEY ARE READY S. B.
C. DOT ORG IN SANTA BARBARA
COUNTY. AND THE CHALLENGE WITH
THAT A SENATOR JACKSON INDICATED
IS A REQUIRES PEOPLE OFTEN.
SO DESPITE A FAIRLY AGGRESSIVE
EIGHTEEN MONTH IN A CAMPAIGN
THROUGHOUT THE ENTIRE COUNTY WE
STILL SEE FAIRLY LOW NUMBERS.
HE AND MY DAD IF THE STATE WAS
LOOKING TO DO SOMETHING. FOR
CONSISTENCY.
WHILE EVERY COUNTY HAS ITS OWN
CULTURE AND HOW THEY DO IT AND I
THINK LOCAL GOVERNMENT BODIES
SHOULD DICTATE THAT. USING THE
SAME NO NOMENCLATURE AS TO WHAT
IS IT IN A VOLUNTARY EVACUATION
RESIDENT ADVISORY.
ESPECIALLY NEAR BORDERING
COUNTIES MIGHT BE HELPFUL AND
WHILE THEY'RE CERTAINLY BE SOME
DISCUSSION AMONGST ALL THE THE
FIRST RESPONDERS AND THOSE
INVOLVED I THINK YOU COULD COME
TO SOME CONSENSUS SO AT LEAST
EVERYBODY WAS TALKING THE SAME
LANGUAGE. I DON'T THINK YOU'RE
EVER GONNA HAVE A CONSENSUS OR
THAT YOU SHOULD ON WHEN THE
NOTIFICATION SHOULD ACTUALLY GO
OUT.
MR GRUBER.
I SET MYSELF TO SOME RESEARCH IN
IT IT LOOKS LIKE THE FIRST DE
ENERGIZE POLLY BACK IN TWO
THOUSAND TWELVE.
WAS THE FIRST INCIDENT HERE WE
ARE SIX YEARS LATER IN EIGHTEEN
AND I GUESS. I DON'T WANT TO
WAIT FOR THE PC TO MAKE A
DECISION THAT MAYBE TWO YEARS
DOWN THE ROAD GOT A FIRE SEASON
COMING UP IT'S GONNA BE DRY
AGAIN.
SO THERE IS THE EMPHASIS TO ME
FOR SOME.
FIRST TO GET GOING ON THAT AND
AND MAKE IT A STANDARD
OBVIOUSLY.
EACH SCENARIOS DIFFERENT AND
DICTATES WHAT COULD HAPPEN AS
FAR AS I KNOW WHEN AND WHETHER
YOU MIDI FIRE SO.
TO ME THAT'S SOMETHING THAT
SHOULD HAPPEN.
SOONER THAN THE LATER KNOWN THE
WAY THE STATE GOVERNMENT WORKS
IT COULD BE TWO YEARS FROM NOW
FOR THE DECISION ON THAT SO SO
HOW DO WE GET THERE. WITH YOU
GUYS IN THE OF UTILITIES I USE
I TRY TO FIGURE OUT A SYSTEM
THAT WE CAN PLAY THIS SUMMER.
IF YOU SUB FIRES HAPPEN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
GIVING USERS UP HERE YET
HOW DO WE GET THERE THIS SUMMER.
SO MISTER COOPER THAT.
ALL I CAN IMPRESS UPON YOU AT
THIS MOMENT IS THAT.
WE ARE CONTINUING THROUGH EMMA
USING RELATIONS CONTINUING TO
BUILD WITH TO SEE IF YOU SEE WE
ARE MEETING WITH.
THE HIGHEST EVEL EXECUTIVES OF.
SOME OF THE THREE MAJOR A
UTILITY COMPANIES THIS WEEK TO
TALK ABOUT THE LESSONS LEARNED A
LOT OF THOSE ITEMS ARE SO WE'RE
MEETING WITH THEM ON FRIDAY.
IN THESE WILL OBVIOUSLY BE
SUBJECTS OF DISCUSSION. YES WERE
FIRST RESPONDERS YOUR FIRST
RESPONDERS SO THAT TRUMP'S A LOT
OF OTHER THINGS IN. THIS ISSUE
PC IS VERY SLOW.
IN THEIR ACTIONS AND THAT'S JUST
THAT'S JUST HOW IT IS SO I GUESS
IF IT WE'VE CHANCE OF BEING ABLE
TO. GO ON PREVENT SOME THESE
THINGS TO HAPPEN THIS SUMMER.
WHICH IS A FEW SHORT MONTHS AWAY
I WOULD SAY LET'S DO IT.
SOMEHOW SOME WAY THAT'S THAT'S
TO ME IS NOT A HEAVY LIFT.
IF IF IT WANTS CONDITIONS AND I
THINK COMMANDERS THERE AND FEELS
BEST TO SHUT DOWN TO SAVE LIVES.
WE SHOULD DO IT.
I THINK YOU GUYS I WOULD SUPPORT
OTHER PERSON THAT THAT'S WHAT
YOU SAID ABOUT THE COMMANDER
MAKES DECISION THE SUPPORT I
THINK ALLEGE THERE WOULD DO. NO
ONE SECOND GUESS YOU GUYS.
SO IT'S IT'S SOMETHING THAT IF
YOU NEED IF IT SAVES LIVES.
AND SAVES
RESIDENCES AND EVERYTHING ELSE.
SUPPORTIVE OF IT SO IF YOU HAVE
PROBLEMS THE PC LET US KNOW WHAT
WE WANT TO HELP.
I THINK THINK ESCOBAR I AM ALSO
ONE POINT WITH A SPECIAL GUEST
TODAY.
MISLI MON WHO REPRESENTS THE
AREA AND IS SITTING IN WITH US.
AND I KNOW YOU HAVE A QUESTION.
THANK YOU. AS SINCE I WANT TO
FIRST START OFF BY THANKING ALL
OF YOU THAT WE'VE GOT INTO THAT
WORK TOGETHER OVER AT.
UNFORTUNATELY AT YOU KNOW SOME
OF THE NATURAL DISASTERS AND I
WOULD ECHO.
WHAT'S BEEN SAID THAT WE DID I
* DO WE DID IDENTIFY
IMMEDIATE PROBLEMS IN TERMS OF
THE COMMUNICATION. UP BUT THERE
WAS ALSO ANY MEDIA EFFORT TO
RECTIFY THE PROBLEMS AND TO COME
TO A SOLUTION I AND I THINK
THAT.
WHAT WE
ABOUT AND ON THE?
AND I ON THE FRIEND TO HAVE.
.
KIND OF MAKING A DECISION ABOUT.
A.
ABOUT OUR ENERGY SUPPLY AND AND
SO FORTH I I THINK I JUST WANT
TO NOTE THAT IT WAS.
.
ON THE FIRST NIGHT OF THE THOMAS
FIRE. AYE WHIZ AYE LIVE CASH HOW
MANY MILES IS IT FROM.
THE LEAD AFTER.
SENATE PAULA.
CDI.
SOMETHING LIKE THAT AND I WAS.
.
TWO AND I I THINK DIDN'T HAVE.
THE POWER FOR SIX HOURS AND SO
OUR ENTIRE HIGHER REGION.
AND AND YOU KNOW I WAS IN A
DIFFERENT COUNTY THAT OUR ENTIRE
REGION.
WAS DOWN IN TERMS OF POWER BUT
I ALSO REALIZE THAT.
FROM THE POINT OF THE
CONSTITUENTS.
.
EVEN EVEN NOTICE IT IS REALLY
HELPFUL BECAUSE THAT'S A LOT OF
IMPLICATIONS SO I KNOW THAT
THERE'S IMPLICATIONS RELATED TO
HEALTH PARTICULARLY THOSE.
WHO HAVE HEALTH ISSUES WHO NEED
SOME FORM OF POWER TO GET THEM
THROUGH EACH HOUR? ON AND I
DON'T KNOW IF THERE'S A WAY TO
PREPARE PEOPLE IN CASE OF AN
EMERGENCY WE MAY BE DOWN.
THE EXAMPLE REGRETTABLY THAT
COMES TO MIND OVER AND OVER WAS.
AND WHEN AT ONE POINT WE THOUGHT
WE MIGHT BE SIX DAYS AND THAT
WAS WHAT WE WERE MESSAGING TO
THE PUBLIC AND THE ANGST AROUND
THAT.
SMALL BUSINESSES INDIVIDUALS OF
LIKE WHAT DOES THAT MEAN SIXTIES
WITHOUT POWER AND HOW DO YOU
PREPARE IT'S NOT YOU KNOW GET
YOUR LITTLE BOX TOGETHER
IMMEDIATE SIX DAYS.
AND SO I THINK THAT WHATEVER WE
CAN DO SO LONG AS IT'S ALSO
INCLUDES A COMMUNICATIONS PLAN.
TO THE BEST POSSIBLE I MEAN
THIS WAS AN EMERGENCY THINGS
DIDN'T GO RIGHT BECAUSE IT IS AN
EMERGENCY. AND.
AND I WONDER RECOGNIZE THAT
THAT THERE'S ONLY SO MUCH AS
HUMANS THAT WE CAN DO AND
PREPARE FOR AND I BELIEVE THAT
WE REALLY TRIED TO DO THAT.
BUT IF THE COMMUNICATION PLAN
AROUND OUR.
OUR ELECTRICITY SUPPLY INCLUDES
KIND OF HELPING OUR CONSTITUENTS
GET THROUGH THAT MOMENT BECAUSE
I THINK AS ELECTED OFFICIALS AS
PUBLIC SAFETY. ON WE WERE ALL
FIGURED OUT BUT OUR
CONSTITUENTS.
I MEAN AS LONG AS THEIR
CELLPHONES WERE STILL WORKING
THERE EMAILING US AND CALLING
US.
ABOUT WHAT THAT WOULD MEAN SO I
THINK THAT WHATEVER WE CAN DO TO
KEEP THEM ON WITH US AND HELP
THEM UNDERSTAND THAT THERE IS A
PLAN AND THAT NO ONE WANTS SIX
DAYS. I'M AND EVERYBODY WILL
WORK REALLY HARD TO GET SEVEN
SIXTIES WITHOUT A POWER THING
THAT THAT WOULD BE USEFUL AND
AGAIN THANK YOU FOR EVERYTHING
THAT YOU ALL.
HAVE DONE AND THAT YOU CONTINUE
TO DO BECAUSE THIS WAS INDEED AN
EMERGENCY AND.
THINGS WERE IN PERFECT IF WE ARE
TO GO DOWN THAT THAT
ROUTE SO I JUST WANT TO MAKE
SURE WE DON'T FORGET THOSE
PEOPLE THAT. ARE UNABLE TO MAYBE
LEAVE OR RELOCATE.
AND FOR THEM THE WANT TO STAY
AT HOME.
WITHOUT POWER WOULD BE
DETRIMENTAL TO THEIR HEALTH.
THANK YOU I THINK THE PANELISTS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR.
COMING TO THIS HEARING I THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND THANK YOU
FOR SERVICE.
I WANT TO GO ON TO THE NEXT.
PANEL.
WHICH WOULD BE FUTURE THREATS
IMPLICATIONS FOR CALIFORNIA.
WE'LL START OFF WITH.
MISTER MIKE MY GUT.
MY DOG* I APOLOGIZE ABOUT
THAT.
MISTER CURRIER.
FOLLOWED BY MISTER MARTINEZ.
AND AGAIN WE'LL GO THROUGH A UP
TO TEN MINUTES PER PERSON.
I AFTER THAT WILL GOING TO Q.
AND A
.
AND THANK YOU ONCE AGAIN
GOOD AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU MY
NAME'S OUR NICHE MEDICAID WHICH
I AM THAT IF THE TRACTOR AT THE
COVERS OFF MUCH SERVICES.
AND.
WITH ME IS A BUNCH CAREER WHO'S
ALSO WITH CAT CALLOWAY US HE'S
OUR BRANCH MANAGER FOR A NINE
ONE ONE.
AND ALSO THE LEAD ARE FORTUNATE
NEVERS AND SO. I WANNA SEE THANK
YOU.
TO THE MEMBERS HERE FOR
ALLOWING US TO COME BACK IN. AND
SPEND SOME TIME WITH YOU AND
TALK ABOUT.
SO IT'S VERY IMPORTANT TO US
WHICH IS.
PERSON AT AND WHERE WE'RE GOING.
AND.
THIS SIR IT'S BEEN POINTED OUT
BUT THE OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE THIS
BROADBAND ACCESS TO US AS A AS A
PRIMARY MEANS AND DEDICATED.
SPECTRUM FOR FIRST RESPONDER
COMMUNITY.
IS A IS ESSENTIAL AND WE'RE
EXCITED ABOUT THE OPPORTUNITY.
TO LEVERAGE THAT SPECTRUM FOR
ALL OF OUR FIRST RESPONDERS IN
THE BUILD OUT. THE.
APPLICATIONS.
THAT WILL.
UNDOUBTEDLY UNFOLD FOR THEM AND
AS YOU HEARD FROM THE FIRST
PANEL.
THAT WILL HELP THEM.
SITUATIONAL AWARENESS
AND THEN I'LL DEFINITELY HELP US
IN OUR A RESPONSE RECOVERY
ACTIVITIES.
SO IT'S A.
SOMETHING THAT WERE.
EXTREMELY EXCITED.
TO SEE COME TO FRUITION.
I THINK WOULD BE IMPORTANT FOR
ME TO SHARE WITH YOU HOW WE
ARRIVED HERE WHICH IS.
WE.
.
WE HAD A SERIES OF PUBLIC
OUTREACHES AND ONE OF THE SLIDES
WE JUST PASSED OUT TO HIS. ARM
THAT THE OUTRAGE IS THAT WE
ENGAGED IN UP AND DOWN THE
STATE.
I'M CAL YES.
WAS PLEASE TO LEAD THAT EFFORT.
IN ENSURE THAT OUR FIRST
RESPONDER COMMUNITY HAD CHANCE
TO COME OUT AND VOICE TO US
EXACTLY WHAT THEY WANTED OR THE
EXPECTED. AND WHAT THEIR
PRIORITIES WERE.
AS WE OWE MORE TO GO SHADING
WITHOUT FIRST NET AND WITH
EIGHTEEN T..
THIS ALLOWED US TO COMBINE ALL
THOSE COMMENTS AND COME TOGETHER
METHODICALLY AND DELIBERATELY
AND BRING A. A GOOD.
ANALYSIS FOR AS WE.
BEGAN THOSE NEGOTIATIONS.
WITH EIGHTEEN EIGHTEEN PERSON
AT.
DURING THOSE OUTREACH EFFORTS OF
BOTH EIGHTEEN DIVERSE THAT
JOINED US AND IT GAVE EVERYBODY
AN OPPORTUNITY TO HEAR. A PER
VERBALLY FROM THE HORSE'S MOUTH
AND WHAT IS GOING TO HAPPEN OVER
LOOKING AT WHAT'S GOING ON AND
FOR US TO HAVE A. GREAT OPEN
DIALOGUE HOW WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE THAT AS WE MOVE FORWARD
WITH A MORE PUBLIC OUTREACH.
MOST OF OUR OF FIRE AND LAW
AGENCIES EMS AGENCIES A MANY OF
WHOM CAME OUT JOINT ASIDE DURING
THOSE ARE EACH EFFORTS AND GAVE
US A CHANCE TO. TO HAVE THAT
DISCUSSION.
OF CRITICAL IMPORTANCE TO US.
IS THAT.
FIRST IT IS HAVE A PUBLIC
SAFETY GRADE COMPONENT TO IT.
HOW WE RECOGNIZE THAT THIS IS?
AN IMPORTANT ELEMENT OF FIRST
MET IT'D BE OPERATIONAL IT
PROVIDE THAT RESILIENCY IN
PROVIDE THAT REDUNDANCY SO THAT
OUR. FIRST RESPONDER COMMUNITY
CAN DO THEIR TO THEIR JOBS
AND WITHOUT THAT.
IT WILL UNDOUBTEDLY NOT BE
SUCCESSFUL FOR US.
FIRST NET IS NOT A PANACEA BY
ITSELF IS A SINGLE TOOL ONE TOOL
THE TOOL KIT FOR FIRST RESPONDER
COMMUNITIES TO USE.
BUT EVERY TOOL THAT THEY HAVE.
.
BRINGS THEM TO A BETTER CHANCE
FOR SUCCESS WINNER WHEN THEIR
OPERATIONAL DEPLOYING AND SO WE
WANT THEM TO HAVE THAT.
I TODAY I BASS BUDGE.
TO PRESENT TO YOU.
GIVE YOU KIND OF A SHORT UPDATE
AND SEE UNDERSTAND WHAT THE
TECHNICAL INTEGRATION IS OF
FIRST NET BECAUSE I THINK WE IS
A LOT OF TERMINOLOGY AROUND HERE
AND I WANT YOU TO BE ABLE TO.
UNDERSTAND HOW IT FITS IN WITH
THE SEQUENCE WHERE THEY WERE
WORKING ON HE'S GONNA WALK YOU
QUICKLY THROUGH. TWO OF OUR
GRAPHICS
BUDGET.
IT'S MY NAME IS BUDGET CARRIER
ON THE NINE ONE BRANCH MANAGER
WITH CALLAWAY ES NOT RESPONSIBLE
FOR THE NINE ONE NETWORK IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AS WELL AS
THE FIRST THAT DEPLOYMENT AND
INTEGRATION THOSE TWO SOLUTIONS
TOGETHER. SO BEFORE YOU HAVE A
GRAPHIC WE'VE GOT IT HERE ON
THIS.
SLIDE TO THE FAR TO MY FAR
RIGHT IT'S CALLED CONNECTING THE
TECHNOLOGY. WHAT THE PURPOSE OF
THE GRAPHIC IS TO HELP
UNDERSTAND HOW THESE
TECHNOLOGIES ARE DIFFERENT YET
INTEGRATED?
AND SO THE ONE THAT I'VE BEEN
SPENDING MOST OF MY TIME ON HIS
NEXT GENERATION NINE ONE ONE. SO
THAT'S LOCATED IN KIND OF THE
UPPER LEFT HAND CORNER OF THE
DIAGRAM.
SPOKE IS STUNNED GETTING THE
INFORMATION AND THE DATA FROM
THOSE WHO NEED HELP.
INTO OUR PUBLIC SAFETY ANSWERING
POINTS SO THEY CAN RECEIVE THE
HELP THEY NEED.
SO THAT'S KIND OF BEEN IN GRASS
PATH INTO THE AMERICAN C.
RESPONSE SYSTEM.
AND WE'VE GOT A LOT OF OUTREACH
AND AND EFFORT.
RELATED TO THAT MOVING FORWARD
SO WE CAN MAKE SURE THAT THAT'S
RESILIENT AND REDUNDANT AND
FUNDED PROPERLY SO ONCE IT
ARRIVES AT THE PUBLIC SAFETY
ANSWERING POINT. THE NEXT PIECE
OF THE PUZZLE WOULD BE THE
COMMUNICATION THAT HAPPENS
BETWEEN THAT PUBLIC SAFETY
ANSWERING POINT AND THOSE THAT
ARE OUT IN THE FIELD RESPONDING.
SO THERE'S BASICALLY TWO PADS
THERE ONE IS MISSION CRITICAL
VOICE.
IT'S SHOWN ON THIS DIAGRAM IS
LAND MOBILE RADIO SO THIS YOU
MAY HAVE HEARD ALOMAR LAND
MOBILE RADIO TERMS OF THIS IS
THE RADIOS AT THE USE FOR
MISSION CRITICAL. VOICE
COMMUNICATIONS
AND A LOT OF THE INTER
OPERABILITY CONVERSATIONS THAT
WE HAVE CENTER AROUND THAT ABOUT
HAVING CALM AND.
VOICE CHANNELS TO TALK ONE TO
ANOTHER AND.
THAT WAS SOME SOME OF THE
CONVERSATION IN THE PREVIOUS
PANEL.
THAT'S SYSTEMS BEEN IN PLACE A
LONG TIME ITS HARDENED ITS
PUBLIC SAFETY GRADE IT SURVIVES
THROUGHOUT THESE DISASTERS AND
IT'S SOMETHING THAT'S ALWAYS
AVAILABLE. AND WAS AVAILABLE
THROUGHOUT EACH OF THESE
DISASTERS THAT HAVE BEEN
DISCUSSED TODAY.
THE OTHER PIECE IN KIND OF THE
CENTER OF THE DIAGRAM IS WHERE
FIRST NIGHT IS.
AND SO I'VE ALSO CALLED THAT
BROADBAND SERVICES BECAUSE
ESSENTIALLY THIS IS YOUR DATA
CONNECTION FROM THOSE EMERGENCY
RESPONDERS WHO NEED THIS DATA.
BACK INTO THE PUBLIC SAFETY
ANSWERING POINTS.
SO THAT INFORMATION PRIMARILY
INTERACTS WITH THEIR COMPUTER
AIDED DISPATCH
SO THIS IS THE DISPATCH SYSTEM
THAT THEY USE TO SEND THE
INFORMATION FROM THE DISPATCHER
OUT TO THOSE IN THE FIELD.
THAT'S ONE OF THE PRIMARY
PURPOSES OF FIRST NET NOW FIRST
THAT HAS A WHOLE BUNCH OF OTHER.
ADVANTAGES THAT WERE GOING TO
TALK ABOUT IN A MOMENT BUT
THAT'S THE PRIMARY PIECE.
AND THEN ALONG THE BOTTOM OF
THIS DIAGRAM YOU SEE ALERTS AND
WARNINGS AND I'VE GOT THAT
LITTLE CIRCLE DRAWN IN THERE
UNDER.
LOCAL AUTHORITY.
THE LOCAL AUTHORITY MAKES THE
DECISION ON HOW TO ISSUE THOSE
AND AND YOU HEARD I SHARE
FIFTEEN. TALK ABOUT HIS
SOLUTIONS IN HIS COUNTY AND ON.
DECEMBER FOURTH THAT LAKE
COUNTY SHERIFF WAS HERE TO GIVE
YOU SOME OF THE LESSONS LEARNED
OVER THE OVER THAT AND YOU
PROBABLY REMEMBER. SO THAT'S
THAT BOTTOM PIECE AND THERE'S A
NUMBER OF TOOLS THAT ARE IN THAT
TOOLBOX
AND EACH ONE HAS A SPECIFIC
PURPOSE TO REACH A CERTAIN GROUP
OF FOLKS.
BUT I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
EVERYONE UNDERSTANDS IT'S NOT
FOLLOWING A REVERSE PATH THROUGH
NINE ONE ONE EVEN THOUGH IT'S
CALLED REVERSE NINE ONE ONE
SOMETIMES.
SO THERE IS A DISTINCTION ON THE
PATH THAT IT TAKES TO GET BACK
TO THOSE THAT ARE RECEIVING THE
WARNING.
AND AND IT'S FAIRLY IMPORTANT
BECAUSE THE NETWORKS ARE
DIFFERENT.
SO THIS IS HOW THESE
TECHNOLOGIES ARE RELATED AND
OBVIOUSLY AT THE SENATE ABOUT
ALL THIS THE PUBLIC SAFETY
ANSWERING POINTS.
THE NEXT GRAPHIC IS IS TO HELP
UNDERSTAND THE CONNECTIONS
BETWEEN NEXT GEN NINE ONE ONE
ARE NEXT GENERATION NINE ONE ONE
AND FIRST NOW SO THAT'S THE NEXT
GRAPHIC.
AND YOU'LL NOTICE PROBABLY IN
THE CENTER OF THAT DIAGRAM
THERE'S THIS WHITE BUBBLE THAT
SAYS NEXT AND I'M ONE
INTEGRATION TO FIRST NET THERE'S
THIS INTEGRATION HAS TO HAPPEN.
NEXT GEN NINE ONE ONE WILL TAKE.
DATA RICH INFORMATION FROM THOSE
THAT NEED HELP AND SEND IT INTO
THE PUBLIC SAFETY ANSWERING
POINT THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
DESIGNING IT TO DO.
FIRST NOT HAS THE ABILITY TO
TAKE THAT INFORMATION A PUSH IT
OUT TO THE EMERGENCY RESPONDER
WHO MIGHT NEED THAT INFORMATION.
THERE'S A CRITICAL CONNECTION
HAS TO HAPPEN BETWEEN THOSE TWO
TECHNOLOGIES AT THE PUBLIC
SAFETY ANSWERING POINT.
IS THAT SOME OF THE EFFORTS THAT
ARE UNDER GO THAT WE'RE UNDER
UNDER WAY RIGHT NOW.
YOU NOTICE IN THE UPPER LEFT
HAND CORNER WE CAN HAVE TWO
COLUMNS THERE OF WHAT FIRST NET
IS TODAY RIGHT NOW.
AND THERE'S A ROLL OUT PLAN I
KNOW THAT EIGHTEEN TO INFER
CENTER PROBABLY GONNA TALK ABOUT
THIS IN THE NEXT PANEL. BUT
THERE'S SOME FEATURES THAT WILL
EVENTUALLY BE AVAILABLE ONE DAY
AND THERE SOME FEATURES THAT ARE
AVAILABLE TODAY RIGHT NOW AND
THERE'S A LITTLE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN THOSE TWO BECAUSE IT'S A
ROLL OUT PLAN.
THE OPTIM DECISION CAME IN DC ON
DECEMBER TWENTY EIGHTH. AND SO%
WERE FAIRLY NEW IN THIS PROCESS
AND SO RIGHT NOW PRIORITY IN
PREEMPTION. MEANING THAT IF
THERE'S A PUBLIC SAFETY
RESPONDER WHO SUBSCRIBE TO FIRST
NET.
THEY GET PRIORITY.
ACCESS INTO THE NETWORK AND IF
THAT CELL TOWERS CLOG PREEMPTION
SAYS THEY GET HEAD OF THE LINE
IN THE PUSH SOME OTHER LOWER
PRIOR TO USE OUR OFFICE OF THAT
THEY GET ACCESS.
THOSE ARE VERY IMPORTANT
FEATURES.
AS WE MOVE INTO THE FUTURE THE
AT THE CAUGHT THINGS WE'VE
IDENTIFIED IN THE NEXT COLUMN OR
SOME OF THINGS THAT CAL O. YES
IS GONNA BE WORKING IN A
PARTNERSHIP WITH A TNT AND FIRST
NET. TO MAKE SURE THAT THIS
FIRST NIGHT NETWORK ALSO
PROVIDES ALL THESE FEATURES AS
WELL BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT THAT'S
ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL TO.
SASSER FIRST NOW.
SO WITH THAT HIGH LEVEL OVERVIEW
I'M WILL TURN OVER TO THE BACK
OF IMAGE.
SO WE'RE LOOKING FORWARD TO
SEEING THE SEACOAST FEAR COME
WERE OPTIMISTIC ABOUT IT.
AND OBVIOUSLY CALAVERAS IS
DEEPLY INTEGRATED. AND WILL
CONTINUE TO BE SO.
A WITH FIRST MET AND WITH
EIGHTEEN T. AS THEY ROLL OUT.
MOST.
OF YOU ARE FAMILIAR WITH A
DRACULA SHE'S LETTER THAT
ACCOMPANIED THE GOVERNOR'S.
HOPPED IN DECISION DECEMBER
TWENTY EIGHTH. AND SO ON WE'RE
GOING TO CONTINUE IN THAT ROLE
AND IN LEADERSHIP CAPACITY TO
ENSURE.
THAT WERE A WORKING HAND IN
HAND AT THE BESA SERVICES
SEPARATE STATE CALIFORNIA.
BUT FORTY OR QUESTIONS OF
FOLLOWING THAT BUT.
TO SOME AUGUST WILL TURN OVER
TO ACHIEVE MARTINEZ.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS OF THAT
COMMITTEE I'M PRIVILEGED TO
SPEAK TO YOU TODAY.
.
AS I SIT HERE AND LISTEN TO THE
PREVIOUS.
PANEL MEMBERS I WONDER WHY I AM
SPEAKING IN. I'VE BEEN IN THE
PUBLIC SAFETY SERVICES FOR ABOUT
FORTY PLUS YEARS NOW THIRTY FIVE
OF WHICH WERE IN THE FIRE
SERVICE AND TWELVE OF THOSE
YEARS OF THE FIRE CHIEF.
HEARINGS ARE GOING TO COUNTY.
I ALSO SPENT EIGHT YEARS IN
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT SERVING AS
THE.
CHIEF OF LARGE SERVICES FOR THE
CITY AND COUNTY OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES AND ALSO FOR
YELLOW COUNTY.
I'M WELL THAT EXPERIENCE GIVE ME
SOME INSIGHT INTO PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMUNICATIONS MY REMARKS TODAY
ARE GONNA COME FROM SOME OTHER
EXPERIENCES.
A FOR THE LAST TWENTY YEARS.
I'VE PARTICIPATED.
WITH THE FEDERAL MERGING
MANAGEMENT'S AGENCY URBAN SEARCH
AND RESCUE PROGRAM.
SOME OF YOU MAY BE FAMILIAR
WITH THE PROGRAM IT WAS ACTUALLY
STARTED IN CALIFORNIA FOLLOWING
ON THE CREATOR.
AND THE MEXICO CITY EARTHQUAKE
AS ITS DESIGN IS REALLY TO DEAL
WITH.
VICTIMS OF A COLLAPSE RUPTURED
DURING EARTHQUAKES.
AND I KNOW WHEN I FIRST GOT
INVOLVED THAT BACK IN NINETEEN
NINETY TWO OUR FOCUS WAS SIMPLY
BEING PREPARED FOR EARTHQUAKES.
ON MY FIRST DAY OF BLUSH WITH.
NATIONAL DISASTERS WAS A FEW
YEARS LATER IN NINETEEN NINETY
FIVE WITH THE OKLAHOMA CITY
BOMBING.
MEMBERS THE SEPARATE AREA ALONG
WITH OTHER TEAMS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE WE HAVE A URBAN SEARCH
RESCUE TEAMS I SAY CALIFORNIA.
AND MANY THIS TEAM'S RESPONDED
TO BE.
BOMBING IN AN OKLAHOMA IN
NINETEEN NINETY FIVE IN FOR ME
AND FOR MANY OF MY COLLEAGUES
THAT WAS REALLY THE BEGINNING OF
OF THIS EVOLUTION THAT WE DEAL
WITH THE DAY AND THAT IS LOCAL
FIRST RESPONDERS.
FINDING THEMSELVES IN NOT ONLY
OTHER COMMUNITIES BETTER OTHER
STATES IN SOME CASES OTHER
COUNTRIES.
I HAVE TO ADMIT THAT IN
OKLAHOMA.
WELL AT THE TIME IT SEEMED LIKE
A LARGE EVENT IT WAS.
.
DEVASTATING. BUT THE FOOTPRINT
WAS MUCH SMALLER.
M. MY FIRST.
REAL.
I ATTENTION DE INTER OPERABILITY
LACK OF IN OUR REALLY ARE
FAILURE COMMUNICATION WAS IN
NINETEEN NINETY SIX AND THAT WAS
AT HURRICANE FRAN HURTING FRIEND
CAME TO THE CAROLINAS.
PRETTY GOOD SWATH I WAS PART OF
A AND A TEAM THAT WENT TO DO
SEARCH AND RESCUE.
ON THE CAROLINA COAST SOUTH
CAROLINA SPECIFICALLY. THE FIRST
TIME THAT I EXPERIENCED MEANS
SET DOWN THE COMMUNITY AND
SUDDENLY GOING FROM A RESPONDER
TO SOMEONE.
NEEDING SOME RESCUE AT OURSELVES
WE WERE TOTALLY WITHOUT
COMMUNICATION AT THAT TIME.
OR OUTSIDE OF OUR LITTLE SPHERE
COMMUNICATION CONSISTED OF
CELLULAR.
AND I NEED TO TELL YOU THAT I'M
NOT A COMMUNICATIONS SPECIALIST
OR TECHNICIAN OR AN EXPERT I AM
IN USERS AND WHEN. YOU RELY ON A
SINGLE VEHICLE TO COMMUNICATE
AND IT FAILS.
IT'S STARTLING AT FIRST.
I WISH I COULD SAY THAT WAS THE
ONLY TIME I FACE THAT.
BUT A IN TWO THOUSAND FIVE HER
CANE KATRINA.
I FOUND MYSELF IN THE STATE OF
MISSISSIPPI. AND WHILE WE HAD.
MIGRATED FROM CELLULAR SOLELY TO
CELLULAR AND SATELLITE PHONES.
AGAIN IN TWO THOUSAND FIVE I
WAS RESPONSIBLE WITH EIGHT
HUNDRED.
SEARCH AND RESCUE PERSONNEL IN
GULFPORT MISSISSIPPI WE WERE.
WORKING ABOUT THIRTY FIVE TO
FORTY MILES OF COASTAL FRONT AND
A WE WERE WITHOUT COMMUNICATION
THAT PART OF THAT TIME.
THE SAME THING HAPPENING
GREENBERG KANSAS IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVEN AND I COULD GO ON.
THE POINT IS IS.
EARLIER YOU HEARD FROM THE
OTHER PANEL MEMBERS IT TALKED
ABOUT AND INTER OPERABILITY
WITHIN THE COMMUNITY I COME FROM
SACRAMENTO COUNTY WE HAVE A VERY
ROBUST AND COMMUNICATION NETWORK
THAT ALL. FIRST RESPONDERS AND
OUR SUPPORT.
MATRIX.
HAS A VERY ROBUST.
IN A COMPETE MEDICATION
ABILITIES.
RADIOS.
BUT I'M SPEAKING TO MORE IS THE
ABILITY TO TO HAVE THAT TO HAVE
COMMUNICATION OUTSIDE OF THAT
RADIO NETWORK.
WHETHER YOU TALK ABOUT KATRINA
ARE GREENBERG OR HER CAN'T FRAN
OR THE DOZEN OTHER HER KIDS IN
TWENTY YEARS I'VE GONE TO WHAT
HAPPENS IS YOU'RE UNABLE TO.
PROVIDE SITUATIONAL AWARENESS
AND EARLIER PANEL MEMBER THAT A
MISSION THAT. THE INABILITY TO
CONTACT OUTSIDE THE IMPACTED
AREA TO SAY WE NEED THIS
OPEN THIS IS WHAT IT LOOKS LIKE
HERE.
THE INABILITY TO ASK FOR
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES INABILITY
TO RECEIVE RESUPPLY.
WITH THE SEVENTY EIGHT HER.
.
FIRST WATER PERSONAL AHEAD IN
HER CANE KATRINA ONE OF OUR
BIGGEST COMPLICATIONS WAS FEEL.
I MEAN WE LITERALLY MADE PARDEE
DECISIONS ON BECAUSE WE DIDN'T
APPEAL TO GET OUT THERE AND GET
BACK.
WHEN WE SENT TEAMS OUT TO THE
FIELD WE DIDN'T HAVE A WAITED TO
COMMUNICATE WITH THEM BECAUSE WE
ALWAYS WOULD SET UP A LOCAL
RADIO NETWORK.
.
WE STILL HAD NO OTHER
COMMUNICATION VEHICLES AND THEN
EVEN CALLING A BACK TO DC TO
FEMA PROPER AND SAY THIS IS WHAT
WE NEED LONG TERM OVER THE WEEKS
AHEAD.
I'M.
AS YOU LOOK FORWARD IN THIS
VERDANT FIRST THAT COMES ON LINE
I'M SURE THAT THEY'RE GOING TO
HAVE SOLUTIONS TO MANY OF THESE.
BUT I WOULD AS A AS A LOCAL FIRE
CHIEF IS SPENT. TWELVE YEARS
MANAGING A LOCAL FIRE BUDGET. I
WOULD JUST ASK YOU TO ME. TO
CONSIDER AND ALL ALL PARTIES ARE
GOING FOR THAT.
FOR THOSE OF US THAT ARE
INVOLVED AS FIRST RESPONDERS ARE
SOLUTION NEEDS TO BE ROBUST AND
REDUNDANT. IT NEEDS TO BE
AFFORDABLE.
WE NEED AN EASY MAINTAIN.
.
IT NEEDS TO BE PROVEN TECHNOLOGY
SOMETHING THAT WE CAN RELY ON
AND IT'S EASY TO USE KNOW WHAT
I'VE SEEN.
OVER THE LAST FORTY.
THREE YEARS.
IS THAT TECHNOLOGY IS INFLUENCE
WHAT WE DO. FAR FIREFIGHTERS AND
POLICE OFFICERS IN EMS PERSONNEL
AND MERGING MANAGE IT WE WE HAVE
INTEGRATED APPROPRIATE LIKE WE
HAVE IN OUR OWN HOMES.
TECHNOLOGY AND EVERYTHING WE DO
HOWEVER WHEN TECHNOLOGY FAILS.
OR THE SUPPORTING ASPECTS OF
THAT POWER.
WHICH HAS BEEN A PROBLEM.
.
WE BECOME RELIANT ON IT AND THEN
WE HAVE AVOID.
.
I'M NOT GONNA REPEAT I THINK
SHARE TEAM POINT OUT.
VERY WELL HOW MANY OF OUR
COUNTIES ARE USING.
THINGS LIKE EVER BRIDGE FOR
PUBLIC NOTIFICATION A LAYERED
EFFECT.
.
AND I THINK FOR ME MANY NOT ALL
OF OUR OUR COMMUNITIES HAVE A A
PRETTY STRONG LOCAL NETWORK FOR
RADIO COMMUNICATION.
I'M NOT EXPECTING THAT VIDEO.
STREAMING.
ONLINE CHATTING.
TEXT MESSAGING OR ANYTHING ELSE.
I WOULD REALLY HAVE HOUSTON JUST
ABOUT EVERY CIRCUMSTANCE I HAVE
BEEN IN SOME VOICE COMMUNICATION
THE ABILITY TO TALK TO SOMEBODY.
WOULD HAVE BEEN REALLY IMPORTANT
HAD TO COMMUNICATE FOR BOTH AND
NEEDS AND THEN FOR RECOVERY.
PRESIDENT BRIEFLY STATED.
CALIFORNIA HAS A VERY ROBUST
MUTUAL AID PROGRAM.
OVER THE YEARS WE'VE MANAGED TO
COBBLE TOGETHER A RADIO NETWORK
THAT WORKS IN FIRES. MANY OF
OUR.
FIRE COMPANIES ON LARGE WHILE
AND FIRES DO IT A GOOD JOB OF
COMMUNICATING A USING WHATEVER
IS AVAILABLE. BUT AS YOU GO
FORWARD WITH FIRST AND I WOULD
HOPE THAT THAT WOULD BE EXTENDED
SO THAT IN THESE DARK SPOTS THAT
WE HAVE IN OUR STATE THAT
THEY'RE GOING TO BE DISASTROUS
AND YOU THE ADDRESS.
THAT FIRST RESPONDERS REGARDLESS
OF THEIR DISCIPLINE WILL HAVE
THE ABILITY TO COMMUNICATE AND
BE SUPPORTED.
THANK YOU FOR COMMENTS ON.
THE THE FOLKS IT RESPONDED TO
BOTH THE NORTHERN CALIFORNIA AND
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA FIREFIGHTERS
AND POLICE TO SAY THAT MY SON IS
A. IS A FIREFIGHTER AS IS MY
STEPDAUGHTER. AND SO I WILL TAKE
THOSE BACK HOME AND THEY WILL BE
APPRECIATIVE.
WITH THAT I AGAIN MY EXPERIENCE
IS A. BIT LONG IN THE TOOTH BUT
I'D BE HAPPY TO TRY TO ANSWER.
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY.
OPEN UP THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
OF.
MISS RODRIGUEZ.
YES HAVE A QUESTION FOR BOTH FOR
BOTH FROM BOTH PANELS.
FIRST OF ALL. ON THE SHE YOU'RE
SURE KNOWS THE SECOND REGARDING
IMMIGRATION NEXT GEN NINE ONE
FIRST NOT.
SO HAVE YOU HAVE THE DIAGRAM OR.
FROM THE AGAINST THE TOWER OF
THE COMMUNICATION GOING TO
POLICE FIRE.
BACK AND FORTH.
SELECT.
AT THE ALMONDS IS THERE GOING TO
BE AWAY WERE THE PRIVATE SECTOR
EMS IS GOING TO BE ABLE.
COMMUNICATE DIRECTLY WITH
FIRE OR PDA AS THEY CURRENTLY
SHOWING AND YOU HAVE YOUR
GRAPHIC HERE.
IS THE REASON WHY THAT'S NOT.
AN AREA THAT WE'RE LOOKING OUT
BECAUSE IT'S OF VERY IMPORTANT
THEY'RE THEY'RE TRANSPORTING
THAT THE PEOPLE THAT ARE SICK
AND INJURED THAT.
BE ABLE TO HAVE A COMMUNICATION
WITH THE PUBLIC SAFETY IS OUR
CANOES ELABORATE ON THEM.
YEAH SO THAT THE GOAL OF THE
GRAPHIC WAS TO BE.
NOT OVERWHELM WITH DATA BECAUSE
IF WE WERE TO SHOW EVERY
APPLICATION THAT POTENTIALLY
COULD RUN OVER FIRST NAT. OR
OVER A BROADBAND SERVICE AT THE
WHOLE PAGE WILL BE FULL SO
ABSOLUTELY ALL OF THOSE
APPLICATIONS THAT ARE NEEDED TO
SUPPORT MISSION CRITICAL DATA
FLOW AN INSTANT RESPONSE. THAT'S
WHAT WE INTENDED TO TO REPRESENT
WITH THAT LITTLE GRAPHIC THERE.
SO APOLOGIZE IT'S A LITTLE
SPARSE.
NO NOT JUST THAT IT JUST GOES
FROM FROM MY PERSONAL
EXPERIENCES WORKING IT IN.
THE PRIVATE SECTOR AND WAS
INDUSTRIES HOW.
YOU NO WE TALK ABOUT SOME OF
JUST THE WEBER. BIG BUS CRSH OR
SOMETHING AND SOMETIMES THAT
COMMUNICATION IS NOT REALLY
RELATE TO THE PRIVATE SECTOR
WERE SOME AGENCIES ARE
CONTRACTED OUT WITH THE PRIVATE
SECTOR YOU MUST PROVIDE. OF THE
TRANSPORT EARNED AND THEN I'M IN
THERE.
ELLIS SERVICEABLE SPEAK
AND AND WHAT THAT THE WHICH ONE
TO SEE THAT WOMEN IN WHAT TO.
GETS
RICK MARTINEZ TALKING ABOUT YOUR
EXPERIENCES AND KATRINA AND READ
I WAS THERE AS WELL I SPENT FOUR
WEEKS THERE.
AND COMMUNICATION IS VITAL. YOU
KNOW WE HAD A MILITARY RADIO
THAT WAS GIVEN TO US.
AND THEY WERE SO YOU GO TO THIS
SECTION YOU CAN IS THERE FOR
TWENTY FOUR HOURS.
BUT IN NO WAY TO COMMUNICATE IN
THE MONEY WE DID OUR DO OUT JOB.
BUT I LOOK BACK AT MY EXPENSES
THERE THAT.
THAT'S STATE THOUGHT THEY WERE
READY TO HANDLE DISASTER.
WHEN THIS HER KINGS CAME THERE
WERE TOTALLY TAKEN OFF.
OFFICE YOU SAYING THAT THE THE
INSTANCES OCCURRED THURMOND.
INFRASTRUCTURE IS GONE. YOU KNOW
WHAT AND WHEN IT CAME TO VITAL
SERVICES IN MASS WIT IMPROVISING
DO THINGS WE NORMALLY ARE USED
TO DOING.
SO HOPEFULLY AS LESSONS LEARNED
FROM THEIR TONE OUT OF FIRES WE
HAD LAST YEAR IN THE STATE AND
WHAT'S NEXT GENERATIONS OF NINE
ONE ONE. FIRST AND EVERYTHING
ELSE
THAT THE SYSTEMS ARE REALLY
SYSTEM THAT EVERYBODY CAN RELY
ON AND AND. HOPE WE DON'T HAVE
THOSE DEAD ZONES AS WE REFERRED
IT YOU KNOW I'M TALKING ABOUT I
THINK EVERYBODY COMMUNITY KNOWS
THAT THERE CERTAIN PARTS IN OUR
CITIES OR COUNTIES OR THERE'S
DEAD ZONES WHERE YOU CAN'T
COMMUNICATE BECAUSE OF.
THE LOCATION ARTS OUT AND
HOPEFULLY WITH THESE NEW SYSTEMS
THAT WE CAN GET RID OF THAT'S WE
KNOW NO MATTER WHERE AT IN A ROW
ERROR DOWN URBAN CITY THAT WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE. GOOD WAYS TO
COMMUNICATE TO JUST WANDER BRING
THAT FORD IS WELL.
THANK YOU A DOCTOR PAN.
THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH I
APPRECIATE YOUR PRESENTATION.
YES WHEN I QUESTIONS HAS TO DO.
WITH NO TALK ABOUT
INFRASTRUCTURE IN COURSE IN A
DISASTER YOU MADE LOSE
INFRASTRUCTURE RIGHT SO WHAT
HAPPENS IS THAT.
WE SIT THERE WILL PREPARE YOU
HAVE.
CELL TOWERS YOU OF RADIO TOWERS
IT'S UNDER.
THE BE GOOD NOW THEY LOSE POWER
ETCETERA.
WHAT IT AND?
MAYBE IT'S FOR THE FOLKS WHO
FOLLOWED THE NEXT AIRBAGS. TO
TERMS OF.
WHAT'S OUR CAPACITY TO REBUILD
A COMMUNICATIONS STRUCTURE FROM
GROUND UP.
THANK YOU NO CAN'T IT SIR I MEAN
WE TALK ABOUT. THE.
IS THERE TECHNOLOGICAL
APPROACHES SO THAT.
YOU YOU SAID THAT A WAXED PAPER
DRONE OUT THERE NOW THAT'S THE
CELL TOWER BECAUSE THE CELL
TOWERS ON THE GROUND OF ALL DAY
AND YOU KNOW THE THE POWERS OR
SOMETHING.
SO.
AND THEN YOU TALK ABOUT. DARK
SPOTS WELL THE CHALLENGES IS
THAT.
MAYBE SO I JUST DID WHAT BUT THE
INVESTMENT TO FINALLY FELL IN
THE DARK ABOUT THE NOW
DIVERGENCES THERE CAN YOU
SUDDENLY SET UP A QUICK
COMMUNICATIONS LINK TO THAT DARK
SPOT I MEAN YOU DON'T HAVE TIME
TO WAIT FOR SOMEONE TO BUILD
SOMETHING RIGHT. AND THE SEND
SOME WINE OUT THERE SO IS IT. IS
THAT'S SOMETHING WE'RE WORKING
ON AND TERMS OF BEING ABLE TO
REALLY LIKE I COME UP WITH
COMMUNICATIONS SOLUTIONS THAT
CAN BE SET UP AND YOU KNOW.
THE FEW HOURS OR SOMETHING AND
AND AND AND A PLACE AND THEN
HOOK IT INTO THE.
THE MAIN EIGHT THAT I WOULD
THINK THAT THAT'S A KIND OF
CAPABILITY WE SHOULD BE LOOKING
INTO.
SO IT'S A GREAT QUESTION.
.
OBVIOUSLY IT DEPENDS ON THE TYPE
OF EVENT HAD THAT CAUSES THE
OTHER DAMAGE AND SO THE FIRES
WERE OBVIOUSLY UNIQUE
ENVIRONMENT WHERE YOU.
DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO GO BACK
AND REBUILD. OUR YOU WOULD NEED
THAT THAT COVERAGE IN BECAUSE.
YOU HEARD IT MENTIONED BEFORE
THE TOPOGRAPHY AND GEOGRAPHY THE
STATE.
THAT THOSE THEIR SOULS KEY
MOUNTAIN TOPS ARE OBVIOUSLY THE
BEST POINTS. AT THE PLACE I
INFRASTRUCTURE OF FORESTS AND IF
YOU CAN'T ACCESS THEM.
OF COURSE IT DOESN'T WORK AS
WELL HAVING SAID THAT. COME.
ARE PARTNERS IN THE COMMUNITY
THEY CAN TALK ABOUT IT MORE IN
THEIR IN THEIR PERIOD. HARM TO
ENGAGE IN A SERIES OF DEPLOYABLE
AS THEY TRY TO BRING IN PART TO
PROVIDE. SOME ACCESS FOR US INTO
TO REPLICATE WHEN.
INFRASTRUCTURE IS DAMAGED.
AND THAT CAN WORK ARE REALLY
WELL IF THERE'S WHAT THEY CALL
BACK CALL BEHIND IT ALONE
FISCALLY CAN.
A DROP RIGHT IN AND AND ACTUALLY
MIMIC IT RIGHT BEHIND IT. IF
THERE'S NOT BACK CALL THEN
THERE'S SOME LIMITATIONS IN
TERMS OF.
WHO WILL SUPPORT WORKS REALLY
WELL FOR MAYBE A SMALL COMMITTEE
FIRST RESPONDERS? NOT SO GOOD IF
YOU'RE TRYING TO REPLICATE OF
THE ENTIRE GENERAL POPULATION
SO.
THEY CAN.
TALK TO MORE THAT BUT THE
ANSWER QUESTIONS EVERYBODY'S
TRYING TO. FIND SOLUTIONS THAT
ARE BETTER THE KEEP THERE'S
CONSTANTLY APPROACHING. US WITH
THE NEW TECHNOLOGIES OF THE
CHINA AND PLACE AN AND. NUMBER
OF SEE SUPPORTIVE OF THAT.
THANK YOU MS SAGER CURRY.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON SO AS MANY OF
THOSE YOU SITTING THERE NO MY
BIG THING ABOUT FIRST THAT.
YOU KNOW THIS IS BACK IN TWO
THOUSAND TWELVE IT FIRES AND
WINTERS CALIFORNIA WE DIDN'T
HAVE CELLPHONES WE DIDN'T HAVE
ANY WALKIE TALKIES THE LAND
LINES WERE DOWN AND WE COULD
PREVENT A LOT OF FIRE.
AND THAT'S WHEN I WENT AFTER
FIRST THAT MONEY.
AND I'M FRUSTRATED SITTING HERE
TODAY THAT WE ARE IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN AND NOTHING
HAS REALLY HAPPENED.
NOW I'M NOT GONNA POINT FINGERS
AT ANYONE BECAUSE I KNOW THERE'S
A LOT OF BUREAUCRACY BEHIND THIS
BUT MY FRUSTRATION IS THAT HOW
WE'RE GOING TO DEPLOY THIS WITH
THE TIMELINE.
I THINK NOW WE ARE IN THE
SITUATION THAT WE ARE ALL BACK
PEDDLING ON. AND MY LOOK AT THIS
AND I SAY WELL THAT SEEM MARCH
SEVENTEENTH. TWO THOSE SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN TO GOT THE CONTRACT
WITH THAT'S GREAT I'M THAT GUY
THAT'S MOVING ALONG. BUT IT
WASN'T UNTIL DECEMBER TWENTIETH
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN THE
CALIFORNIA DECIDED POPPED INTO
FIRST KNOW WHAT TOOK SO LONG.
IF YOU HAVE THAT I'M MAD LOVE TO
KNOW WHAT TOOK SO LONG FOR THIS
TO HAPPEN.
BECAUSE IT'S JUST SO.
YOU KNOW HERE WE ARE AND MAYBE
SOME OF THIS COULD HAVE BEEN
DEPLOYED. I'M DOES TALK ABOUT
ONE TIME THAT IT WOULD BE BUTTE
DEPLOYED SINCE WAS THROUGH THAT
A FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. WE
DEPLOYED ON FEDERAL BUILDINGS
WELL THAT MADE A LOT OF SENSE TO
ME BECAUSE YOU PUT ON TOP OF A
DAM YOU COULD PUT HIM ON TOP OF.
YOU KNOW DIFFERENT FEDERAL
BUILDINGS TO AT LEAST GET IT
GOING.
AND SO.
MY FRUSTRATION ISN'T WITH YOU
IS JUST WITH WHAT HAPPENED ALONG
THE LEHIGH.
AND I'M NOT I'M. JUST LIKE.
HERE WE ARE. AND MAYBE WE COULD
OF ADDRESS SOME OF THIS LONG
ALONG THE WAY. IT SEEMS LIKE WE
ALWAYS HAVE TO GO BACK AND START
THIS ALL OVER AGAIN.
SO. IF YOU WOULDN'T MIND JUST
HELPING ME OUT AND DO YOU KNOW
OF ANYONE THAT IS ACTUALLY
DEPLOYED TO SHUT.
I CAN BUT LET BUDGET TALK ABOUT
BUT.
BE AND FOURTEEN WHEN YOU TALK
ABOUT THE DEPLOYMENT.
OF IT SPECIFICALLY FOR THAT. AT
SPECTRUM THAT'S BEING USED.
IT IN EIGHTEEN T. CAN ANSWER
THAT FOR AS WELL BECAUSE THEY'RE
OBVIOUSLY.
NOW THAT.
THE STATE'S OPTED EN AND OTHER
STATES HAVE THEIR STARTING THEN
INSTALLATION SO THEY CAN TELL
YOU WHAT THEIR TIMELINE IS IN.
HOW THAT'S GOING TO ROLL OUT FOR
YOU? I WILL SAY THAT. ARE FOR
CALIFORNIA WE CERTAINLY HAD
HARDLINE SUSPENSE IS THAT WE HAD
TO COMPLY WITH WITHIN.
.
I NATIONALLY AND MOST OF US WERE
IN AND VERY.
.
DELICATE NEGOTIATIONS
SPECIFICALLY WHAT WE WANTED FOR
CALIFORNIA.
SO.
IF YOU.
YOU HAVE THE SELECTION OF
EIGHTEEN TO FURTHER PLANTING OF
FORGETTING THE CONTRACT.
AND THEN FOLLOWING THAT.
FEW MONTHS LATER IS WHEN THEY
CAME OUT STATES WITH THE PLAN.
AND THEY ROLLED OUT THAT PLAN TO
US.
AND AT THAT POINT TIME WE.
HAD BEEN MEETING WITH OUR OUR
REPRESENTATIVES IN OUR
STAKEHOLDERS AND WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE WERE GETTING. IN
ACCEPTING THE BEST PLAN POSSIBLE
FOR YOU. AYE EARLY OFTEN.
WOULD ADMIT THAT WE'RE
ACCEPTING THE VERY FIRST BROWN.
NEGOTIATION
AND SO HOW WE SAT DOWN AND WENT
THROUGH A SERIES OF PRIORITIES
THAT WERE IMPORTANT FOR
CALIFORNIA.
AND MADE SURE THAT WE WERE ABLE
TO TRY TO ADDRESS EACH OF THOSE
PRIORITIES WITH US AND SO THAT
ITERATE THAT.
HOW THOSE ITERATIONS WERE A
SWING BACK AND FORTH WITH
EIGHTEEN T. WITH WHAT WE WANTED
COUNTER PROPOSALS ALONG WITH
WHAT THEY WERE GOING TO?
OBLIGED TO BECAUSE ONCE THEY
SUBMITTED THAT FINAL PLAN TO
CALIFORNIA THAT IS THE
ENFORCEABLE PLAN. THAT FIRST NET
WILL HOLD EIGHTEEN TO
ACCOUNTABLE FOR FOR THE BILL OUT
FOR ALL OF US.
AND SO.
AN EARLY AND EARLY YES.
.
I DON'T A CHRIS HAS MY FULL
STATES BUT ORDER SIMPLY SAY IF
YOU ACCEPTED THE FIRST PLAN
WITHOUT GETTING IN NEGOTIATION
ON THINGS ARE MOST IMPORTANT TO
YOU. YOU MAY NOT HAVE GOTTEN THE
BEST.
POSSIBLE SOLUTION FOR YOUR
STATE.
SENATE JACKSON AND I THINK
THAT'S ACTUALLY A NICE SEGUE I
I'VE READ THE LETTER BY.
DIRECTOR KILLER DO CHIEF WHO I
THINK WE CAN ALL AGREE IS DONE
EXTRAORDINARY JOB FOR.
ALL OF A SUDDEN. UP I NOTE HERE.
THAT.
.
ESPECIALLY THE FIRST PAGES
SUTTER SO EXACTLY THRILLED. WITH
THE WAY THIS.
SORT OF EVOLVED SAYING THAT. WE
BASICALLY.
DIDN'T HAVE A WHOLE LOT OF
CHOICE
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE POLITICS
WERE I JUST KNOW THAT. HE'S NOT
VERY HAPPY AND I'M GOING TO BE
ASKING OUR FIRST THAT PEOPLE.
TO RESPOND TO SOME OF.
THE CONCERNS THAT HE EXPRESSED.
PARTICULARLY.
.
WHETHER OR NOT THEY ARE
ADDRESSING THE THREE CONCERNS
ONE BEING INTER OPERABILITY. OF
THE SECOND BEING SECURITY THIS.
ACTUALLY.
.
DOESN'T.
APPARENTLY DOESN'T HAVE.
TO GIVE ACCESS TO OUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT PEOPLE TO USE THESE.
THE CLUTCH SYSTEM IN THE OTHER
CRIMINAL JUSTICE INFORMATION
SYSTEMS WHICH I KNOW MY
COLLEAGUE IS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
COOPER IS WELL AWARE OF AND.
VERY IMPORTANT IN THE WORK THAT
THAT HE AND OTHER LAW
ENFORCEMENT PEOPLE DO AND HAVE
DONE. AND THEN THE THIRD ITEM.
IS HARDENING.
IS THE POINT THAT YOU KNOW THE
CELLULAR SITES AS YOU MENTIONED
THIS IS BEEN PART OF THE
PROBLEM.
UP IN THE HILLS WHICH HAVE BEEN
THE FIRST THING THE GOAL WHEN I
THINK ALSO WERE IN THE NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA FIRES. WE KNOW CELL
TOWERS GO WEEK WE LOSE WE LOSE
COMMUNICATION.
AND SO WE NEED THAT RESILIENCY
IN THE REDUNDANCY AND AS I
UNDERSTAND THAT'S WHAT THIS.
PROGRAM IS SUPPOSED TO PROVIDE.
AND YET THERE IS CONCERN THAT
THAT ISN'T NECESSARILY WHAT HAS
BEEN OFFERED SO I'M.
I WOULD I'D LIKE TO ASK YOU.
MISTER I'M A DAVID CHIU I HOPE
I'VE GOT THAT RIGHT AYE IS SO
HAVE YOU BEEN CONTINUING TO WORK
ON THAT AND I WILL. SHARE THAT
MY I'M GOING TO ASK THOSE VERY
SAME QUESTIONS TO OUR.
FIRST MET PEOPLE WHAT THEY'RE
DOING TO ADDRESS THOSE CONCERNS
BECAUSE.
I THINK THEY'RE LEGITIMATE AND I
THINK THEY'RE APPROPRIATE FOR
CALIFORNIA AND WE HAVE LEARNED
AGAIN SOME OF THE LESSONS
LEARNED ESOS TOWERS OF GONE OUT.
WITH THE FIRES AND.
HOW ARE WE GOING TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAVE THAT REDUNDANCY AND
RESILIENCY THAT THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA? AFFECTIVELY PAYING
FOR AND EXPECT.
SO COULD YOU KIND OF UPDATE US
ON THAT.
GOING FORWARD NOT GOING BACK
WHICH WERE GOING FORWARD. YES.
SINCE.
THE.
OFTEN A DECISION WAS MADE WE'VE
HAD A SERIES OF MEETINGS WITH A
WITH A TNT AND I CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THEM. OF THE EXAMPLES
THAT.
YOU.
YOU'VE MENTIONED WITH SIX HOURS
IN THE NOW SIX DAYS IN WHICH ARE
TALKING ABOUT. HOW?
?
HOW LONG CAN YOU OPERATE NOW
WITHOUT POWER AND AND AND ACCESS
IN AND TO THOSE AREAS AND SO?
OBVIOUSLY WE WANT THE MOST
RESILIENT SYSTEM POSSIBLE THAT'S
WHAT OUR EFFORTS ARE.
TO WORK WITH ANYA EIGHTEEN T.
INFERS THAT CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH US AND.
HAVE.
INDICATED THAT THEY'RE GOING TO.
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THE SITE
HARDENING OTHERS A SOLUTION WITH
THAT MOTION FOR THE FOR THE
KLUTZ ACCESS.
.
OUR BIGGEST ISSUE IS THAT WE
WANTED IT DONE IT SHOULD BE A AN
ADDITIONAL CHARGE.
AND SO THEY'VE COME FOR WITH A
GOOD SOLUTION FORCE VERSION
THINK THAT THE.
THE SHOP TO PAY FOR IT SHOULD BE
PART OF YOUR SERVICE PACKAGE AND
SO.
OF SO YOU CAN IMAGINE WERE.
WORKING THAT ADD TOGETHER
JOINTLY.
ON OUR NEGOTIATION SO FOR THAT
TRYING TO FIND WHAT'S BEST FOR
OUR STAKEHOLDERS.
AND THEN THE INTER OPERABILITY
PIECE.
IS STILL SOMETHING THAT WERE
TRYING TO ADDRESS A LOT AREAS
THAT.
ARE GOING TO BE USING VERIZON
SERVICE.
FOR AWHILE NOW WHILE EIGHTEEN
HE BUILDS OUT HEATHER
INFRASTRUCTURE. AND SO ON IN
THOSE AREAS WE WERE HOPING TO
HAVE SOME SORT OF IN OUR ABILITY
PIECE AND.
THEY'VE COMMITTED TO LEASE A
MAINTENANCE DISCUSSIONS AND
WHERE POSSIBLE WORK WITH US.
FROM IT SO BUDGET EARNING I'VE
MISSED ON THAT.
YEAH SO I THINK THAT'S PART OF
WHAT WE REALLY FOCUSED ON DURING
THE NEGOTIATIONS AND SO
EVERYTHING THAT YOU SEE
HIGHLIGHTED IN THAT LETTER WERE
NEGOTIATION PIECES WE WERE
TRYING TO GET.
AND WARRANT AS X. SUCCESSFUL AS
I WANTED TO BE.
KNOWING THE NEEDS OF THE
STAKEHOLDERS IN AND REALLY
THAT'S THE TAKEAWAY.
WE LISTENED TO THOSE THAT ARE
GOING TO BE USING THE SYSTEM TO
IDENTIFY WHAT THEY REALLY NEEDED
TO HAVE IN THE SYSTEM. AND WE
COMMUNICATED THAT BACK THAT WAS
THE FOCUS OF OUR EFFORT.
AND SO AS WE COMMUNICATED THAT
BACK YOU CAN YOU CAN IMAGINE
THERE IS A GIVE AND TAKE AND
WHERE WE ENDED UP IS WITH THESE
GAPS THAT WE'VE GOT TO ADDRESS
NOW IN THE DEPLOYMENT. AND
THAT'S REALLY WHAT WE'RE WORKING
ON IN OUR PARTNERSHIP WITH WITH
A TNT AND FIRST MET TO ADDRESS
THESE REMAINING GAPS AS THEY
ROLL OUT THE SYSTEM.
YOU I'M.
GO GO AHEAD SORRY I JUST TRY TO
FIGURE OUT WHO RAISE THEIR HAND
AT THE FOR FOR CHRISTMAS.
GO AHEAD PLEASE.
ALL YOU MISTER MEDICAL*.
MY PRONOUNCE IT RIGHT.
MEDICAL WHICH OKAY GREAT THANK
YOU I. I WAS JUST WONDER IF WE
COULD.
CIRCLE BACK A LITTLE BIT.
ON MAYBE SOME LOW TECH
ALTERNATIVES AND I DON'T KNOW TO
WHAT DEGREE THIS IS REALISTIC
BUT.
CB RADIOS AND HAM RADIO I
WONDER IF THESE ARE OPTIONS THAT
ARE AVAILABLE FOR COMMUNICATIONS
IN THE NOW IN THE EVENT OF AN
EMERGENCY WHERE EVERYTHING GOES
DOWN.
THE ANSWER IS YES WE AYE I MEAN
ARE RESPONDED COMMUNITY USES
EVERYTHING AND WE STILL HAVE
FELLOW HAM OPERATORS.
AS PART OF OUR.
.
I WOULD SAY NO WHEN YOU GO FROM.
YOUR PRIMARY COMMUNICATIONS
USUALLY AS ON YOUR ON YOUR VOICE
IN YOUR INTERNET THAT YOU'RE
USING IT HAVE FORM. THEN YOU'RE
GOING TO CELLULAR AS YOUR
SECONDARY BACKUP NO WE HAVE
SATELLITE COMMUNICATIONS THAT WE
USE IN OUR TERTIARY. BUT I WILL
TELL YOU THAT. AND IN WE SLAM
OVER RADIOS AND THEN WE GO INTO.
AND WE START REALLY GETTING
INTO.
THE ALL WAY TO THAT POINT
WEAVES LOW TECH A SERVICES
BECAUSE.
EVERY TOOL COUNTS AND SO
SOMETIMES YOU HAVE TO HAVE. OF
THAT ONE THAT'S GOING TO
CONTINUE TO WORK FOR YOU AND AND
AND. BE ABLE TO.
ENHANCE THE SITUATION TO WORK
IN FRONT OF.
GREAT THANK YOU.
TO GET A COUPLE MORE QUESTIONS
AND I'M GONNA ASK US TO MOVE ON
SO HERE'S WHO I HAVE AG YOU'RE
CURRENTLY MON ENABLE MUSLIM OWN
AND THEN MISTER COOPER UNLESS I
MISS SOME.
ON THIS RODRIGUEZ AND I'LL JUST
ASK FOR BREVITY SO WE CAN
CONTINUE TO MOVE TOKYO.
BE SURE.
OKAY.
THANK YOU.
MISTER COOPER I I'M SORRY.
OBVIOUSLY MOON THE MISS COOPER.
THANK YOU THAT SO THAT THE.
WE WERE TALKING ABOUT FUTURE
THREATS AND IMPLICATIONS FOR
CALIFORNIA AND AM IN THE LAST.
PANEL ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
WAS MENTIONED WAS.
HOW WE DID IN TERMS OF GETTING
COMMUNICATION AND SPANISH
ACCORDING TO THE LAST CENSUS
FORTY FOUR PERCENT OF
CALIFORNIANS AS SPEAK A LANGUAGE
OTHER THAN?
ENGLISH AT HOME.
HOW DO WE BRING THAT FORTY FOUR
PERCENT ALONG IN THE
COMMUNICATIONS DO YOU HAVE IDEAS
IF SO WHAT ARE THOSE IDEAS?
SO ON THAT THE PEACE COME IN ON
NEXT GEN NINE ONE ONE WE HAVE AT
THE PUBLIC SAFETY ANSWERING
POINT OF FOREIGN LANGUAGE
SERVICE THAT WE OFFERED EVERY
PUBLIC SAFETY ANSWERING POINT.
AND THAT CONTRACT IS VERY
SPECIFIC THE TOP FIVE.
LANGUAGES ARE ACCOMMODATED
WITHIN YOU KNOW SECONDS OF WHEN
IT COMES AND AND THEN THE REST
HAVE A LONGER DURATION. AND SO
ON THE AND THE INGRESS PATH YOU
THINK ABOUT THE PACKED COMING IN
WE'VE ADDRESS THAT THROUGH THE
NET THAT NEXT GEN I'M ONE SYSTEM
IN THE EXISTING NINE ONE SYSTEM.
THE NEXT STEP TO YOUR POINT IS
TO BE ABLE TO ADDRESS THAT ON
PUSHING THE INFORMATION OUT
THRILLER AND WARNINGS.
AND THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE'VE
BEEN WORKING.
IN AT CALLAWAY ASKED TO
IDENTIFY THOSE NEEDS.
IN EVEN ALL THE WAY UP THROUGH
THE FCC.
THROUGH TEXT TRANSLATION AND
FOREIGN LANGUAGE TRANSLATION
THOSE TECHNOLOGIES ARE NEWARK
AND ARE FULLY DEPLOYED BUT THOSE
ARE SOME THINGS WE'RE LOOKING AT
TO GET THAT DATA GOING BACK OUT
IN IN A IN A WAY THAT CAN BE
UNDERSTOOD.
YOU RUN INTO SOME CHARACTER SET
ISSUES WITH SOME OF THE
LANGUAGES THAT YOU CAN IMAGINE
AND THOSE ARE SOME OF THE
CHALLENGES IN THE TECHNOLOGY
SIDE.
AND I AM GLAD THAT THAT THAT
THAT WORK IS HAPPENING BECAUSE
IT FORTY FOUR PERCENT AS WELL AS
BEING NUMBER AND THIS IS AT A
PUBLIC SAFETY ISSUE.
WHEN YOU KNOW WHEN AWAY REALIZE
WHEN A STREET GOT TRANSLATE ELSE
LIKE NO THAT'S NOT WHAT YOU'RE
SUPPOSE TO TRANSLATE THE STREET
NOT THE STREET NAME BECAUSE
THERE IS NO STREET NAME. WITH
THAT TRANSLATION IT'S IN ENGLISH
AND THAT'S WHAT PEOPLE LOOK FOR
AND SO THERE'S ELEMENTS LIKE
THAT THAT ARE VERY IMPORTANT TO
EVERYBODY. I'M IN THAT COMMUNITY
SO I'M I'M GLAD TO HEAR THAT THE
CONVERSATIONS ARE HAVING AND I
HOPE WE DON'T DROP THOSE BECAUSE
THOSE ARE DEFINITELY PART.
THE OF OF OF REALLY IMPORTANT
PART OF HOW WE KEEP THE
COMMUNICATION GOING.
TO THANK YOU MR GRUBER. IS PHONE
UPON SENATOR JACKSON'S COME
ABOUT HARDING WILL SITES OF. YOU
KNOW SAFE YOUR HOME THAT'S READY
FIREPROOF FOR FOUR HOURS
WHEN THE HARD THE SIDES OF THE
CAN DO THAT FOR FOUR EIGHT
HOURS.
AND THEN TALK ABOUT TALK ABOUT
COMMUNICATIONS VERY FOR PORTABLE
RADIO FOR AN OFFICER TO HAVE ON
THEIR HIP.
BEFORE THE DOLLARS APIECE
FOR RADIO FOR REGULAR VEHICLES
ABOUT FIFTY FIVE.
FIVE HUNDRED BUCKS
SO THEY'RE VERY EXPENSIVE MAY
CHANGE
THE FORTY FOUR INDUCTS FOR
PORTABLE RADIO.
SO I GUESS THE ISSUE IS AT SOME
POINT THINGS DO GO DOWN.
I WAS TOLD THERE SOME SYSTEM
WHERE BOUNCES OFF THE
ATMOSPHERE.
ANOTHER COMMUNICATION DEVICE
BECAUSE.
.
THE NET STUFF IS GREAT BUT. I
WAS FOR A BACKUP SO.
WHAT OTHER SYSTEMS ARE OUT
THERE?
IT A RELIABLE AND AFTER A LOT
ABOUT THE ATMOSPHERE ATMOSPHERIC
FANEUIL MUCH ABOUT IT.
PETERSON SOME OF THOSE OTHER
OPTIONS.
YEAH BETWEEN BUDGET I KNOW HE'S
MY TECHNICAL EXPERTS I'M JUST.
THE.
THE TALKING ADDICT VIA.
SO.
YOU KNOW YOUR LAND MOBILE RADIO
THE TRIBUTE TO TALK ABOUT THEIR
IT IS GOING TO CONTINUE THAT IS
GOING TO STAY IN PLACE FOR YOUR
YOU KNOW YOUR OFFICERS AND LOG
FIRE.
THAT'S NOT GOING AWAY ANYTIME
AND SO HOW WE WORK HAND IN HAND
WITH ALL OF THE STATE AGENCIES
THAT WE SUPPORT WITH OUR LAMB
OPERATOR SYSTEM HERE TECH
CALAVERAS THROUGH OUR PUBLIC
SAFETY COMMUNICATIONS.
A DIVISION SO.
AND THOSE ARE PUBLIC SAFETY
GRADE AND AS A BUDGET POINTED
OUT AND WE HAD NO LOSSES FOR ANY
OF OUR FIRED ITS FOR FOR LAND
MOBILE RADIO SYSTEMS THERE. I'M
SO THAT WAS THAT WAS HUGE OF
FORT FIRST HAD NO HAD NO LOSSES
IN. CIVILIAN WE HAD NO LOSSES IN
OUR TOWERS OR STRUCTURE EVEN
THOUGH WE LOST POWER WE HAD YOU
MINUTES MISTER CASES WE HAVE
SEVEN DAYS OF OF.
A FEW ON HAND WERE ABLE TO
CONTINUE TO SUPPORT. AND CAL
FIRE CHP FISHING GAME HOW MANY
LOCAL AGENCIES THAT ARE ARE ARE
HUNG ON OUR SAME.
TOWERS FOR THE STARS APPEARED
THAT THE REASON DISCUSSING IT
YOU USE THAT'S THE THE SAME
NETWORK THAT WE'RE USING MISSILE
HIT LUGER TOWERS BUT WE LOST
CELTA.
CORRECT I GUESS I GUESS IN YOUR
TOWER SUMMER ON PUBLIC BUILDINGS
IN YOUR RURAL AREAS THERE ON
MOUNTAINTOPS SO I GUESS KNOWS
FOR THOSE AREAS WHY DID.
YOUR TOWERS SURVIVED AND NOT
THE.
CELLPHONE TOWERS.
THEY'RE JUST THEY'RE DIFFERENT
GREAT STRUCTURE AND EIGHTEEN T.
IN AND.
CAN REDRESS THAT BEST FOR YOU
HERE BUT THE BUT THE BOTTOM
LINES WERE BUILT WAS A PUBLIC
SAFETY GREAT THAT'S WHAT WE'RE.
ARM ART CHARTERS HIS TO SPORTS
IN PUBLIC SAFETY GRAY.
NETWORK SERVED THIRTY ZAINAL
DIFFERENTLY AND SO THEY CAN THEY
CAN ANSWER THAT FOR YOU BUT I
WILL SAY THAT.
AS WE GOING TO FIRST NET
BECAUSE FIRST IT'S NOT ANY OTHER
TOOL FOR THE OFFICERS ARE OUT
THERE. WILL HAVE THAT CELLPHONE
IN HER HAND BEING ABLE TO USE
THAT LTE NETWORK THAT THEY
CURRENTLY HAVE. AND THEY'RE
GONNA BE ABLE TO USE ALL THESE
VARIOUS APPLICATIONS OTHER GONNA
BE FOR THEM AND SO.
IT IS IMPORTANT OBVIOUSLY WHICH
IS WHY THAT RESILIENCY FOR THAT
NETWORK IS IMPORTANT US TO MAKE
SURE THAT.
THAT THE CARRIERS.
MAKE IT IS RESILIENT AS
POSSIBLE REDUNDANCY AS POSSIBLE
SO THAT. THEY HAVE AN EXTRA TWO
ON THEIR HANDS WE GOTTA MAKE
SURE TOWERS SURVIVED YOU
RECOMMENDING UPGRADING THOSE
TOWERS. IN THOSE AREAS THAT ARE
PRONE TO FIRES. I'M WE
RECOMMENDED THAT.
A SERIES OF OF OF PIECES TO IT
IT'S A YOU KNOW DEBRIS CLEARANCE
FROM THE AREAS.
HARDENING GENERATORS.
HOWARD THE SET UP IN A LOT OF
THE. OTHER THINGS THAT WE BUILD
INTO OUR STRUCTURE OFFICE TODAY
A LOT MORE TOWERS AND WE DO.
BUT NONE THE LESS BECAUSE
THERE'S MICROCELLULAR LARGE
CELLS IN VARIOUS DIFFERENT TYPES
BUT.
OBVIOUSLY THE MORE RESILIENT
THEY ARE THE MORE REDUNDANCY
PASSER OUT THERE TO PICK UP THE
LOAD FOR THEM. A MEANS THAT OUR
FIRST RESPONDER COMMUNITY WILL
HAVE A RELIABLE NETWORK TO USE A
WHEN THEY'RE USING EPO.
I'M ONE OF THE OTHER THINGS
WE'VE DONE IS WE GAVE A LIST OF
BLOCKED SITES THAT SUPPORT
CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE OF OF
THESE ARE CELL SITES THAT ARE
OVER A PUBLIC SAFETY ANSWERING
POINTS. OR OVER SOME
OTHER-MISSION CRITICAL.
POINT THROUGHOUT THE STATE FIVE
HUNDRED SEVENTY ONE OF THOSE
THAT WE GAVE DE TNT THROUGH OUR
ANALYSIS AND THEY COMMITTED TO
HARDENING THOSE AND THAT'S THE
FIRST STEP.
SO YOU CAN IMAGINE THERE ARE
THOUSANDS OF CELL SITES AND
WE'VE ASKED FOR A SMALL PIECE TO
BE HARDENED. REALLY FOR THE
NETWORK TO BE SURVIVABLE TO YOU
KNOW SUPPORT EVERYTHING WE'VE
DISCUSSED HERE TODAY LEON TIRES
THING WOULD NEED TO BE HARDENED
TO ANOTHER LEVEL AND THAT WAS IN
OUR INITIAL ASK.
THAT WE NICK TRIED TO NEGOTIATE
AND SO IT'S SOMETHING THAT
MOVING FORWARD WE KNOW WE'RE
GONNA HAVE TO WORK WITH THEM TO
MAKE SURE THAT THIS NETWORK AND
SURVIVE IN. AND THROUGH THOSE
TWO PIECES IT'S THE POWER INTO
THE SITE.
AND IT'S THE DATA BACK ALL THAT
CONNECTS THE SITE BACK TO THE
YOU KNOW TO THE PIECES THAT ARE
MAKING THE DECISIONS ON WHERE TO
SEND THE CALL. BOTH OF THOSE ARE
WHAT WE'RE WORKING ON THANK YOU.
THINKING OUT WITH A ONE THINK
THE PANELISTS VERY MUCH FOR A
PARTICIPATING GAUGING.
IN THIS CONVERSATION SO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR SERVICE.
.
NOT GONNA MOVE THE NEXT UP.
AND LAST PANEL.
FIRST THEN IT CALIFORNIA'S.
INTEROPERABLE COMMUNICATIONS
SYSTEMS AND THAT WE HAVE THREE
PRESENTATIONS IN THIS ORDER MISS
KENNEDY ON MCNEALY. AND THIS.
ARIANNA CURTIS.
AM GONNA DO THE SAME THING WE'VE
DONE THE PAST.
TEN MINUTES PIECE OF IF.
THEY NEED THAT AMOUNT THE MEMO
GOING TO Q. AND A.
AND THANK YOU THE PANELIST
.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN SANTIAGO A
CHAIRWOMAN JACKSON MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO HEAR
TO BE HERE TODAY.
TO PROVIDE AN OVERVIEW OF THE
FIRST RESPONDER NETWORK
AUTHORITY. AND WITH OUR PRIVATE
SECTOR PARTNER EIGHTEEN T.. AND
WITH THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA HOW
WE INTEND TO DELIVER THE
NATIONWIDE PUBLIC SAFETY
BROADBAND NETWORK OR THE NPS
BEGAN HEARING CALIFORNIA.
I'M JANETTE KENNEDY I AM THE
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS FOR LEAD FOR
ABOUT THE FIRST RESPONDER
NETWORK AUTHORITY.
FOR CALIFORNIA.
LET ME ALSO THE FIRST THING CAL
O. YES DIRECTOR KILLER DUTY
DEPUTY DIRECTOR CRADDICK OF
ITCH.
OF THE TEAM THERE AS WELL AS THE
CALIFORNIA FIRST RESPONDER
NETWORK BOARD.
I OVERTHE LAST FOUR YEARS WE
ENGAGED IN HEAVY CONSULTATION A
TWO TIERED HERMAN THE NEEDS OF
FIRST RESPONDERS. EMERGING YOU
HAD EMERGENCY MANAGERS AND
PUBLIC SAFETY PERSONNEL ACROSS
CALIFORNIA.
YEAH AS THE CULMINATION OF THIS
EFFORT GOVERNOR BROWN OPTED IN
TO FIRST NET.
AND THAT BASICALLY GAVE THE GO
AHEAD FOR THE FIRST RESPONDER
NETWORK AUTHORITY AND EIGHTEEN
T.. TO BEGIN DEPLOYMENT IN
CALIFORNIA.
I AND IS IS WITH THIS RIGOROUS
EFFORT THEM THAT WE CONTINUE TO.
COMMIT TO DIALOGUE AND INCREASED
ACTIVITY NOW THAT WE'RE GOING TO
BEGIN AYE OPERATIONALLY STATION
AND IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
NETWORK.
SO THE FIRST RESPONDER NETWORK
AUTHORITY WAS CREATED BY
CONGRESS IN TWO THOUSAND TWELVE.
AS A RESULT OF ONE OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS OF THE NINE
ELEVEN COMMISSION REPORT.
IN OUR MISSION IS TO ENSURE THE
BUILDING MAINTENANCE DEPLOYMENT
AND OPERATION. OF THIS
NATIONWIDE BROADBAND NETWORK.
AND THAT IT WILL EQUIP FIRST
RESPONDERS WITH THE TOOLS THEY
NEED TO HAVE.
MISSION CRITICAL DATA
COMMUNICATIONS.
AS WE HEARD EARLIER FIRST THAT
IS NOT.
THE LAND MOBILE RADIO NETWORK
THAT. CALIFORNIA STATE OR LOCAL
ENTITIES OPERATE NOR IS IT THE
NEXT GENERATION NINE ONE ONE
NETWORK.
THE FIRST NET NETWORK IS THE
ONLY NATIONWIDE NETWORK WITH
TRUE PRIORITY.
AND RUTHLESS PREEMPTION
DEDICATED TO
PUBLIC SAFETY.
SO AS YOU HEARD WE ENGAGED IN AN
EXTENSIVE CONSULTATION PERIOD.
WITH THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND.
YOU KNOW AND WE ALSO ENGAGED IN
AN OPEN TRANSPARENT COMPETITIVE
BIDDING PROCESS TO FIND IT
NATIONWIDE VENDOR.
AND THAT VENDOR WAS EIGHTEEN T.
SELECTED IN MARCH TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN.
AND THIS CONTRACT WILL BE FOR
TWENTY FIVE YEARS.
SO THIS PUBLIC PRIVATE
PARTNERSHIP TAKES ADVANTAGE OF
OUR RESPECTIVE CORE STRENGTH.
AND ASSETS.
FIRST THAT BRINGS TWENTY
MEGAHERTZ OF SPECTRUM IN THE
SEVEN HUNDRED MEGAHERTZ BAND.
OUR GOVERNMENT OVERSIGHT
RESPONSIBILITIES.
SUCCESS BASED PAYMENTS UP TO SIX
POINT FIVE BILLION DOLLARS
AS WELL AS OUR EXPERTISE IN
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMUNICATIONS.
EIGHTEEN T. IS BRINGING ITS
EXISTING INFRASTRUCTURE.
INCLUDING USE OF ITS LTE BANDS.
FOR PRIORITIZE USED BY PUBLIC
SAFETY.
BRINGS ITS OPERATIONAL AND
TECHNICAL EXPERTISE IN MANAGING
A WIRELESS.
SYSTEM.
AND FINANCIAL STABILITY TO
PERFORM OVER THE LIFE OF THE
CONTRACT.
TO PUT HAVE REALLY SIMPLY FOR
THE MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE
THIS IS A FEDERAL CONTRACT THAT
HAS.
REGULAR ASSESSMENTS AND
DISINCENTIVE.
OPPORTUNITIES IN CASE THERE ARE
FAILURES OUT INTO POINT THE
NETWORK.
AND WITH THE UC CONSULTATION
THAT WE ENGAGE WITH THE STATE.
AS WELL AS.
OF THE LETTER THAT CAME WITH
THE STATE PLAN HERE THERE ARE
CONTRACTUAL OF IT AREAS FOR US
TO BE SURE THAT THE NEEDS OF
CALIFORNIA REMAIN RELEVANT. AND
ARE PART OF THE NETWORK
OPERATION DEPLOYMENT ACROSS THE
STATE.
SO.
NOW THAT WE ARE. GOING INTO THIS
NETWORK WE PREPARED FOR THIS
NETWORK
BY ENGAGING.
EARLY ON WITH FIVE EARLY
BUILDER PROJECTS TO LOOK AT HOW
THIS SPECTRUM COULD BE UTILIZED.
IN THE S. IN THE FUTURE IT'S
C-SPAN.
SO HERE IN CALIFORNIA OF THE LOS
ANGELES REGIONAL INTEROPERABLE
COMMUNICATIONS SYSTEM OR LA REX.
OPERATED IN EARLY BUILDER LTE
PROJECT USING OUR SPECTRUM AND
TESTED SEVERAL KEY LEARNING.
OPPORTUNITIES.
I WITH THE LESSONS LEARNED FROM
LA REX AND THE OTHER AT A EARLY
BUILDING PROJECTS WE GRANT
CRITICAL KNOWLEDGE TO MAKE THE
ROLLOUT OF THE GUEST YES BEEN
SUCCESSFUL.
AND SINCE OUR PARTNERSHIP WITH
EIGHTEEN HE WAS VILIFIED JUST
ABOUT A YEAR AGO.
YOU KNOW WE GAUGE HEAVILY WITH
EIGHTEEN TEACH FOR THE
DEVELOPMENT OF A STATE PLAN.
AND THIS STATE PLAN INCLUDES THE
BUILD OUT FOR THE RADIO ACCESS
NETWORK OR THE RAN
INFRASTRUCTURE ACROSS ALL OF THE
FIFTY SIX STATES AND TERRITORIES
THAT ARE. WE WILL. INTEND TO
SERVE.
SO DURING THIS PROCESS OF THE
STATES WERE ABLE TO REVIEW
PLANS.
I MAKE COMMENTS AND WHERE
FEASIBLE.
WE INTEGRATED THOSE.
.
RECOMMENDATIONS AND SUGGESTIONS
AND THEY ARE REFLECTED IN THE
FINAL INPUT OF THE STATE PLAN.
ONCE THE FIRST RESPONDER NETWORK
AUTHORITY PROVIDE OFFICIAL
NOTICE TO THE PLAN. GOVERNORS
HAD NINETY DAYS BY STATUTE.
TO MAKE THE DECISION A WHETHER
THEY WOULD PARTICIPATE IN THE
FIRST NET PROGRAM. IN WHICH CASE
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IN
EIGHTEEN T..
PROVIDES THE FUNDING AND PAYS
FOR THE DEPLOYMENT OF THE RAN.
IN THE STATE CALIFORNIA.
AND THAT'S OFTEN OR WHETHER OR
NOT THE STATE WOULD OPT OUT IN
WHICH CASE OF THE GOVERNOR.
WOULD BASICALLY COMMIT THE STATE
TO DEPLOYING THAT RAN.
I AND OPERATE THE NETWORK.
AND MAINTAIN THE NETWORK FOR THE
NEXT TWENTY FIVE YEARS.
SO ON DECEMBER TWENTY EIGHTH TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN GOVERNOR
BROWN CHOSE TO OPT IN.
SO FIRST THAT IN EIGHTEEN T.
WILL PROCEED TO BUILD.
THE.
AND PSP AND IN CALIFORNIA FOR
CALIFORNIA'S FIRST RESPONDERS.
SO IN ADDITION TO PROVIDING
UNFETTERED UNINTERRUPTED NETWORK
ACCESS TO FIRST RESPONDERS.
FIRST NET WILL HELP IMPROVE
RESPONSE TIMES AND SITUATION
AWARENESS.
SO THIS INCLUDES APPLICATIONS
OTHER LOCATION SERVICES YOU CAN
SEND TEXT MESSAGES SEND VIDEO.
YIELD TEN MAPPING INFORMATION.
ALL THESE TYPES THE DIFFERENT
SERVICES THAT ARE CURRENTLY NOT
NECESSARILY A.
A WIDELY ADOPTED TODAY IN
URGENCY COMMUNICATIONS AND
RESPONSE.
SO THE NETWORK TECHNOLOGY WILL
ALSO BE TESTED AND VALIDATED
THROUGH WITH THE FIRST RESPONDER
NETWORK AUTHORITY INNOVATION AND
TEST LAB LOCATED IN BOULDER
COLORADO.
THIS IS INTO THIS IS TO ENSURE
THAT FIRST RESPONDERS HAVE
RELIABLE TOOLS AT THE PUBLIC
SAFETY GRADE.
.
OPERATE APPLICATIONS THAT THEY
NEED TO PERFORM THEIR JOBS
TODAY.
I WAS SO YOU KNOW I THINK THERE
ARE A COUPLE QUESTIONS.
REGARDING DIRECTOR KILLER
TUCCI'S LETTER I THINK THAT WE
HAD ADDRESSED IN THE PREVIOUS
SESSION AND OUTRAGEOUS LIES TALK
A LITTLE BIT ABOUT.
SOME OF THOSE THREE AREAS SO
INTER OPERABILITY.
WE ALREADY HAVE VOICE
INTERCONNECTION TODAY SO YOU CAN
MAKE YOUR OWN A CELL PHONE CALL
FROM ONE CARRIER TOGETHER ONE
AND THAT WORKS FINE.
IN TERMS OF APPLICATIONS YOU
KNOW YOU DO HAVE APPLICATIONS
THAT ALREADY WORK ACROSS
DIFFERENT CARRIERS.
BUT WHAT WE'RE DOING HERE IS
FIRST THAT IS WE'RE LOOKING AT.
SPECIFIC APPLICATIONS.
HA.
FOR FIRST THAT SUBSCRIBERS THAT
WOULD BE INCLUDED THAT HAVE
PUBLIC SAFETY FEATURES LIKE
MISSION CRITICAL PUSH TO TALK.
AND YOU KNOW ALL THIS IS GOING
TO BE SANDERS SPACE.
SO ANYONE THAT WANTS TO YOU KNOW
USE THE STANDARDS WILL BE ABLE
TO USE. TO CREATE THOSE TYPES OF
APPLICATIONS.
BUT THOSE ARE THE TYPES OF
FEATURES THAT PERCENT IS REALLY
DRIVING ACROSS.
ON THE NETWORK AND HAVING OUR
NETWORK IN THE RELIABILITY
SUPPORT THOSE FEATURES FOR FIRST
NET USERS.
IN TERMS OF SITE HARDENING.
WE DO HAVE AS PART OF OUR
CONTRACT WITH THE TNT SPECIFIC
REQUIREMENTS THAT AND AROUND
SECURITY THAT'S PHYSICAL
SECURITY AS WELL AS
CYBERSECURITY.
BECAUSE I KNOW CALIFORNIA HAS.
.
AS A NUMBER AS WE HEARD ABOUT
FROM THE FIRST PANEL BUT ALSO.
IN THE SECOND A NUMBER OF YOU
KNOW VERY TREMENDOUS.
.
PUBLIC SAFETY EVENTS.
IN RESPONSE REQUIREMENTS AND SO
THOSE OF ADDITIONAL DISCUSSIONS
WE HAD THE WITH THE STATE WERE
ALSO INCLUDED AS AS PART OF THE
STATE PLAN. IN A SIDE LETTER.
AND I AM HAPPY TO REPORT THAT
THIS MORNING WE FIRST SET AND
EIGHTEEN T. ANNOUNCED THAT.
WE WILL BEGIN THE ACTUAL
DEPLOYMENT OF NETWORK WHICH
MEANS THAT THOSE DOCUMENTS IN
THOSE ITEMS THAT WERE INCLUDED
AS PART OF STATE PLAN HAVE BEEN
CODIFIED IN NOW IS PART OF THE
PLAN OF RECORD.
TO START DEPLOYING IN CALIFORNIA
SO I THINK THE SHOWS THAT THE
PROCESS WHEREBY THE INPUT FROM
THE STATE AND FIRST RESPONDERS.
CAN BE PUT AS PART AND WILL BE
ACTED UPON AND ACTIONABLE.
THROUGH THIS CONTRACT.
AND THE LAST QUESTION IS ON
SECURITY. AND I THINK TO DAILY
WE ALREADY HAVE SOLUTIONS IN
PLACE.
DAY AS FAR AS I UNDERSTAND TO
SEE JUST INFORMATION. THAT
ENTITY.
I USUALLY HAVE TO BE CERTIFIED
THROUGH THEIR STATE. AND LET'S
AGENCY.
ON AND THAT'S A SYSTEM WHERE AND
I YOU KNOW WE'RE NOT GOING TO
CHANGE.
THERE WOULD THE CERTIFICATION
PROCESS BY FIRST HAVING FIRST
THAT ITSELF. FLATTENED AREA
WHERE YOU KNOW THAT THE ENTITY
THAT IS REQUESTING INFORMATION.
AND WHAT'S TO USE THAT
INFORMATION MOST OF YOU KNOW
THAT'S STILL GOING TO BE MANAGED
BY THE LOCAL ENTITY AND THE
LOCAL ENTITIES REQUIREMENTS TO
MEET THE FBI REQUIREMENTS.
SO I THINK IT'S A LITTLE BIT
MORE COMPLICATED.
COM THAN THAT THERE ARE OTHER
SOLUTIONS AVAILABLE AND IN THE
FUTURE THERE MAY BE NO OTHER
SOLUTIONS OTHER THAN.
THAT MOTION BUT THAT'S WHAT WE
HAVE TODAY SO IT OVER THE LIFE
OF OUR CONTRACT WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THE STATE AND OTHER
STATES EMAIL.
.
AND OUR AND OTHER PARTNERS.
TO LOOK AT SOLUTIONS ON HOW TO
MAKE THAT EASIER BUT.
IT'S FAR IS GOING THROUGH UPON
WHAT WE HAVE TODAY A YOU KNOW
THIS IS THE STATE OF
CONVERSATION AND.
HOW WE INTEND TO MOVE FORWARD?
SO IN CONCLUSION NOW THAT FIRST
THAT HAS OPTED IN. A YOU KNOW WE
COMMIT TO CONTINUE CONSULTATION
WITH THE STATE TO ENSURE THAT IT
MEETS THE NEEDS OF CALIFORNIA'S
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMUNITY. AND
WHILE THERE MAY BE MANY
CHALLENGES AHEAD OF US WITH
COVERAGE AND. I IMPROVED.
DEPLOYMENT SPEEDS YOU KNOW
CALIFORNIA HAS A HIGH DEMAND A
RELENTLESS.
NEED FOR RELIABILITY AND
COVERAGE AND THAT WILL CONTINUE
TO BE A DRIVER IN OUR PROGRAM.
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME TODAY IN NEW LOOK FOR TEN
THE QUESTION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SWIMMINGLY
YEAH CON GOOD AFTERNOON ASSEMBLY
MAN THAT'S AND IAGO SENATOR
JACKSON AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS KEN MCNEELY
AND PRESIDENT OF EIGHTEEN TO
CALIFORNIA AND I'M.
HERE TO UPDATE THE COMMITTEE ON
THE PROGRESS A TNT IS MAKING AND
WORKING WITH ITS FIRST NET
PARTNERS TO PROVIDE NATIONWIDE
BROADBAND NETWORK FOR PUBLIC
SAFETY.
THIS IS OURS HISTORIC TWENTY
FIVE YEAR PRIVATE PRIVATE PUBLIC
PARTNERSHIP LEADING TO AN
UNPRECEDENTED INVESTMENT IN
TELECOMMUNICATIONS
INFRASTRUCTURE. MAKING PUBLIC
SAFETY A PRIORITY IN CALIFORNIA
AND ACROSS THE NATION.
THIS INVESTMENT IN THE BILL
ABOUT SUPPORTING IT IS EXPECTED
TO CREATE TEN THOUSAND U. S.
JOBS OVER THE NEXT TEN YEARS.
THESE NEW JOBS WILL INCLUDE
POSITIONS IN TECHNOLOGY
DEVELOPMENT.
NETWORK DEPLOYMENT IN
OPERATIONS.
A TNT HAS A ONE HUNDRED AND
FORTY YEAR HISTORY OF INVESTMENT
IN CALIFORNIA AND LONG STANDING
COMMITMENT TO SERVING
CALIFORNIA'S PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMUNITY.
WE ARE FULLY COMMITTED TO
DELIVERING DEDICATED
INTEROPERABLE NETWORK THAT WILL
GIVE CALIFORNIA FIRST RESPONDERS
AND FIRST RESPONDERS ACROSS THE
NATION. THE TECHNOLOGY THEY NEED
TO COMMUNICATE AND COLLABORATE
ACROSS AGENCIES AND
JURISDICTIONS DURING EMERGENCY
RESPONSES.
THIS OPPORTUNITY ALLIANCE WITH
OUR HISTORY OF SERVING
CALIFORNIA'S PUBLIC.
SO SAFETY COMMUNITY.
I'D ALSO LIKE TO TAKE TO I THINK
THE GOVERNOR AND HIS STAFF OF
PARTICULARLY THE DIRECTOR OF.
รณ WE AYE CALIFORNIA OH YES.
GET A.
GIL.
GILLER DUTY AND HIS STAFF.
THEY WORK TIRELESSLY ON THIS
EFFORT AND I'D LIKE TO THANK
THEM FOR THEIR PART IN THEM IN
THE FIRST ADOPTED PROCESS HERE
IN CALIFORNIA.
A TNT IS HONORED TO HAVE BEEN
CHOSEN TO BUILD AND MANAGE AT
THE FIRST NET NETWORK AND WE ARE
COMMITTED TO BRINGING TO BEAR
ALL THE NECESSARY RESOURCES TO
ENSURE ITS SUCCESS.
JUST AS CONGRESS ENVISIONED WHAT
DOES THIS MEAN.
FIRST AS PART OF ITS COMMITMENT
A TNT WILL SPANNED FORTY BILLION
DOLLARS OVER THE LIFE OF FIRST
NET TO CONTRACT TO BUILD OPERATE
AND MAINTAIN THE NETWORK.
A TNT WILL CONNECT FIRST NAT TO
ITS TELECOMMUNICATIONS NETWORK
VALUED AT OVER ONE HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY BILLION DOLLARS.
SECOND.
A TNT WILL SUPPORT FIRST THAT
WITH ITS WORLD CLASS DISASTER
RECOVERY INDIE OUR TEAM IF
YOU'VE HAD A CHANCE TO TO SEE
THAT IN ACTION HERE IN
SACRAMENTO.
THIS TEAM WHICH WAS ESTABLISHED
OVER TWENTY FIVE YEARS AGO HAS A
SINGLE MISSION.
TO RECOVER EIGHTEEN T. VOICE AND
DATA SERVICES IN AREAS AFFECTED
BY DISASTER.
THE INDY OUR SOLUTIONS COMBINES
NETWORK INFRASTRUCTURE AND
SUPPORT TRAILERS RECOVERING
ENGINEERING SOFTWARE
APPLICATIONS AND THE RESPONSE
TEAM WITH BOTH FULL TIME AND
VOLUNTEER MEMBERS FROM EIGHTEEN
ANTI.
TEAM MEMBERS HAVE SPENT MORE
THAN ONE HUNDRED AND THIRTY
THOUSAND HOURS WORKING ON FILLED
EXERCISES AND DEPLOYMENTS OF THE
LAST TWO DECADES.
THESE CAPABILITIES ARE DEDICATED
NETWORK TEAM WILL WILL ALL BE
AVAILABLE TO SUPPORT COMMUNITIES
AND FIRST RESPONDERS AFFECTED BY
EMERGENCIES.
AND WE WILL INCREASE OUR
EXTENSIVE CALIFORNIA FLEET OF
MOBILE ASSETS WITH THE PLOY
DOUBLES.
EXCLUSIVELY DEDICATED TO TO
SUPPORT FIRST AT.
THE NETWORK WILL GET FIRST
RESPONDERS PRIORITY
AND BY A POOR EIGHTY I'M
PRIORITY I MEAN THAT IN TIMES OF
EMERGENCY IS A NETWORK
CONGESTION OUR NETWORK WILL GIVE
FIRST RESPONDER COMMUNICATIONS
PRECEDENT.
AND FOR PRIMARY FIRE POLICE.
AND EMERGENCY MEDICAL USERS
DESIGNATED BY LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS PREEMPT ALL OTHER
COMMUNICATIONS
TOGETHER THESE CAPABILITIES WILL
BETTER CONNECT FIRST RESPONDERS
TO THE CRITICAL INFORMATION THEY
NEED IN AN EMERGENCY.
IN ADDITION
FIRST NAT AND EIGHTEEN T. WILL
ELEVATE AND EVOLVE THAT NETWORK
TO BENEFIT PUBLIC SAFETY.
BECAUSE THE FIRST NET IS
DESIGNED TO ADVANCE WITH THE
SPEED OF TECHNOLOGY.
THESE ADVANCES CAN MAKE A REAL
DIFFERENCE IN CRISIS SITUATIONS
FOR EXAMPLE PROVIDING EMERGENCY
PERSONNEL INFORMATION ON TRAFFIC
CONDITIONS TO HELP DETERMINE THE
BEST ROUTE TO AN EMERGENCY. CAN
HELP SAVE CRITICAL MINUTES FOR
FIRST RESPONDERS TO GET TO AN
EMERGENCY.
OTHER ENHANCED CAPABILITIES SUCH
AS WE ARE BILL SENSORS AND
CAMERAS FOR POLICE AND
FIREFIGHTERS CAN DELIVER IN
THEIR REAR TALK. REAL TIME
IMAGES OF EVENTS SUCH AS FIRES
FLOODS ARE CRIMES
EIGHTEEN T. IS AT THE FOREFRONT
OF THE INTERNET OF THINGS AND
ADVANCES IN SMALL SMART CITIES
TECHNOLOGY THAT CAN MONITOR
CITIES CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE.
TRAFFIC AND LISTEN TO AND LISTEN
FOR GUNSHOTS.
TODAYFIRST RESPONDERS WHO ADOPT
FIRST NAT AS THEIR PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMUNICATIONS SERVICE WILL
OVERSEE PRIORITY AND PREEMPTION
OVER THE NETWORK LOCAL CONTROL
IT DEDICATED CUSTOMER CARE AND
ACCESS TO FIRST NET APP STORE.
AFTER NEXT MONTH WHEN THE FIRST
NIGHT CORPS GOES LIVEPUBLIC
SAFETY WILL HAVE ACCESS TO THE
FULL BREADTH OF THE FIRST NET
NETWORK IN SERVICE.
INCLUDING DEDICATED FIRST NET
CORPS QUALITY OF SERVICE
PRIORITY WITH PRIORITY LEVELS
INCIDENT COMMAND UP LEFT AND END
TO END SECURITY AND ENCRYPTION.
AND FACT CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
SAFETY AGENCIES HAVE STARTED TO
MIGRATE THEIR COMMUNICATION
SYSTEMS TO FORCE NET.
THESE EARLY ADOPTERS ARE
CURRENTLY USING FIRST DEBT
SERVICE IS OVER THE EIGHTEEN T.
COMMERCIAL NETWORK AND
ANTICIPATION OF THE FIRST NET
CORPS LAUNCH NEXT MONTH.
PUBLIC SAFETY ENTITIES IN THE
TAHOE AREA KINGS COUNTY TULARE
COUNTY AND OTHERS ALREADY USING
THIS REVOLUTIONARY NETWORK AND
SERVICE.
AS WE MAKE THIS INVESTMENT. IT
IS WITH OUR COMMITMENT TO
MEETING AND EXCEEDING ALL
REQUIREMENTS TO SUBCONTRACT WORK
TO VETERANS MINORITY OWNED AND
WOMEN OWNED BUSINESSES.
A TNT IS AMONG THE LEADING
COMPANIES IN IDENTIFYING AND
DOING BUSINESS WITH DIVERSE
SUPPLIERS.
LAST YEAR WE SPENT FOURTEEN
POINT TWO BILLION DOLLARS WITH
THE DIVERSE SUPPLIERS
REPRESENTING NEARLY NINETEEN
PERCENT OF OUR TOTAL SUPPLIER
EXPENDITURES WE HAVE BEEN RANKED
NUMBER ONE FOR THREE CONSECUTIVE
YEARS AND DIVERSITY ING SUPPLIER
DIVERSITY SURVEY.
A TNT STANDS COMMITTED TO PUBLIC
SAFETY IN CALIFORNIA ACROSS THE
NATION AS EVIDENCED BY AMONG
OTHER THINGS I WANT ARE ONE
HUNDRED AND FORTY EIGHT FORTIETH
YEAR HISTORY SERVING. CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMUNITY AND OUR
TWENTY FIVE YEAR PUBLIC PRIVATE
PARTNERSHIP WITH FIRST RESPONDER
NETWORK AUTHORITY TO PROVIDE THE
UNIQUE NETWORKING SERVICES.
THROUGH OUR WORK WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AND CAL ONLY
AS WE HAVE COMMITTED TO
PROVIDING A SOLUTION THAT WILL
SUPPORT PUBLIC SAFETY MISSION
CRITICAL DATA FOR THE NEXT
SEVERAL DECADES HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
A TNT WILL WORK WITH STATE
LEADERSHIP AS WE CONTINUE TO
DEVELOP AND IMPLEMENT INNOVATIVE
SOLUTIONS TO DELIVER THE FIRST
NET NETWORK AND SERVICES TO THE
PUBLIC.
AND ENTITIES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA.
IN CONCLUSION EIGHTEEN T. COULD
NOT BE MORE EXCITED ABOUT
DELIVERING ON THE PROMISE IS A
FIRST NET TO THE BENEFIT OF
CALIFORNIANS HORSES BINDERS AND
THE COMMUNITIES WE SERVE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD AFTERNOON A CHAIR JACKSON
THINK YOU VERY MUCH CHAIR
SANTIAGO AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
FOR ALLOWING ME THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SHARE. THE LA RICK STORY WITH
YOU.
FOR THOSE OF YOU THAT DON'T KNOW
A LOT ABOUT OUR PROJECT LA REX'S
THE LOS ANGELES REGIONAL
INTEROPERABLE COMMUNICATIONS
SYSTEM.
IT'S A SYSTEM THAT IS CURRENTLY
OPERATING IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY
WITH PUBLIC SAFETY USERS
UTILIZING THE SYSTEM WHICH IS
DEDICATED LTE SYSTEM. FOR THEIR
USE AS A PRIORITY.
IT PROVIDES USERS THE ABILITY.
FOR DATA DAY COMMUNICATION
SERVICE SAYS AS WELL AS VIDEO
AND DATA ACCESS.
NOW WHAT WERE SOME OF THE GOALS
OF LA REX AND HAVE WE
ACCOMPLISHED THEM.
WHAT IS THE GOAL THEN WHAT IS
THE PATH FORWARD FOR LA RAKES IN
THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY REGION?
SOME OF THE GOALS THAT'LL LA
WORKS ENVISIONED WHEN WE STOOD
UP.
THE AUTHORITY AND BEGAN.
AWARDING THE CONTRACT FOR THE
DEPLOYMENT OF THE LYRICS IN ONLY
COUNTY WAS TO ELIMINATE THE
EXISTING BARRIERS.
OF COMMUNICATIONS THAT EXISTED
FOR PUBLIC SAFETY USERS.
WE WANTED TO ELIMINATE THE
BARRIERS TO ALLOW PUBLIC SAFETY
TO EXPRESS
ANY INFORMATION THAT THEY NEEDED
TO COMMUNICATE TO EACH OTHER. IN
THE VERY.
VARIOUS DIFFERENT FORMATS
BE AT DATA VIDEO.
VOICE WHICH THEY HAVE PICTURES
TELEMETRY MAPPING LOCATION
SERVICES.
WE DIDN'T WANNA LIMIT AND
OPERABILITY TO VOICE ONLY.
ELLIE REX IS CURRENTLY DEPLOYING
A LAND MOBILE RADIO SYSTEM AS
WELL AND THE LA COUNTY REGION.
BUT WE UNDERSTOOD THE NEED OF
INTER OPERABILITY BETWEEN THE
LAND MOBILE RADIO SYSTEM.
THE. PSP AND SYSTEM THE LTE
SYSTEM NOW AND THE END PSP AND
SYSTEM. AS WELL AS AN
OPERABILITY WITH OTHER
COMMERCIAL CARRIERS.
ANOTHER GOAL FOR LA RAKES IN THE
REGION WAS
TO HAVE A RELIABLE STANDALONE
COVERAGE.
THE GREATER LA AREA AS MANY OF
YOU NOW IS OF THE MOST DIVERSE.
THE GEOGRAPHICAL AREA IN THE
NATION.
EFFECTIVE COMMUNICATION FOR
PUBLIC SAFETY USERS SHOULD NOT
BE RESTRICTED BECAUSE OF THIS
DIVERSE GEOGRAPHICAL AREA.
AND SO THE GOAL FOR LA RICK'S IS
TO PROVIDE. RELIABLE INAUDIBLE
COMMUNICATIONS THROUGHOUT THE
FOUR THOUSAND PLUS SQUARE MILES
IN LA COUNTY.
THAT INCLUDED THE BASE AND THE
VALLEY.
THE DESERT'S THE MOUNTAINS THE
FOREST AS WELL AS CATALINA
ISLAND.
WE ALSO WANTED TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
SAFETY WITH COMMUNICATIONS THAT
IMPROVE TO THEIR SITUATIONAL
AWARENESS.
FACILITATE A COMMON OPERATIONAL
PICTURE WHICH A LOT OF YOU SPOKE
TO TODAY.
OUR GOAL WAS TO SEEK TOOLS AND
APPLICATIONS WHICH WOULD IMPROVE
THAT SICHUAN SITUATIONAL
AWARENESS.
FOR USERS WHILE PROVIDING.
COMMON OPERATIONAL PICTURE TO
ENHANCE UNDERSTANDING.
COOPERATION AND COORDINATION.
RESPONSE AMONGST FIRST AND
SECONDARY RESPONDERS WHEN
NEEDED.
WHAT IS NEXT FRAWLEY REX NOW
THAT WE HAVE THE FIRST NAT I'LL?
AWARDED TO EIGHTEEN ANTI.
ELYRICS HAS FORMED A STRONG
PARTNERSHIP WITH FIRST NET AND A
TNT. OVER THE. US OPEN LAST
YEAR'S WITH FIRST NET AZZA A
USER OF THEIR SPECTRUM.
AND OVER THE LAST YEAR WITH A
TNT SINCE ONE OF THE CONTRACT.
AND EIGHT R. ELYRICS HAS
FORMALLY SUBMITTED A REQUEST TO
THE FEDERAL GRAND TOUR.
TO TRANSFER THE LA RICK'S ASSETS
TO AND EIGHTEEN ANTI FOR
INCLUSION IN THE NATIONAL
DEPLOYMENT.
HOWEVER WE ARE NOT HANDING OVER
THE KEYS AND WALKING AWAY FROM
THE REGIONAL COMMUNICATIONS.
WE'VE ACTUALLY.
AS A AS A ONE OF THE OTHER
CONDITIONS ARE ONE OF THE S.
STIPULATIONS IN THIS ASSET
TRANSFER AGREEMENT EIGHTEEN
ANTI.
LA REX'S ACTUALLY SUBMITTED A
PLAN AND REQUEST
FOR THE REMAINING BALANCE OF
FEDERAL GRANT FUNDS THAT WERE
ORIGINALLY APPROPRIATED TO LA
BRICKS IT'S APPROXIMATELY THIRTY
FOUR MILLION DOLLARS.
SO THAT WE BAY CONTINUE WITH THE
DEPLOYMENT CONTINUE WITH AN
EXPANSION OF REGIONAL
COMMUNICATIONS AND ALI COUNTY.
THAT PLAN THAT WE SUBMITTED TO
THE FEDERAL GRAND TOUR INCLUDES
THREE MAIN OBJECTIVES WHICH WERE
WORKING CLOSELY WITH A TNT. A TO
ENSURE SUCCESS AND INTEGRATION
INTO THE NATIONAL NETWORK.
THOSE THREE OBJECTIVES INCLUDE
COVERAGE AUGMENTATION.
SO WE WILL BE IMPLEMENTING A
SECOND WAVE OF SITES THAT ARE
DESIGNED TO SPECIFICALLY ADDRESS
AREAS WHERE EIGHTEEN T. AND L.
A. REX'S OF CURRENT COVERAGE.
OR EXPECT EXPERIENCING EITHER
DIFFICULT IN COVERAGE OR
CAPACITY.
WE ARE ALSO REQUESTING AWARD OF
FUNDS TO PURCHASE MAINTAIN AND
DEPLOY RAPID RESPONSE VEHICLES
THOSE ARE FAST REACTIONS
SATELLITE TRUCKS THERE CALLED
COLTS.
UNITS THAT HAVE BECOME NOW MORE
IMPORTANT NOW.
THAT EIGHTEEN TO SUBSTANTIAL
FIXED.
THAT'S.
SITES HAVE BEEN ESTABLISHED THE
COVERAGE ISSUES EXPERIENCED.
STILL REMAIN UNCERTAIN URBAN
AREAS AS YOU'VE MENTIONED AND
THE AND HAVE TOUCHED UPON TODAY
IN CONNECTION WITH THE FIRES AND
MUD SLIDES.
THE NEED TO RESPOND TO PUBLIC
SAFETY INCIDENTS BOTH WITHIN THE
URBAN AREA BUT ALSO IN THE CITY
IN THE.
SUBSTANTIAL EVENTS THAT HAPPEN
OUTSIDE OF THE URBAN AREA. IS
SIGNIFICANT AND THUS WERE
PROPOSING A.
THE SELLING LIGHT TRUCKS THAT
WILL ALLOW US TO DEPLOY.
REGIONALLY.
TO AREAS WHERE THERE MAY BE
ISSUES WITH COVERAGE UNDER
CAPACITY.
AND THEN THE THIRD OBJECTIVE
THAT WE'VE PROPOSED.
IS.
APPLICATIONS AND PROBABILITY.
THE PURPOSE.
OF BUILDING THE NATIONAL PUBLIC
SAFETY BROADBAND NETWORK IS TO
UNITE COMMUNICATION AND PROVIDE
AN INTEROPERABLE PLATFORM FOR
PUBLIC SAFETY THROUGHOUT THE
COUNTRY.
A SOLUTION HOWEVER REQUIRES BOTH
NETWORK AND APPLICATION
INTEROPERABLE LADY.
FIRST MEDI TNT AT ARE
IMPLEMENTING THE NETWORK
PLATFORM AS YOU'VE HEARD TODAY.
FOR WORKING TO PROVIDE AN
APPLICATION ECOSYSTEM WHERE THE
HOSTED ENVIRONMENT A WOULD BE
AVAILABLE FOR USERS FOR
APPLICATIONS.
THE AUTHORITY THE LA RICK'S
AUTHORITY.
I BELIEVE THAT WE HAVE ARE AT
THE FOREFRONT OF PUBLIC SAFETY
APPLICATION DEVELOPMENT AND ARE
WELL POSITIONED. TO NOT ONLY
TEST FUNCTIONALITY OF THESE
APPLICATIONS BUT ALSO GOVERNANCE
STRUCTURE. THAT WILL ENSURE THE
IN ARBIL. IN OPPORTUNITY AMONGST
ITS USERS.
THAT REQUEST FOR I GRANT
AUGMENTATION IS CURRENTLY WITH
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. AYE AND
SO WE AWAIT.
TO APPROVALS WON APPROVAL FROM
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT FOR THE
FORMAL ACID TRANSFER OF THE LA
RICK'S IT THE FIFTEEN SYSTEM TO
A TNT. AS WELL AS APPROVAL LOVE
THE AROUND TO PLAN WE CALL THAT
FOR THE REGIONAL DEPLOYMENT AND
ALI BRICKS TO AUGMENT THE
EXISTING.
DEPLOYMENT.
THANK YOU I KNEW US SENATE
JACKSON HAD A QUESTION AND IF
ANY OTHER MEMBERS HAVE A
QUESTION THAT I MOVE.
A FINANCE OF MISS RODRIGUEZ
AFTER THINKING.
I DO HAVE A FEW QUESTIONS.
THIS IS A HUGE CONTRACT I HOPE
I STILL OWNED STOCK IN EIGHTEEN
T..
.
SO.
THE FIRST QUESTION BOMB.
THIS IS A TWENTY FIVE YEAR
CONTRACT WITH
THERE ANY METRICS OR ANY.
REQUIREMENTS THAT HAVE TO BE
MET IN ORDER FOR THE CONTRACT TO
CONTINUE.
AND WHAT ARE THOSE AND WHO WILL
BE DECIDING WHETHER OR NOT.
THOSE METRICS ARE BEING MET.
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION.
SO THERE COUPLE DIFFERENT OF
WAYS WE CAN MAKE SURE THAT YOU
KNOW THE CONTRACT IS BEING OUT
FOLLOWED IT HERE TOO SO FIRST OF
ALL IT IS A FEDERAL CONTRACT.
AYE THERE ARE PROCUREMENT
OFFICERS FROM BOTH SIDES
MANAGING THE CONTRACT MAKING
SURE THAT YOU WE ISSUE
APPROPRIATE TASK ORDERS AND
THERE'S YOU KNOW APPROPRIATE
FOLLOW UP TO ENSURE THAT THOSE
TASK ORDERS ARE THOSE TASKS ARE
PERFORMED.
AS PART OF.
WHAT WAS IN THE REQUEST FOR
PROPOSAL AS FAR AS THE STRUCTURE
OF THIS BECAUSE A?
CONTRACT ARE THERE DIFFERENT
NUMBERS OF.
ASSESSMENTS THAT COULD BE MADE
SO FIRST OF ALL ARE. THE
DEPLOYMENT TARGETS
SO.
.
ANY VENDOR AND THIS WAS
CONDUCTED IN AN OPEN TRANSPARENT
PROCESS.
PRIOR TO EVEN RELEASING THE RFP
WE HELD TO INDUSTRY DAYS THERE
WERE SEVERAL PUBLIC NOTICES.
ASKING THE COMMUNITY HOW THEY
WOULD LIKE TO SEE THIS YOU KNOW.
RP BELT AND THEN THE NATURE OF
THE CONTRACT.
SO PUBLICITY AND INDUSTRY HAVE
AN OPPORTUNITY TO COMMENT ON
THAT.
SO IN THE FINAL ARE P. WE
LOOKED THAT PRIMARILY TWO
DIFFERENT WAYS FOR ASSESSMENT
THE FIRST IS THE ACTUAL
DEPLOYMENT OF THE NETWORK. HOW
MUCH OF THE POPULATION COVERAGE
WILL THE VENDOR BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE?
WHETHER THAT WOULD BE BANNED
FOURTEEN THAT'S THE FIRST THAT
SPECTRUM THE TWENTY MEGAHERTZ OF
SPECTRUM THAT THERE BE USING.
BUT ALSO ANY NON BAND FOURTEEN.
IMPLEMENTATIONS OR OPERATION.
SO EVERY VENDOR THAT SUBMITTED A
BID.
HOW TO SHOW US HOW THEY WOULD
BUILD OUT AND TO WHAT DEGREE
THEY WOULD BUILD OUT THE NETWORK
NATIONWIDE?
ON THE SECOND IS ADOPTION
TARGETS SOLD THE WAY CONGRESS
ENVISIONED OUR PROGRAM YOU KNOW
WE DIDN'T WANT TO JUST BUILD IT
AND THEN IT ALL JUST LANGUISH IN
NOBODY'S ACTION CAN USE IT.
SO FIRST THAT CREATES AT THE
FIRST RESPONDER NETWORK
AUTHORITY THEN CREATED ARE ASKED
BIDDERS TO PROVIDE WHAT IS THERE
PROJECTED ADOPTION TARGETS TO
MEET THE NETWORK.
NEEDS AND SHOW THAT THIS IS
ACTUALLY A VIABLE COMPETITIVE
PRODUCT FOR PUBLIC SAFETY.
SO IN THE CONTRACT THERE WILL BE
ANNUAL ASSESSMENTS ON WHETHER OR
NOT THE EIGHTEEN T. HAS MET THE
BUILD. OBLIGATIONS BUT ALSO
ADOPTION TARGETS.
AND WITHIN THAT STRUCTURE.
THERE IS ALSO THIS DISTANCE THE
RECALL AND DISINCENTIVE PAYMENTS
SO AS I MENTIONED BEFORE OUT WE
ARE PROVIDING UP TO SIX POINT
FIVE BILLION DOLLARS EIGHTEEN
T..
SHOULD ANY OF THOSE.
METRICS NOT BE MET THEN THE
PAYMENTS WILL BE.
NOT TREATED BASICALLY.
TO EIGHTEEN T..
COM SECOND AS THE FEDERAL KIND
OF ENTITY LEVEL ON IN TEN YEARS
FROM TWO THOUSAND ALSO TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY TWO IN THE
GOVERNMENT IF ACCOUNTABILITY
OFFICE WILL WRITE A REPORT ON
WHETHER OR NOT WE'RE MEETING ARM
XIN. ON AND MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS.
THERE SO IF WE ARE NOT MAKING.
ANY OF OUR TARGETS WERE
ACTUALLY MEETING THE NEEDS OF
PUBLIC SAFETY AND CONGRESS. THEN
THERE WOULD BE SOME SORT OF
REVIEW BY CONGRESS OF HOW DO.
HE'LL WORK WITH FIRSTHAND MOVING
FOR IT AFTER THAT.
SO.
IF I COULD.
.
I JUST.
YOU'VE GOT MATRIX BUT.
ITEM WHICH IS KIND OF BAR DOWN
LOW BUT. IF PHAM IF FIRST THAT
USES THE ELEMENTS OF EIGHTEEN
TEAS COMMERCIAL CELLULAR NETWORK
WHICH
I ASSUME IS PART OF THIS
PROCESS.
AND PART OF THAT NETWORK RESIDES
IN THE HILLS ABOVE OUR
COMMUNITIES AND WE ARE ON LIKE
KANSAS AND OTHER STATES WHERE
THEY DON'T HAVE HILLS.
BUT WE DO WHEN OUR HILLS TEN
BURNED.
.
YOU KNOW WHAT WE SAW THE
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA WE SAW IT OF
AT THE THOMAS FIRE. AYE IS IN
THAT SYSTEM VULNERABLE TO
WIDESPREAD OUTAGES AND HOW YOU
HOW YOU GONNA PLAN TO.
EIGHTEEN T. HOW ARE YOU GOING
TO PLANNED TO ADDRESS THAT
BECAUSE THAT'S WHERE A LOT OF
YOUR SYSTEM IS. IN CALIFORNIA.
SYSTEM IS STATEWIDE BUT YES I WE
PART OF THE PERSON THAT.
CONTRACT ANTICIPATES
SIGNIFICANT BUILD OUT
SIGNIFICANT BUILD OUT FOR
ADDITIONAL COVERAGE AND FOR
HARDENING OF THE OF THE NETWORK
THAT.
THAT HAD BEEN TALKED ABOUT
EARLIER I THINK SENATOR I GO I
CURRY ASKED.
YOUR.
OUR COLLEAGUES AT CAL OH YES
WHAT TOOK SO LONG IN THE
NEGOTIATIONS TO.
LEADING UP TO THIS OP ED AND
I'D ALL ALL START OUT BY SAYING
YOU HAVE VERY GOOD
REPRESENTATIVES REPRESENTING THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA ENSURING
THAT YOU'RE GETTING THE BEST.
THAT WERE ABLE TO OFFER FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA THEY THEY
YOU THEY KNOW VERY INTIMATELY.
THE UNIQUE NEEDS OF THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA AND THEY AND THEY
ARE.
NEGOTIATING QUITE WELL ON YOUR
BEHALF AND THAT NEGOTIATION IS
INCLUDES AS THEY STATE THAT
SIGNIFICANT RESOURCES BEING
DEPLOYED TOWARDS HEARTENING THAT
WORKS IN ANTICIPATION THAT MANY
OF THESE.
CELL TOWERS MIGHT BE VULNERABLE
TO FIRES.
SO WE CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
THEM HUNDREDS OF THESE NEW TELL
A. THOUSAND.
I THOUSAND.
PLUS TOWERS OUGHT TO BE BUILT
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TO AUGMENT THE IS THE
EXISTING NETWORK AND MANY OF
THOSE. HEARTENING TO THE
STANDARDS THAT THEY HAVE THEY
HAVE NEGOTIATED IN CONTRACT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY ARE IN FACT.
RESILIENT.
BECAUSE OF THE UNIQUE NEEDS AND
THE ENVIRONMENT OF CALIFORNIA.
SO IT WILL FIRST NET INSURER
THAT OR ADVOCATE THAT EIGHTEEN
TEAM MEET THE REQUIREMENTS THAT
WERE LISTED IN. MR GILLER DO
CHEESE LETTER WITH RESPECT TO
THESE ISSUES THOSE THREE AREAS.
OBVIOUSLY HE WAS VERY HAPPY. AYE
THAT THESE HAD NOT BEEN RESOLVED
IN THE TIME IT RIGHT NOW I MEAN.
IT'S ONE OF THOSE SORT OF
HOBSON'S CHOICE WILL GET COME
DIVE IT OR PARTICIPATE IN A
NATIONAL SYSTEM I WILL THROW SIX
POINT FIVE BILLION DOLLARS INTO
THE POT. OR CHOOSE NOT TO WHEN
YOU'RE ON YOUR OWN RIGHT MEAN
YEAH I MEAN.
FIRST THE THE FIRST RESPONDER
NETWORK AUTHORITY COULD HAVE
EASILY SPENT SIX POINT FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS HERE JUST IN
CALIFORNIA BUT WE HAVE A A
NATIONWIDE PROGRAM.
THE STATE PLAN THAT POLICIES
RECEIVED WERE.
A DEPICTION OF WHAT THE FIRST
NET NETWORK WILL BE IN THE FIRST
INITIAL PHASE OF.
DEPLOYMENT SO REALLY WHAT THAT
IS IS BASICALLY WHAT THEY'RE
LOOKING AT FOR THE FIRST FIVE
YEARS OF THE TWENTY FIVE YEAR
CONTRACT.
SO THIS IS NOT THIS IS TO SAY
THAT WHAT ALL THIS EACH RECEIVED
IS NOT THE FINAL AND ONLY AND
POINT IN WHAT THE. AND PSP AND
WILL LOOK LIKE SO THEY'LL BE
ADDITIONAL OPPORTUNITIES TO
INCREASE
OF THE COVER AND THERE WILL BE
AN EIGHTEEN T. IS JUST THE
REGULAR COURSE OF BUSINESS WILL
BE AUGMENTING ENDING. BUILDING
CAPACITY TO THEIR NETWORK MUCH
APPRECIATE BUT WILL YOU ON
BEHALF OF FIRST NAT.
EITHER ENSURE ADVOCATE THAT
EIGHTEEN T. MEET THESE
REQUIREMENTS BECAUSE YES THAT
ANSWER OKAY AT A GOOD ANSWER
ADDITIONAL SENATE I I THINK I
HAVE TO SAY THAT. THERE ALSO
PENALTIES THAT ARE IN PLACE.
HAS WON THE CONTRACT IN
ASSUMING THAT ANY PEOPLE TO
NETWORK AND NO ONE SHOWS UP I
MEAN SO WE HAVE AN OBLIGATION TO
SATISFY OUR CUSTOMER AND AND.
IN ORDER TO.
INSURE USAGE OF THE NETWORK OR
PENALTIES WILL BE PAID BY
EIGHTEEN T.
SURE AN AND I APPRECIATE THAT WE
CHOSETO YOU KNOW WE'VE. WE'VE
HAD A NUMBER OF HEARINGS WE'VE
TALKED ABOUT SOME OF
CALIFORNIA'S NEEDS FOR
RESILIENCY IN REDUNDANCY AND PRE
POSITIONING THESE ARE ALL THINGS
THAT ARE CRITICAL TO SAVING
LIVES IN THIS CALIFORNIA. THESE
APART THE LESSONS THAT GOD FOR
BID WE'VE HAD TO LEARN AND I
JUST
I'M CONCERNED THAT. THIS IS A
NATIONWIDE PROGRAM EVERY STATE
HAS ITS OWN SET OF ISSUES WE'VE
SEEN WHAT SOME OF THEM ARE IN
CALIFORNIA.
DIRECTED KILLER DO CHIA
ARTICULATED THEM I THINK FAIRLY
EMPHATICALLY IN WELL AND I JUST.
SO FOR THE MONEY IN THE
CONTRIBUTION AND THE
EXPECTATIONS OF THE PEOPLE
CALIFORNIANS IMPORTANT. I THINK
TO ALL OF US AND CERTAINLY. I
GUESS I CAN ONLY SPEAK FOR
MYSELF THAT WE IMPLEMENT.
THIS PROGRAM IN A WAY THAT'S
GOING TO MEET THOSE NEEDS AS
WE'VE SEEN THEM THROUGH THESE
VARIOUS.
TRAGIC EVENTS IN AND
CATASTROPHES THAT WE'VE
EXPERIENCED OVER THE COURSE OF
TIME SO I'M PLEASED TO HEAR THAT
AND AND I DO APPRECIATE THAT.
EIGHTEEN TIAS.
YOU KNOW WORKING ON THIS SOME
STATES THOUGH IT HAD BETTER
SYSTEMS IN PLACE THAN OTHERS
CALIFORNIA HAS PROBABLY BEEN IN
THE LEAD NATIONWIDE IN TERMS OF.
OUR OF MANAGEMENT OF OF THESE.
DISASTER OF VANCE XIN IN BETWEEN
THE FLOODING IN THE WILDFIRES IN
THE EARTHQUAKES THAT WE HAVE WE
BEEN PRETTY MUCH ON TOP OF THIS
AND SO THE LAST QUESTION IS.
WILL THE FIRST NET NETWORK
UNDER EIGHTEEN TEE ABBY PUBLIC
SAFETY GRADE GIVEN THAT I LA
RICK'S. รณ NETWORK.
THAT EIGHTEEN TIAS AQUIRED IS A
PUBLIC SAFETY GRADE HOW ARE YOU
GOING TO BE ABLE ARE YOU GOING
TO COMMIT TO THAT AS WELL. WELL
WE'RE WE'RE COMMITTING TO WORK
WITH TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
CAL AWAY AS TO IDENTIFY THOSE
SITES THAT THEY BELIEVE TO BE.
TO BE.
ARE REQUIRED TO BE OF F A TO
BE HARDENED.
AND YES WE'VE COMMITTED TO
HARDING THOSE SITES.
GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU.
MISS RODRIGUEZ FOLLOWED BY A.
THIS GAINES.
SUCH JUST QUESTION REGARDING.
WITH.
WITH THIS NEXT GENERATION OF
COMMUNICATIONS.
AS OUR WAY WOULDN'T GUARANTEE
THAT OFFICE YOU WOULD KNOWS WHAT
HAPPENED WITH THE
FLOODS THE FIRES THE
EARTHQUAKES.
SO THE SYSTEM WILL GO DOWN
VENTURE THE CELL TOWERS NAM
LINES INTERNET. IS DURING AWAY
WE CAN GO TO MAINTAIN
COMMUNICATION WHEN WORST CASE
AND ARE ALL THAT STUFF GOES
DOWN.
CAN WE MAINTAIN. COMMUNICATION
WITH OF ALL SYSTEMS GO DOWN IS
OR SOME TYPE OF BACKUP PLAN.
I KNOW WE WE TALK ABOUT THEY
HAVE THEIR.
RESPONSE.
TRUCKS BEAN GOT THERE AND SET UP
BUT THE MEANTIME AND
EVERYTHING'S WIPED OUT BECAUSE
OF THE FIRE THE FLUTTERED
EARTHQUAKE.
IS OUR WAY WE CAN STILL
MAINTAIN.
WITHOUT INTERRUPTION.
OR WILL THE REAR IS OUR
TECHNOLOGY FOR THE.
THEY THINK YOU FOR THE QUESTION
THIS ORDER I GUESS.
IN YOU KNOW IT'S IMPOSSIBLE TO
ANTICIPATE. WHATEVER COULD
HAPPEN BUT I ASSURE YOU THAT
AGAIN.
THOSE NEGOTIATING ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA CERTAINLY ARE TRYING
TO ANTICIPATE THE MANY DISASTERS
THAT CAN AND WILL ACCORD HAVE
OCCURRED IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
WE'VE BEEN WORKING VERY CLOSELY
HAND IN GLOVE WITH THEM FOR A
NUMBER OF YEARS AND CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THEM GOING FOR IT AND
SOME OF THE WORK SOME OF THE THE
HARDENING THAT A SENATOR
JACKSON'S JUST MENTIONED IS
BEING DONE THAT HELPS THAT'S
PART OF THE SOLUTION. PART OF
THE SOLUTION ALSO NEGOTIATED BY
YOUR REPRESENTATIVES A CALLER WE
ASK AS A LARGER.
NUMBER OF DEPLOYED UNITS.
THE AND AND MOST STATES HAVE
UNDERSTANDING THE PROPENSITY FOR
NATURAL DISASTERS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA SO THAT'S ANOTHER WAY
OF LOOKING AT THE RESILIENCY OF
THE NETWORK TO ENSURE THAT TIME
DOUBT IS MINIMIZE. ANOTHER THAT
AGAIN YOUR NEGOTIATORS ARE ARE
ARE AYE I'VE BEEN SUPPORTING AS
WELL IS ADDITIONAL.
SUPPORT.
GENERATORS AROUND NETWORKED AYE
EQUIPMENT THAT WE'RE WORKING
WITH THEM ON AS WELL SO THERE
ARE A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT.
ALTERNATIVES IN ADDITION TO
JUST BUILDING OUT MORE CAPACITY
IN GENERAL THESE ALL WORK
TOGETHER IN COMBINATION TO
ENSURE THAT OUT ITS TIMES ARE
CUT TO AN ANIMAL. CAN WE ENSURE
THAT THERE IS NEVER EVER GOING
TO BE AN OUTAGE KNOW WHAT WE CAN
ENSURE THAT WHEN WE DO HAVE AN
OUTAGE IT'S GOING TO BE AS
MINIMAL AS POSSIBLE AND
IMPACTING THE PUBLIC SAFETY OF
THE COMMUNITY.
AND WITHOUT SAID IS OUR WAY WE
COULD.
MINIMIZE THAT IMPACT OR WE HAVE.
MAYBE SOME CERTAIN TYPES OF
GUIDELINES THAT WITHIN. AN AREA
THAT WHEN EVERYTHING GOES DOWN
WORST CASE SCENARIO THAT. WITHIN
FOUR TO SIX HOURS ON OUR THAT
WILL HAVE THE BACK UP WITH
THERE'S THE GENERATOR WITH THE
TRUCKS THE MOBILE TRUCKS OUT
THERE SET UP SO COMMUNICATIONS
COULD BE. UP AND RUNNING ESERVER
ANYTHING TALK ABOUT. COMING UP
WITH THE PLAN AYE RESPONSE TIME
FOR.
THOSE ARE SERVICES TAKEOVER DO
YOU KNOW IF THERE'S THAT WHILE I
KNOW WE WE ARE SO WE ARE
CERTAINLY WORKING ON.
AND.
AND BACK UP GENERATOR TIME.
YEAH HOW LONG WILL IT HOW WE'RE
RUN WITHOUT ELECTRICITY FOR
INSTANCE OF COURSE IN INSTANCES
WHERE THE ENTIRE ENTIRE TOWERS
DOWN CERTAINLY THERE THEY'RE
GONNA BE CHALLENGES THEY ARE BUT
WE CONTINUE TO WORK WITH.
WITH YOUR REPRESENTATIVES ON
THOSE KINDS OF ISSUES TO
INTERMENT TO AGAIN ENSURE THAT
WE HAVE MEANT AS AN.
AS MINIMAL A LOSS AS POSSIBLE.
CREE YEAH THANK YOU.
TO THE PANELISTS I APPRECIATE
YOUR OR YOUR INPUT TODAY AND.
I WAS JUST WONDERING IF.
.
MISTER MCNEALY MIGHT BE ABLE TO
HELP ME.
WITH ISSUES RELATED MY DISTRICT
I'VE GOT A VERY RURAL DISTRICTS
NORTHEASTERN CALIFORNIA.
TWENTY SEVEN THOUSAND SQUARE
MILES.
THAT'S ALMOST SEVEN TIMES CITED
SIZE LA COUNTY GEOGRAPHICALLY.
AND A LOT A LOT OF WELL
WILDFIRE EXPOSURE LOT OF
FORESTS.
AND SO I'M JUST TRYING TO GET.
CLARITY IN TERMS OF THE
HARDENING ASPECT.
WOULD YOU MIND EXPANDING A
LITTLE BIT IN TERMS OF WHAT THAT
MEANS AND THEN.
IS THERE ALSO GOING TO BE.
.
MORE MORE BUT DEFAULT.
FEATURE SO THAT IN THE EVENT
THAT YOU HAVE.
A TARA GO DOWN.
.
WE MIGHT HAVE MORE MORE TOWERS
PER SQUARE MILE OR WHATEVER.
SO THAT IN THE EVENT YOU HAVE A
A SMALLER REGIONAL FIRE.
YOU STILL HAVE COMMUNICATION
ABILITY.
BECAUSE.
OF THE DIP HAVE.
NATURE OF THE INFRASTRUCTURE.
SURE CHERISH THE GAINES I THINK
ONE OF THE.
I THINK GOT SENATOR JACKSON USE
THE TERM.
.
WHEN I GO I USE THE TERM HARDING
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT PUBLIC
SAFETY GREAT I THINK SENATOR
JACKSON USE THAT TERM.
THOSE ARE THE KINDS OF THINGS
YES WE'RE NEGOTIATING WITH CAL
WE ASKED TO ENSURE THAT AT LEAST
IN PARTICULAR AREAS WHERE THEY
BELIEVE THERE ARE SIGNIFICANT
VULNERABILITIES YES.
WE'RE GOING TO WE'RE GOING TO
LOOK AT.
HARDENING IN THAT FASHION THEIR
AND THEIR NUMBER OF WAYS WHEN WE
TALK ABOUT HARDENING.
IT IT IT IT.
THAT SIMPLY MEANS THAT THEIR
HOURS.
SIGNIFICANTLY MORE.
PROTECTIONS AROUND THAT
PARTICULAR PHYSICAL STRUCTURE
THAT MIGHT MAKE IT MORE
RESILIENT TO.
ACTS OF GOD FOR INSTANCE.
BUT TO I ALSO ADDRESS YOUR IT
DO YOUR YOUR CONCERNS ABOUT THE
TO CLEAN RURAL PARTS OF
CALIFORNIA.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO UNDERSTAND
THAT THIS PROGRAM WORKS HAND IN
HAND WITH ANOTHER FEDERAL
PROGRAM THAT EIGHTEEN TO HAVE
BUILT ITSELF UP AND THAT'S THE
CAL ADAPT THE.
CAN'T TO THE.
AND.
THE DEAD APPROACH THAT OUT
ALLOWS FOR ADDITIONAL DEPLOYMENT
OF BROADBAND INTO WORLD AREAS OF
OF THE STATE.
.
ACROSS THE COUNTRY AND AND THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA IN
CALIFORNIA ALONE.
WE'RE GOING TO BE LOOKING AT AN
ADDITIONAL ONE HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND A WORLD HOUSEHOLDS THAT
WILL BE COVERED BY THIS BILL DOT
AS WELL WHICH IS HAPPENING
SIMULTANEOUSLY TO THE BUILD OUT.
OF.
UNDER.
UNDER OF THE FIRST THAT PROGRAM
AS WELL SO WHEN WE TALK IN TERMS
OF THE ABILITY TO CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE COVERAGE FOR YOU THIS IS
PART OF THE REDUNDANCY PICTURE
THAT WE'RE TRYING TO PUT
TOGETHER TO ENSURE THAT.
PARTICULAR RURAL PARTS OF THE
STATE IF ONE TOWER GOES DOWN YES
WE CAN REROUTE IN FACT IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA AND SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA FIRES WE WERE ABLE TO
REROUTE A SUBSTANTIAL NUMBER OF.
OF OF.
OF OF CALLS ARE FROM TOWERS
THAT HAD GONE DOWN PARTICULARLY
WHERE THE FIBER HAS NOT THE
FIBER BACK CALL IS NOT BEEN
IMPLICATED WE CAN REROUTE
INSTANTANEOUSLY AND THAT
TYPICALLY HAPPENS WITHIN THE
FIRST HOUR. GREAT WONDERFUL I'M
EXCITED ABOUT THE FUTURE IN THE
OPPORTUNITY WHERE WE CAN MAKE
THIS MUCH MORE ROBUST AND.
HOPEFULLY.
USE BETTER MANAGEMENT.
PRACTICES FOR FOREST'S IT'S ALL
INTEGRATED AND.
.
I THINK THIS IS A WAKE UP CALL.
FOR US AS LEGISLATORS SO.
THANK YOU I APPRECIATE. YOUR
GREAT ADVICE.
MISTER COOPER IS A FEW COMMENTS
ON THINK THE PANEL AND I I DO
YOU FOLLOW UP ON SENATOR
JACKSON'S COMMENTS. THESE
IMPORTANT HARD THE SITES AND
HARDEN INTO LAW ENFORCEMENT
GRADE.
HER PUBLIC SAFETY GRAY SPECIALLY
IN THE RURAL SITES OBVIOUSLY
IT'S A RIB BERMAN SITES. GIVEN
EARTHQUAKES ALL DIFFERENT ANIMAL
BUT FOR FIRES OF NOT RULE AREA
INGALLS HARDENED SITES
DEFINITELY HELP YOU KNOW BIG
ISSUE THE TALK ABOUT QUIT SINCE
THE JUST ON.
IN A DISASTER.
I REALLY DON'T CARE ABOUT
RUNNING SOMEBODY FOR RECORDS
CHECKS IF SOMEONE'S WARRANTS ARE
FBI INFORMATION AT THAT POINT
YOU ABOUT PUBLIC SAFETY SO. I
ALLOW FOLKS WANT THAT THAT'S
IMPORTANT.
I KNOW LA COUNTY IS GOING TO
HAVE THE BACKUP SYSTEM
I'VE BEEN TOLD.
OH YES NO REALLY AS THE
QUESTION.
A CELL SITES GO DOWN.
WHAT IS A BACKUP IN WE KNOW? WAS
CELL SITES EIGHTEEN DOES A GREAT
JOB BUT.
THINGS HAPPEN SO THAT YOUR FROM
FIRST NET.
IF IT GOES DOWN WHAT IS OUR BACK
IT WOULD WE.
WE DEPEND UPON AND I I I TALK
ABOUT THE ONLY THING NOT TO
REPLACE IT BUT AS A BACKUP.
TO THIS THE SYSTEM SO YOU TALK
ABOUT THAT'S AND SO YES DIDN'T
ADDRESS AT ALL.
WELL I'LL I'LL I'LL START BY
SAYING THAT AGAIN.
THE THEM THE MOBILE NETWORK IS
ONE OF THE MOST RESILIENT
NETWORKS THE DIGITAL MOBILE
NETWORK IS ONE OF THE MOST
RESILIENT NETWORK THAT WE HAVE
IN THE ABILITY TO BE ABLE TO.
TO.
OF ALL SLOW TRAFFIC FROM ONE
SIDE TO ANOTHER IS ACTUALLY
QUITE SIGNIFICANT AND WITH
ADVANCED TECHNOLOGIES IT'S CALL
ACTUALLY GOING TO GET BETTER SO
THE PROVISION OF ONE. THAT THE
DEPLOYED UNITS THE NUMBER THE
SIGNIFICANT NUMBER DEPLOYED
UNITS THAT CALL WE HAS HAS
NEGOTIATED FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA PROVIDE SUBSTANTIAL
BACK UP BUT THE OR.
OPPORTUNITIES
FOR FOR THE STATE.
AS WELL AS THE ADDITIONAL
NUMBER OF CELL SITES THAT
THEY'VE.
ALSO.
NEGOTIATED THAT ALLOWS FOR
BETTER COVERAGE AND INTO
COVERAGE IN THESE AREAS SO THAT
IF ONE SIDE GOES DOWN IT MAKES
IT EASIER TO OFFLOAD THAT
TRAFFIC ON TO ANOTHER SITE SO
THESE ARE THE KINDS OF THINGS
THAT YOU'RE REPRESENTATIVES HAVE
NEGOTIATED AND AN ANTICIPATED.
OKAY THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
ASK ANY QUESTIONS OF COMMENTS.
ONE THINK PANELIST STUFF FOR
YOUR TIME AND UP PARTICIPATING
THIS CONVERSATION THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
NOW WE'RE GONNA OPEN UP THE
PUBLIC COMMENTS THAT YOU MADE
LINEUP.
IF THERE ARE ANY.
WHAT I ASK FOR A BRIEF BRIEF?
OUR COMMENTS THANK YOU ALONG
WITH THEIR LONG HEARING
UNDERSTAND CHRIS FORESIGHT WITH
OP EXTREMES.
WE ARE A WOMAN OWNED.
SATELLITE COMMUNICATION COMPANY
AT A CLOVIS CALIFORNIA. FOR
ABOUT THE LAST SIX YEARS WE'VE
BEEN FOCUSING ON A MOBILE
OPERATING SATELLITE EMERGENCY
SYSTEM.
LIKE FIVE BY EIGHT WAYS FOURTEEN
HUNDRED POUNDS YOU DROP IT
ANYWHERE YOU FLIP THE SWITCH IN
FIFTEEN MINUTES. YEAH UP TO A
NINE HUNDRED SQUARE MILE
COMMUNICATIONS BUBBLE IT'S
INTEROPERABLE DON'T ASK ME HOW
IT ALL WORKS.
THAT'S FOR THE TECHIE PEOPLE
AYE WE THINK WE ARE A SOLUTION
TO SOME OF OUR INFRASTRUCTURE
CONCERNS THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT HERE WE HAVE AN
INFRASTRUCTURE DEPENDENT
EMERGENCY COMMUNICATIONS SYSTEM.
I WE CANNOT EIGHTEEN T. CANNOT
ALLOW FOR EVERY EVENTUALITY
EARTHQUAKES MUDSLIDES ACTS OF
NATURE HURRICANES ETCETERA. I WE
HAVE THIS PRODUCT IN THE FIELD
TEXAS FORESTRY USES IT. THEY
USED IT IN A HURRICANES ARE MATT
AND I ARE VERY SUCCESSFUL THEY
LOVE BUT THAT WAS ACTUALLY A
FIRST GENERATION MODEL.
OUR LATEST.
MODELS DO MUCH MORE THAN THAT
MODEL.
AND WE LOVE TO ENTER INTO A
CONVERSATION ABOUT HOW THAT CAN
BE ANOTHER TOOL IN THE TOOLBOX
FOR THOSE CIRCUMSTANCES WHERE.
IF YOU BURN DOWN SEVENTY SEVEN
POWER YOUR EMERGENCY ALERT SPARK
GOING TO GET WHAT THEY NEED TO
GO REGARDLESS OF HOW ORGANIZED
AND COHERENT.
THEY ARE AND SO WE NEED MORE
TOOLS IN OUR COMMUNICATIONS TOOL
BOX AND WE WOULD ENCOURAGE THE
CONVERSATION TO LOOK AT NEW
TECHNOLOGIES ALL LIKE ARTS IS
NOT NEW BUT IT'S NEW TO OTHERS.
SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME PUSH
IT.
THANK YOU AND YOUR PUBLIC
COMMENTS.
IN THAT CASE LIKE A.
I BY BAST LE MY CO CHAIR HERE IF
THERE'S ANY FINAL COMMENTS.
I I VERY MUCH APPRECIATED THE
DISCUSSION I LOOK FORWARD TO
SEEING HOW THE RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN OUR STATE.
YES AND OF THIS NEW SYSTEM
INVOLVE CLEARLY THERE'S WORK TO
BE DONE AND APPRECIATE WHAT
SOUNDS LIKE A GOOD FAITH EFFORT
SO. LOOK FORWARD TO HEARING MORE
AND WANT TO THANK THE CHAIR AND
HIS STAFF AND ALL THOSE.
COLLEAGUES WHO HAVE A IN MY
STAFF AS WELL FOR. OTHER
DILIGENCE THIS IS CRITICAL TO
CALIFORNIA FOR THE NUMBER ONE
JOB OF GOVERNMENT IS TO PROTECT
THE SAFETY AND SECURITY OF ITS
PEOPLE.
AND WHILE WE'RE HAVING TO
ADDRESS CLIMATE CHANGE AND ITS
IMPACTS ON OUR.
WHETHER IN AYE NOTE NOW MY HOME
STATE OF MASSACHUSETTS IS
UNDERGOING IT A SECOND NOR
EASTER IN THE COURSE OF A WEEK.
AND.
THE DRAMATIC WEATHER PATTERNS
WERE SAYING IS RESULT OF CLIMATE
CHANGE HOPEFULLY WILL ADDRESS
THOSE CAUSES.
AND REALIZED THAT WE'VE GOT TO
REDUCE OUR RELIANCE ON THE KINDS
OF FOSSIL FUELS THAT ARE
CREATING THIS HAVOC. THAT THEN
COMES DOWN TO OUR NEED TO.
I SPEND ENORMOUS AMOUNTS OF
MONEY TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC IT'S
SOMETHING THAT AT THIS POINT WE
ARE. HAVING TO DO.
AND I'M GLAD THAT WE'RE HAVING
THESE CONVERSATIONS AND
APPRECIATE THE GOOD WORK OF THIS
COMMITTEE. A IN DOING SO SO WITH
THAT I WILL. AGAIN THANK YOU FOR
HOLDING THIS HEARING.
I THINK YOU US CENTER FOR PART
RING WITH THIS AND.
.
AND THEN NOW SERIES OF TO.
COMMITTEE HEARINGS THAT WE'RE
GONNA I THINK ALL THE MEMBERS
WHO.
WHO ARE HERE TODAY AND ENGAGED?
AB TYPES AND A LOT OF COMMITTEE
HEARINGS AND AND NOT SEEN THAT
MANY MEMBERS WALKING AND NOW A
VERY MANY AND THE TICKLING GATE
TO THE LEVEL OF. CONVERSATION
THAT WE DID TODAY SO.
OF WERE FORTUNATE TO HAVE THAT
SORT PARTICIPATION IN THIS AND
OBVIOUSLY ALL THE PANELISTS WHO
PARTICIPATED TODAY.
IT'S.
I'M ENCOURAGED BY THE
CONVERSATIONS.
.
ALSO SAT IN THAT WE HAVE TO
HAVE.
DISASTERS AND THOSE ARE THINGS
THAT WE CAN'T PLAN FOR. HOW AS
WE'VE SEEN ON THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SO WE NOW KNOW THAT
IS IN A MATTER OF OF THE IF IT'S
A MATTER WHEN IT HAPPENS AND?
WE COULD TO KEEP THE
CONVERSATION GOING TO ENSURE
THAT WE HAVE THE BEST A RESPONSE
IS THE BEST PREPARATION AND THE
BEST COMMUNICATION POSSIBLE
BETWEEN. OUR FIRST RESPONDERS
AND THE PUBLIC SO THINK THANK
YOU ALL FOR PARTICIPATING TODAY
AT LOOK FOR THE NEXT ONE THANK
YOU